BUDGET COMMITTEE SUB SIX
HEARING WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING
THE OVERVIEW OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S TWENTY TWENTY-
BUDGET AGREEMENT. SO AS AS YOU
ALL KNOW WELL WE'VE DONE THIS-
WE'VE GOT A SUB SIX HEARING NOW
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT TIME SO
THIS HEARING IS. USING
TECHNOLOGY WE ARE ALL FULL
RESPECTING SOCIAL DISTANCE
WHICH IS WHY WERE PART. WE HAVE
FOR A PUBLIC TESTIMONY
AVAILABLE DOWNSTAIRS IN THE- ON
THE FIRST FLOOR OF THE
LEGISLATURE BUT OF COURSE IF
PEOPLE ARE HERE WE WILL BE
TAKING THAT. PEOPLE DON'T WANT
TO APPEAR IN THE BODY THAT
SUBTLY FIND WE HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT AVAILABLE BY TELEPHONE
AS WELL. SO WE HAVE- WE'RE
ALLOWING ONE MINUTE OF PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WHICH IS WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING FOR SINCE- OR
HEARINGS HAVE STARTED SINCE.
APRIL WE HAVE MR PANIC IN THE
ALLEY- STAFF AVAILABLE AS WELL
AS WELL S WE HAVE. MR IVEY'S
ANYTHING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS WELL AS HIS STAFF.
OR I ASSUME STAFF IS AVAILABLE
BY PHONE AS WELL THANK YOU-
JUST TO GIVE PEOPLE THE PHONE
NUMBER FOR CALLING IN THE
NUMBERS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
IN THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO I
ASSUME THAT NUMBER'S BEING
POSTED AS WE LIVE STREAM. IS
THAT CORRECT I'M JUST LOOKING
FOR CONFIRMATION- ALSO YOU CAN
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE HEARING
A GENDER FOR A BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE SIX IF YOU JUST.
SEARCH FOR CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE LOOK
FOR SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER SIX THE
WEBSITE ARE YOU COULD ALSO GIVE
US ANY FEEDBACK YOU WANT
THROUGH THE INTERNET. YOU CAN
SEND EMAILS TO- BUDGET SUB SIX
BUDGET S. U. B. SIX AT ASM DOT
C. A. DOT GOV IF YOU HAVE ANY
TROUBLE CONNECTING BY TELEPHONE
FEEL FREE. TO CALL THE
COMMITTEE OFFICE AT THREE ONE
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE.
TWO ZERO NINE NINE. AGAIN I
WILL STOP BY THE STORE BY COLOR
ROLE. MR TEN. ARAMBULA BLOOM
MISTER COOPER HERE MISTER FONG
KILEY. MR MCCARTY. A STROLL T.
DOCTOR EVER. SO GOOD JUST- GO
REVIEW VERY QUICKLY WITH THE
AGENDA IS AFTER OPENING
COMMENTS BY ANY MEMBERS WE THE
PANEL TODAY WHERE WE HAVE THE
LA- PROVIDING ANALYSIS WE ALSO
HAVE ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THEN WE GO TO A NUMBER
OF QUESTIONS AND THEN WE'LL GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. SO AGAIN
JUST VERY QUICKLY- TODAY WE ARE
PRESENTING THE LEGISLATURE'S
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET- THE
LEGISLATURE'S TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET BUILT ON THE
ARCHITECTURE FROM THE GOVERNOR
SO WE ALSO HAVE A TRIGGER THAT
IS DEPENDENT ON FEDERAL
FUNDING. WE ARE VERY CLEAR THAT
WE CAN'T GO GO THIS ALONE SO WE
ARE ASKING WASHINGTON DC FOR
HELP HOW WITH OUR- TO FOR WORK
WITH HOLD OFF MANY OF THE CUTS
THAT WERE. ORIGINALLY PROPOSED-
THEY'RE NOT IN THE TRIGGER AS
WELL AS THEY ARE NOT- PROPOSED
CUTS SO IN TERMS OF. CUTS THAT
WERE ORIGINALLY PROPOSED MAY
REVISED TO CHILD CARE EDUCATION
HEALTH CARE- SENIORS FAMILIES
MANY OF THOSE CUTS DO NOT ARE
NOT IN OUR TRIGGER- WITHIN THE
TRIGGER WE DO HAVE DEFERRALS TO
EDUCATION. WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THAT THE- KEY THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WILL STILL BE
ALLOWED TO SPEND THE MONEY THIS
IS MONEY THAT IS OFFERED AT OFF
FOR A LATER DATE. IF THE
FEDERAL FUNDING DOES NOT
COMMAND THERE ARE TRIGGER CUTS
TO YOU SEE CSU AS WELL AS TO
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. ON AT A TIME
WHEN PEOPLE NEED GOVERNMENT THE
MOST WE THOUGHT IT WAS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO NOT CUT
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES- MANY
OF THE SOCIAL SAFETY NET
SERVICES THAT ARE VERY QUORUM.
TO PEOPLE WHO AT TIMES OF FULL
EMPLOYMENT WERE READY LIVING ON
THE EDGE FOR THE MILLIONS OF
FAMILIES WHO APPLIED FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT. WHO ALREADY WERE
WERE STRUGGLING WHEN THEY WERE
WORKING FULL TIME. WE KNOW IT'S
OBSOLETE CRITICAL TO KEEP THEM
IN THEIR HOMES IT'S CRITICAL TO
BE ABLE TO OFFER THE SOCIAL
SAFETY NET SERVICES SUCH AS CAL
WORKS CAL FRESH MEDI CAL.
CRITICAL CRITICAL SUPPORT
SERVICES TO MAKE SURE THEIR
FOOD SHELTER AND HEALTH CARE
ALSO- WE AGREED THAT WE NEEDED
TO. BE RESPONSIBLE AND LOOK AT
A REVENUE PROPOSAL WE THOUGHT
THAT THE- REVIEW PROPOSAL
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNMENT A
GOVERNOR MADE SENSE- SUSPENDING.
CORD TMPORARILY SUSPENDING
CORPORATE TAX DEDUCTIONS FOR A
COUPLE YEARS- MADE A LOT OF
SENSE IN TERMS OF GENERATING
OVER FOUR BILLION DOLLARS OF
REVENUE. IF WE DIDN'T I
GENERATE THIS FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS OF REVENUE THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO CUT- SCHOOLS
AGAIN BY ALMOST TWO BILLION. AS
WELL AS LOOKING AYE CUTTING
HEALTH CARE AS WELL AS SOME OF
THE OTHER. FIFTEEN AT SERVICES
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT THE SO
MANY FAMILIES AND SENIORS ARE
RELYING ON- AGAIN OVER HALF OF.
THE GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
GOES TO EDUCATION STARTED FROM
EARLY EDUCATION UP TO HIGHER
EDUCATION- WITHOUT IS VERY
CRITICAL TO PRESERVE THAT.
SPENDING WE INSURED THAT NOT
ONLY WE PRESERVE THE SPENDING
BUT THEY WERE SMALL COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENTS TO- ALL THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
WHETHER IT WAS CHILD CARE. AND
EARLY EDUCATION K. THROUGH
TWELVE AS WELL AS OUR
INSTITUTIONS HIGHER. EDUCATION
IT IS AN- WE WERE VERY PROUD OF
THE GOVERNOR AND HE FOCUSED HIS
OF THE STATE SOLELY ON
HOMELESSNESS. SO WE AREN'T
MEANT TO THE GOVERNOR'S HOME
WITH THIS PROPOSAL. BY
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. TO BE
SPENT WE WANTED TO KEEP THAT
SPENDING FLEXIBLE TO REALLY
ALLOW DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS
TO AGAIN TACKLE HOMELESSNESS
IN. WAYS THAT MADE SENSE IN
WAYS THAT WERE SUCCESSFUL
LOCALLY. AGAIN WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF THIS BUDGET WE THINK THAT
THESE THESE BUDGETS BOTH THESE
BUDGETS ARE MOVING. IN THE SAME
DIRECTION AND WE LOOK FORWARD-
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE DAYS TO
DISCUSSING HOW WE CAN. COME
TOGETHER ON ONE SINGULAR BUDGET
THAT WILL GET PASSED ON JUNE.
FIFTEENTH WITHOUT I'M GONNA
TURN OVER TO MR WANTING. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU I
THINK THIS BUDGET HAS COME A
LONG WAYS IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
WEEKS I'D LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE- IT ON THE- THE
COMMITTEES AND ALL OF OUR
STAFFS FOR THEIR HARD WORK-
ALSO WHAT I THINK WOULD BE A
LOT OF PROGRESS IN SHIFTING THE
CUTS TO. AREAS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE THE MOST IMPACTFUL ON THE
VERY SAME PEOPLE THAT WERE
TRYING TO HELP. I THINK THOSE
WERE VERY APPROPRIATE- IN
PARTICULAR I WANT TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND- CHRISTIAN
FOR. HELP YOUR WORK ON- HELPING
TO KEEP THE BARSTOW VETERANS
HOME OPEN ANOTHER PEOPLE BAR
STONER VETERANS ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE FOR THAT WORK- I
DO REMAIN CONCERNED HOWEVER
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF INNER FUND
BORROWING AND THE NUMBER OF
DEFERRALS THATREMAIN IN THIS
BUDGET AND- HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT THAT- THIS AFTERNOON
BECAUSE I REALLY I REALLY THINK
THAT WERE NOT BEING REALISTIC
IN SOME WAYS ABOUT THE SCOPE.
OF THIS RECESSION AND HOW LONG
IT'S GOING TO LAST- AND I ALSO.
WANT TO STILL BE VERY
INTROSPECTIVE ABOUT THE
PROSPECT OF ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING TO THE STATES
PARTICULARLY TO CALIFORNIA-
BUT- I KNOW WE ARE VERY HOPEFUL
THAT THE STATE IS GOING TO GET
MORE FEDERAL AID I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WE'RE BEING REALISTIC
ABOUT THE- POSSIBILITY OF THAT
OCCURRING. AND BEING REALISTIC
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED
TO DO AS IT STATE GOVERNMENT IF
THAT IS NOT MATERIALIZE SO I
THINK MISTER CHAIRMAN LOOKING
FOR THE. THANK YOU OPEN
COMMENTS AUTORAMA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR CONVENING SUB
SIX ON THE NEXT STAGE OF OUR
BUDGET PROCESS FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL YEAR.
OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE
RESPONSIBLE AND WE ARE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THIS MOMENT.
PEOPLE HAVE LOST PATIENCE
BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T SEEN
PROGRESS. OUR GOVERNOR SPOKE
THESE WORDS JUST A FEW DAYS AGO
AND THAT IT IT IS MY HOPE THAT
WE CAN KEEP THISSENTIMENT AND
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN WITNESSING AT
THE CENTER OF OUR ACTIONS
TODAY. AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK
ON A BUDGET THAT WILL AFFECT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
IN PARTICULAR ARE BLACK
COMMUNITY. AS CHAIR OF SUB ONE
OF HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES MY
SENSE OF RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
PEOPLE HAS NEVER BEEN STRONGER.
I BELIEVE NOW MORE THAN EVER
THAT WE NEED A STRONG
HEALTHCARE SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM AND CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS TO OUR SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS. SERVING OUR HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICE PROGRAMS
WHERE WE CAN SUCH AS
INVESTMENTS IN OUR- ACHIEVING
HEALTH FOR ALL IS A MORAL
OBLIGATION. AND ENSURING THAT
WE MAKE SMART HEALTH FINANCING
DECISIONS AND HOW WE INVEST OR
PROP FIFTY SIX DOLLARS HELPS US
TO MEET OUR MORAL AND FISCAL
OBLIGATIONS INTO THE FUTURE. I
ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF
COUNTLESS ADVOCATES SAY OF METS
WITH THESE PAST SEVERAL WEEKS.
IN THAT IF WE TAKE STEPS BACK
AND HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WE ARE AGGRAVATING THE
SUFFERING FOR FAMILIES AND WE
ARE PROLONGING THE CURRENT
FISCAL CRISIS. I FIRMLY BELIEVE
AND EVER PETER LEAVE VOICED ON
THIS DíAS THAT AN INVESTMENT
IN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS AND
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS ARE AN
INVESTMENT TO OUR ECONOMIC
HEALTH. WE SHOULD NOT TAKE
LIGHTLY THAT SUPPORTING
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
REBUILDING OUR ECONOMY ARE
INDEED ONE AND THE SAME. OUR
HEARING TODAY SYMBOLIZES AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS GETTING
CLOSER TO FULFILLING OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION TO
PASS A BALANCED BUDGET BY JUNE
FIFTEENTH. I AM PLEASED AND
HOPEFUL THAT THIS ARCHITECTURE
LAID OUT IN THE PROPOSED
ASSEMBLY BUDGET PLAN WHILE
STILL RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE
A LOT OF WORK TO DO IN THE NEXT
SEVERAL DAYS BEFORE JUNE
FIFTEENTH DEADLINE. I AM
COMMITTED TO MEETING THIS
MOMENT AND TO WORK COLLECTIVELY
WITH COLLEAGUES AND ADVOCATES
TO REACH A FINAL AGREEMENT. IT
IS MY SHARED HOPE THAT THE
DECISIONS WE MAKE TODAY AND
MOVE. FORWARD AS A BODY MAKE
POSITIVE MEANINGFUL IMPACT FOR
ALL COMMUNITIES. AND THE BUDGET
PLAN ACTIVELY WORKS IN A MANNER
THAT IMPROVES CONDITIONS FOR
THE PEOPLE. NOT TO WORSEN THEM.
I AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
ADDRESS THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND TO EXPLORE
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO INCREASE
REVENUE THAT STRENGTHENS OUR
STATE ECONOMIC RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER COMMENTS BY THE
MEMBERS. ANY OTHER COMMENTS SO
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO MISTER
PATRICK KELLY UP. MR BUT IF WE
DON'T HAVE VOLUME SO IF. I KNOW
IF YOU'RE MUTED OR- OR HELLO
THIS IS LOOKING. I STILL DON'T
HEAR ANYTHING. RIGHT ABOUT.
OKAY THERE WE GO PERFECT THANK
YOU OKAY MY APOLOGIES. SO GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR INVITING OUR OFFICE TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
WE WERE ASKED BY COMMITTEE
STAFF TO PRESENT SORT OF A
CROSSWALK BETWEEN. THE MAY
REVISION AND THE NEW
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE THAT YOU
WERE JUST DISCUSSING SO JUST A
BRIEF NOTE ON THAT I WOULD I
WOULD. POINT OUT THAT WHILE WE
ARE VERY PLEASED TO PROVIDE
THIS CROSSWALK WE WERE NOT
INVOLVED IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE PACKAGING SO TO THE EXTENT
YOU HAVE. QUESTIONS ABOUT
DETAIL PROVISIONS THAT THAT-
COME UP TODAY- THERE MAY BE
OTHERS ON THE COMMITTEE THAT
COULD YOU COULD- RESPOND TO
THOSE- OF OUR BETTER POSITION
TO RESPOND TO THOSE. ALSO ON I
WOULD JUST MENTION THAT-
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE A COPY OF
TWO OF THE HANDOUT THAT I PLAN
TO WALK THROUGH TODAY. I AM BUT
FOR IT FOR ANYONE FOLLOWING
ALONG. YOU COULD ALSO ACCESS
THE SAME HAND OUT ON OUR
WEBSITE AT. L. A. O. DOT SEE A
DOC OF. OKAY SO WITH THAT I
WILL GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED.
ON PAGE ONE. TO BEGIN WITH-
JUST SORT OF A BRIEF HIGH LEVEL
OVERVIEW OF SOME OF THE KEY
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WENT INTO THE
TWO PACKAGES ALL TOUCH ON
REVENUES BASELINE SPENDING AND
THEN THE ASSUMPTIONS ARE
RELATED TO FEDERAL FUNDING. ON
REVENUES AS MR TANG ALREADY
MENTIONED. THE BOTH PACKAGES
ARE USING LARGELY THE SAME SET
OF ASSUMPTIONS AND BOTH DO.
LOOK TO AUGMENT THE STATE
REVENUE BASE ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS BY SUSPENDING THE USE OF
NET OPERATING LOSSES AND-
LIMITING THE USE OF TAX CREDITS
TARGETING PRIMARILY- MEDIUM AND
LARGER SIZE BUSINESSES SO THOSE
SUSPENSIONS AND LIMITATIONS
WOULD BE IN PLACE FOR THOSE FOR
THE UPCOMING THREE FISCAL YEARS
AD WOULD GENERATE AN ESTIMATED
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION IN.
ADDITIONAL REVENUE IN THE IN
THE BUDGET PACKAGE. WHEN IT
COMES TO BASS LINE SPENDING THE-
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE
DEPARTS FROM THE MAY REVISION
BY USING THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OUR OFFICES
ESTIMATES FOR CASELOADS IN
PARTICULAR WE HAVE DIFFERENT
ESTIMATES THEN THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES FOR CAL
WORKS IN FOR MEDI CAL. IN CAL
WORKS ARE ARE- CASELOAD
ESTIMATES ARE QUITE A BIT LOWER
THAN WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATED AND BY USING OUR
ESTIMATES IN IN THAT AREA THERE
THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE
CAN RECOGNIZE AROUND TWO POINT
NINE BILLION IN BUDGET SAVINGS
IN THE GENERAL FUND. ON MEDI
CAL WE HAVE SIMILAR CASELOAD
ESTIMATES BUT WE HAVE
DIFFERENT- COST PER CASE LOAD
ESTIMATES THAN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND BY USING OUR
ESTIMATES IN THIS AREA. THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE CAN
REALIZE AROUND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION AND- LOWER
COSTS AND SO THE COMBINED-
DIFFERENCES THERE'S AROUND
THREE POINT SIX BILLION AND-
LOWER BASELINE SPENDING
EXPECTATIONS UNDER THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE.
OKAY WHEN IT COMES TO FEDERAL
FUNDING THIS IS WHERE THE TWO
PACKAGES REALLY HAVE A
FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
APPROACH AND THEY ARE DIFFERENT
SUCH THAT THEIR THEIR BASELINE
ASSUMPTIONS ON ON WHETHER OR
NOT ADDITIONAL FEDERAL AID WILL
BE FORTHCOMING MAKES IT SO THAT
IT'S ACTUALLY KIND OF DIFFICULT
TO COMPARE THE TWO PACKAGES.
ACCORDING TO THEIR BASELINE
ASSUMPTIONS SO WHAT I MEAN IS
AS MR TING ALREADY ALLUDED TO
THE- THE MAY REVISION IS
STARTING FROM A PRESUMPTION
THAT NO ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE WILL BE FORTHCOMING
AND THEREFORE. ON JULY FIRST-
IT INCLUDES AROUND FIFTEEN
BILLION IN REDUCTIONS. BUT IT
ALSO INCLUDES- TRIGGER
PROVISIONS THAT WOULD. REVERSE
THOSE REDUCTIONS IN THE EVENT
THAT ADDITIONAL FEDERAL AID
WERE TO ARRIVE. THE LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET PACKAGE ON THE OTHER
HAND STARTS FROM THE
PRESUMPTION THAT WE WILL
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL AID-
HOWEVER IN THAT CASE THE
CONTINGENCY IS A TRIGGER
REDUCTION THAT WOULD TAKE PLACE
ON OCTOBER FIRST IF THE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING DOES
NOT MATERIALIZE. SO BECAUSE
THOSE TWO BASELINE ASSUMPTIONS
ARE KIND OF COMING AT THIS FROM
A FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
PLACES OF THE BALANCE OF MY
REMARKS WILL COMPARE THE TWO
PACKAGES UNDER THESE DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS ONE WHERE WE DO HAVE
THE DIGITAL FEDERAL AID. AND
THE OTHER WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL LAKES I
THINK THAT IS PROBABLY THE
CLEAREST WAY TO TALK ABOUT IT.
SO MOVING TO THE SECOND PAGE OF
THE OF THE HANDOUT. I'LL START
WITH TOUCHING ON THE CASE IN
WHICH THERE IS ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL AID. IN THIS CASE THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE AND
THE MAY REVISION ARE ACTUALLY
BROADLY SIMILAR WITH A FEW KEY
DIFFERENCES. ALL JUST TOUCH ON
A FEW- THAT ONE ONE NOTABLE
DIFFERENCES THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE
WOULD IN THE FISCAL YEAR WITH
AROUND A BILLION DOLLARS IN
TOTAL RESERVE HIGHER TOTAL
RESERVE BALANCES- AT THE END OF
IT BUDGET YEAR ANOTHER. COUPLE
OF POINTS OLD NOTE- ONE IS THAT
THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE
PROVIDES AROUND A BILLION
DOLLARS OF FUNDING FOR COUNTIES
FOR THE REALIGNMENT PROGRAMS-
REALIGNMENT FUNDING IS EXPECTED
TO SUFFER SOME SIGNIFICANT.
DECREASES BECAUSE OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN RECESSION. AND THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE
RECOGNIZES THE- DIFFICULTY THAT
THAT WOULD PUT THE COUNTIES IN
FROM A FISCAL STANDPOINT AND
WOULD PROVIDE ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS OF FUNDING TO HELP
ALLEVIATE THOSE STRESSES
ALTHOUGH- AROUND SIX HUNDRED
MILLION OF IT WOULD BE- THE
SUBJECT TO TRIGGER REDUCTION IN
THE EVENT WE DON'T RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL AID. ON
SIMILARLY THE LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET PACKAGE DOES PROVIDE
SOME AUGMENTATION TO FUNDING
FOR THE UNIVERSITY'S. HOUSE CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY IN THE UC
SYSTEM'S ALTHOUGH THAT FUNDING
TO WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
REDUCTION IF ADDITIONAL-
FEDERAL MONEY IS NOT
FORTHCOMING. THERE ARE TWO
AREAS WHERE YOU KNOW THAT ARE
DIFFERENT REGARDLESS OF FEDERAL
FUNDING THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
PACKAGE PROVIDES THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION IN LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING. AND ALSO
WOULD EXPAND THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM TO INCLUDE-
TAXPAYERSTHAT FILE USING
INDIVIDUAL TAX IDENTIFICATION
NUMBERS I TEN FILERS WITH
CHILDREN AT THE AGES SIX AND
UNDER SO- THOSE TWO ITEMS ARE
SHOWN AT THE LATTER PART OF THE
TWO BOTTOM POINTS ON THE ON THE
FIRST SECTION OF THE- THIS PAGE.
NOW I'LL TURN TO TALKING ABOUT
HOW THE TWO PACKAGES DIFFER IN
THE EVENT THE STATE DOES NOT
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL AID
BECAUSE IN THIS CASE THE
PACKAGES ARE QUITE DIFFERENT.
MOVING TO PAGE THREE ALL START
WITH- DISCUSSION OF BUDGET
RESERVES AND ACTUALLY IF I IF I
MAY I WOULD- TALKED- BEGIN BY
SPEAKING TO THE SECOND BULLET
POINT THERE THE CODED NINETEEN
CONTINGENCY FUND AS YOU RECALL
THIS WAS A PROPOSAL IN THE MAY
REVISION TO ESTABLISH A TWO
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLAR. A
CONTINGENCY FUND- THAT WOULD BE
USED TO PAY FOR AS YET UNKNOWN-
CODE RED NINETEEN RELATED
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES. THE WAY
THAT THE FUNDING FOR THIS FOR
THIS FUND WHICH WOULD BE- COME
TO BE UNDER THE NAY REVISION
WAS. FIRST WITH AN
APPROPRIATION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND FOR SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS WHICH
WOULD SERVE AS A STATE AS THE
STATE'S MATCH. TO GENERATE AN
ADDITIONAL ROUGHLY TWO POINT
TWO BILLION IN FEDERAL FEMA
FUNDING. SO THE TOTAL WOULD BE
TWO POINT NINE BILLION BUT WITH
THE STATE COST REALLY BEING THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
MILLION. SO THE LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET PERHAPS A PACKAGE.
REJECT THE CREATION OR
ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS FUND AND
RATHER IT TAKES THE SAME STATE
CONTRIBUTION TO THAT FUND THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
MILLION AND DESIGNATED WITHIN
THE- SPECIAL FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES. AND IT WOULD
THEN BE AVAILABLE LATER IN THE
YEAR IN THE EVENT WE NEED. THE
ADDITIONAL MONEY TO ADDRESS
CODED NINETEEN RELATED RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES. THE OTHER ITEM I
WANTED TO TOUCH ON HERE IS THAT.
YOU'D SEE THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE DRAWS DOWN A BIT MORE
IN THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT AND WHAT THAT MAY
REVISION PROPOSED- JUST AS A
BRIEF REMINDER I THINK IT CAN
BE HELPFUL UNDER PROPOSITION
TWO. HALF OF THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT IS
AVAILABLE IN THE FIRST YEAR OF
A BUDGET EMERGENCY. AND AS A
REMINDER THE BUDGET EMERGENCY
IS THAT CAN BE- ESTABLISHED IN
TWO WAYS ONE THROUGH A- NATURAL
DISASTER DECLARATION- AND THEN
THE OTHER WAY IS TO IF THE
GOVERNOR DECLARES A FISCAL
EMERGENCY. IN A FISCAL
EMERGENCY IS DEFINED AS A
CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH-
RESOURCES IN THE CURRENT YEAR
AND THE UP COMING YEAR ARE
EXPECTED TO BE INSUFFICIENT TO
COVER- THIS IS SPENDING AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF THE PAST THREE
BUDGETS ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION
AND POPULATION. SO TODAY AT IT
AS WE SPEAK WE HAVE AROUND A
SIXTEEN POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT BALANCE. AND YOU SEE
THAT WE WOULD BE TO BRING IT
DOWN TO SIX POINT FIVE BILLION
UNDER THE LEGISLATIVE PLAN.
WHICH IS CLEARLY MORE THAN HALF
OF THE SIXTEEN POINT TWO SO-
YEAH I CAN BRIEFLY ADDRESSED
THAT AND- OF THE SIXTEEN
BILLION ABOUT THREE BILLION HAS
BEEN PUT INTO THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT IN RECENT
YEARS ON AN OPTIONAL BASIS. SO
YOU KNOW THE VIEW IS THAT ALL
OF THAT THREE BILLION IS
AVAILABLE WHICH THEN LEADS OF A
THIRTEEN BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT BALANCE
SO HALF OF THAT IS SIX SIX AND
A HALF BILLION OR SO
APPROXIMATELY AND THEN WHEN YOU
BRING THAT AND ADD IT TO THE
THREE BILLION THAT'S HOW WE
REDUCE THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT BY- ROUND OVER NINE
BILLION DOWN TO THE SIX POINT
FIVE. OKAY MOVING TO SLIDE FOR.
BUT THIS IS AN AREA WHERE
THERE'S SOME OTHER DIFFERENCES
FROM THE NAY REVISION THIS IS
IN THE CATEGORY OF CAUTIOUS
AND- INTER FUND TRANSFERS SO IF
I MADE DRY YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE MIDDLE ROW THERE WHERE IT
SAYS REINSTATE DEFERRALS. YOU
WOULD SEE THAT THE AMOUNT
LISTED IS ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION. UNDER THE LEGISLATIVE
PLAN. THAT IS THAT REFLECTS TO
DEFERRALS THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
PLAN CONTEMPLATES ONE IS THE A
DEFERRAL OF THE FOURTH QUARTER
STATE THIS DEFERRAL OF THE
STATE'S FOURTH QUARTER
CONTRIBUTION TO CALPERS- FROM
LATE JUNE EARLY JULY. AND THEN
IT ALSO INCLUDES A- DEFERRAL OF
THE JUNE PAYROLL- FROM THE YOU
KNOW BY BASICALLY ONE DAY FROM
THE AT THE VERY END OF JUNE TO
THE FIRST DAY OF JULY. NOW
THERE'S AN IMPORTANT- YOU KNOW-
ADD ON THAT I NEED TO MAKE TO
THAT AND THAT IS THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL INCLUDES.
WHAT I WOULD CALL A JANUARY
DETERMINATION PROVISION. SO IF
IT IF WE GET TO JANUARY AND IT
APPEARS THAT THE STATE'S FISCAL
CONDITION IS BETTER IN BETTER
CONDITION THAN WHAT IT IS AT
THE TIME OF BUDGET ENACTMENT.
SO THAT WOULD BE MEASURED BY
HIGHER REVENUES SOME
COMBINATION OF HIGHER REVENUES
IN LOWER EXPENDITURES THAN WE
THOUGHT WHEN THE BUDGET IS
ENACTED AT THAT YOU KNOW IN
JUNE. AND IF THAT'S THE CASE
THEN THIS PAYROLL THE PEARL
WOULD NOT GO FORWARD IT WOULD
BE ELIMINATED BUT- STARTING
FROM JUST THE BASELINE
ASSUMPTIONS WE'RE SHOWING IT IN
THIS LIFE. AND ANOTHER KEY
POINT ABOUT THESE DEFERRALS IS
THAT THEY WOULD APPLY TO BOTH
THE GENERAL FUND AND TO THE
STATE'S SPECIAL FUNDS. SO THEN
THIS SPECIAL FUNDS THE SAVINGS
THAT WOULD BE REALIZED BY THE
SPECIAL FUNDS BY BY-
IMPLEMENTING THESE DEFERRALS
WOULD BE SHIFTED TO THE GENERAL
FUND IN THE FORM OF A LOAN TO
THE GENERAL FUND AND SO
ACTUALLY IF THE THIS RELATES TO
THE LINE OR THE ROW JUST ABOVE
REINSTATEMENT DEFERRALS THE
FIRST ROW SPECIAL FIND LOANS
AND TRANSFERS YOU'LL NOTE THAT
THE- LEGISLATURE. IS IT IS
ABOUT ONE POINT ONE BILLION
HIGHER THAN THE NAY REVISION IN
THIS AREA. AND THAT ONE POINT
ONE BILLION. IS REALLY THE
REFLECTION OF THAT THAT
ACCOUNTS FOR THE SAVINGS THAT I
JUST DESCRIBED- THAT THEIR
SPECIAL FUNDS WOULD REALIZE
FROM THESE- DEFERRALS. SO
THAT'S HOW THE TWO TWO ROWS
RELATE TO ONE ANOTHER. OKAY
MOVING TO. THAT SLIDE FIVE.
HERE I WOULD SPEAK ABOUTTHE
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FUNDING UNDER
THE LEGISLATIVE PLAN THERE IN
THIS IS A CASE WHERE THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING- TO
ADDRESS THE CODED RECESSION. IN
THIS CASE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET PLAN FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES DIFFERS
FROM THE NAY REVISION IN THAT
THERE IS NO REDUCTION AND TO
THE OVERALL LEVEL OF FUN
FUNDING THAT GOES TO THE
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN FACT THERE'S AN INCREASE AND
COMPARED WITH THE MAY REVISION-
FUNDING FOR THE FOR THE SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD BE
HIGHER THAN THE NAY REVISION BY
ABOUT. EIGHT BILLION. THE
SOURCE OF HIGHER FUNDING IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PLAN IS FROM FROM
TWO PLACES ONE IS THE-
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING LEVEL OF PROVIDED BY
THE GENERAL FUND WOULD BE ABOVE
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE AND IT
WOULD BE- FOR ABOUT TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS ABOUT
THAT LEVEL. THEN IN ADDITION.
THERE WOULD BE THE USE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PLAN WOULD CONVERT
ABOUT FIVE POINT THREE BILLION
OF FUNDING TO DEFERRALS AND AT
THE SAME TIME PRESERVE- IN
DOING SO PRESERVE THE
PROGRAMMATIC LEVEL OF FUNDING
FOR THE SCHOOLS BUT WITH THAT
RELATIVE TO THE MAY REVISION AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION OF THAT BEING PROVIDED
IN- DEFERRAL IN DEFERRED FUNDS.
SO THE FIVE POINT THREE BILLION
PLUS THE TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION IS HOW YOU GET TO THE
EIGHT BILLION. IN HIGHER
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS UNDER THE
LEGISLATIVE PLAN RELATIVE TO
THE NAY REVISION. OKAY MOVING
FINALLY HERE TO THE LAST PAGE
ON SLIDE SIX. THIS SLIDE
DISPLAYS SOME OF THE MAJOR
PROGRAMMATIC DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THEM A REVISION AND THE
LEGISLATIVE PLAN AND IF YOU
THINK ABOUT THE SCENARIO WHERE
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT BECOMES AVAILABLE.
I WOULD SAY THAT THIS SLIDE
REALLY IS AT THE HEART OF HOW
THE TWO PACKAGES DIFFER FROM
ONE ANOTHER. YOU WOULD NOTE-
AS- DOCTOR RANDY LISTED. THE TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PLAN HERE
REJECTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED. REPURPOSE SCENE OF
THE PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX FUNDS
TO. WHICH IN THE MAY REVISION
IT WITH THOSE THE FUNDING THERE
WOULD BE USED TO PAY FOR GROWTH
IN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM THE
LEGISLATIVE PLAN- REJECTS
DOUBTING WOULD CONTINUE TO USE
THE FUNDS. FOR SIMILARLY THE
LEGISLATIVE PLAN REJCTS THE
PROPOSAL TO REDUCE THE AYE HSS
SERVICE HOURS. AND YOU KNOW SO
THE OTHER ITEMS YOU CAN SEE
HERE LISTED ON THE SLIDE IN
THESE THESE ARE- SOME OF WHAT
YOU HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT. AS
KEY PROGRAMMATIC DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE TWO PACKAGES. BUT I
WOULD JUST POINT OUT TO INCLUDE
MY PREPARED REMARKS THAT YOU
KNOW THE WAY THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE IS
ABLE TO PROVIDE THESE OR
MAINTAIN THE FUNDING LEVEL FOR
THE SERVICES IS REALLY.
SUMMARIZED IN THREE POINTS-
FIRST THE USE OF THE LA-
CASELOADS AS I WAS SAYING
EARLIER SECOND THE L. THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE USES A BIT
MORE OF THE STATE'S RESERVES-
THAN THE NAY REVISION WOULD.
AND THEN THIRD- THEN THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE DOES USE. A
BIT MORE CAUTIOUS- AS I JUST
TALKED ABOUT UNDER THAT EARLIER
SLIDE SO THOSE THREE ACTIONS
ARE REALLY WHAT PROVIDE THE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AT LEAST
ON AT. A ONE TIME BASIS IN A
COUPLE OF THOSE CASES- THE
ENABLE THAT THE PACKAGE TO
SUSTAIN THESE PROGRAMS AS
DESCRIBED ON THE SIX A SLIGHT.
SO WITH THAT THAT'S A SUMMARY
OF. HOW WE VIEW THE TWO
PACKAGES AND HOW THE- OR
SIMILAR AND HOW THEY ARE
DIFFERENT HOW THEY DIFFER. WITH
THAT I WILL BE HAPPY TO.
RESPOND TO QUESTIONS WHEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU
WITHOUT WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE MISTER THIS WHEN
THEY- DO YOU MISTER CHANG
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF AT AND JUST MAKE THREE
POINTS- ABOUT- A REVISION AND
THE LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL. THE
FIRST IS I WANT TO NOTE LIKE MR
PADDACK- NUMBEROF ITEMS THAT
ARE IN COMMON BETWEEN THE NAY
REVISIONS AND THE LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET PROPOSAL IN PARTICULAR-
GRATEFUL FOR A. B. CONTINUED
PLUSH. AMONG MEMBERS FOR A
GREATER FEDERAL FUNDS IN ACTION
AND CONGRESS. WE APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THE REVENUES-
ESTIMATES FOR EACH OF THESE
PACKAGES ARE THE SAME- AND AT
THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PROPOSAL
ALSO INCLUDES THE TEMPORARY NEW
REVENUES. THAT WERE IN THE NAY
REVISION. AND WHILE AS MR
PADDOCK NOTED WE HAVE AYE
DIFFERENCES ON CASE WHAT
ASSUMPTIONS AND- ON A KIND OF
SEVERAL BILLION DOLLARS WE KNOW
THAT SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
CONTINUING TO DISCUSS- IN THE
DAYS AHEAD. THIS POINT I WANT
TO MAKE THOUGH ABOUT
LEGISLATURE PROPOSAL THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES REMAIN
CONCERNED. ABOUT STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS PARTICULARLY IN THE
OUT YEARS AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IN THE MAIL REVISION. EVEN
THE BUDGET THAT WE PUT FORWARD
HAD SOME STRUCTURAL ISSUES THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED- IN THE
YEARS AFTER THE BUDGET YEAR.
AND THAT IS WHAT OUR BEST
ESTIMATE OF THE REVENUES. NOW
AS EVERYONE KNOWS WE ARE IN A
VERY UNCERTAIN SITUATION. IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT CONGRESS WILL
COME THROUGH WITH EVEN MORE AID
THAN WE ARE EXPECTING. IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT THE ECONOMY CAN
RECOVER MORE ROBUSTLY- DAN OUR-
ECONOMIC EXPERTS ARE.
PROJECTING BUT IT'S ALSO
POSSIBLE THAT ALL THESE NUMBERS
COULD BE EVEN WORSE THAN WE ARE
PROJECTING RIGHT NOW SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO PREPARE
FOR THAT POSSIBILITY. AND WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT A BUDGET
THAT ADDS SEVERAL BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL DEFICITS.
IN THOSE OUT YEARS. AND THAT
BRINGS ME TO MY LAST POINT
WHICH IS THE CONTENT OF THE
TRIGGER POTS- THAT MR PADDOCK
MENTIONED. WELL WE ARE ALL
HOPEFUL THAT CONGRESS WILL GET
ITS ACT TOGETHER AND PASS A
PACKAGE THAT PROVIDES. MUCH
GREATER STATE AND LOCAL AID WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY THAT THEY WILL NOT
COME THROUGH IN WASHINGTON DC.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
CONTENT OF THE TRIGGER CUTS ARE
ONE TIME IN NATURE WHETHER THEY
ARE CAUTIOUS OR DIGITAL USES OF
RESERVES. THOSE ARE AREAS THAT
WILL NOT BE AVAILABLE IN THE
YEAR AFTER THE BUDGET YEAR.
WHICH COULD FORCES TO RESERVE
ON. CHOICES ON WHAT WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING ON THE
LEGISLATURE AND ON THE GO. SO
THE ARE SOME CONCERNS BUT I
WANT TO REITERATE. WE THE
POINTS AND CON. WE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO IN THE
DAYS AHEAD TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT I'M GONNA OPEN UP FOR. CUT
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEE MISTER MISTER
COOPER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS FOR- FINANCE. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MANY LISTEN
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING MYSELF
INTO EXTENSIVE NEGOTIATIONS TO
EXTENDOUR CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM WHICH BECAME AB THREE
NINETY EIGHT AND CREATE A
PROGRAM THAT INSURED WE WOULD
MEET OUR GOALS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES. PROVIDE COST
CONTAINMENT MEASURES TO ENSURE
INDUSTRIES WHEN THE FORCE OF
THE STATE. NOW WITHOUT ANY
POLICY COMMITTEE HEARING OR
PUBLIC INPUT LANGUAGES BEEN
SHOVED IN THE BUDGET THAT WOULD
REOPEN THE AGREEMENTS WE WORK
SO HARD. THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD JUST FINALIZE REGULATIONS
FOR CAP AND TRADE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AND THEY ARE FULLY
IMPLEMENTED UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. YET ALL THE STUDIES DONE
BY CAR SHOW OF THE PROGRAM IS
WORKING TO MEET OUR GHG
REDUCTION GOALS. SO WHAT THE
SEARCH IS REQUIRED TO THIS
POINT- WE VOTE ON THIS BACK
THREE YEARS AGO WAS A TWO
THIRDS VOTE. AND A LOT OF US-
VOTER SUPPORT IT WAS TOUGH WE
HAD GOTTEN THE MOST WE MADE IT
HAPPEN. AND NOW WE'VE PASSAGE
CHANGES ON A FORTY ONE VOTE
BILL. SO YOU KNOW WHAT'S IN THE
THIS IS STILL IN PROCESS. BUT
I'D LIKE TO GET AN ANSWER ON
THAT SIMPLIFICATION PLEASE. YES
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER
COOPER- I THINK I'LL MAKE ONE
OR TWO BRIEF COMMENTS AND THEN
MY COLLEAGUE TO RESET CALPERS
IS ON THE PHONE AND SHE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE. ADDITIONAL
DETAIL AS WELL- I THINK THAT WE
ALL SAW THAT THAT CAP AND TRADE
MOST RECENT AUCTION- CAME WELL
WELL BELOW. THE PROJECTIONS
THAT WE HAD INITIALLY HOPED FOR
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR-
SO BOTH FOR THE END OF THIS
YEAR AS WELL AS THE COMING
YEAR- WE REALIZE THAT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
PROGRAM BECAUSE- THE ABILITY TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
SUPPORTED. THIS YEAR I WILL NOT
BE PRESENT NEXT YEAR BUT LET ME
TURN IT OVER TO RESET TO
ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION MORE
DETAILS. HI GOOD MORNING THE TO
TREAT THE COVER WAS. PART OF
FINANCE. CORRECT THAT
LEGISLATURE. BUDGET THAT
INCLUDE. A NEW PROVISION. THAT
BUT THE- THAT. THERE IS.
FUNDING FOR THEIR- RESEARCH
BOARD YOU CAN. A HOME. CONSIDER
CHAIN. THAT AND TRADE PROGRAM
BUT- THIS WAS PART OF THE
LARGEST. ACTS THAT. MAY WERE.
HAD CHANGES TO. I'D CONTROL
SECTION THAT. ADDRESS WHAT
MISTER. BUT REFER. TO IT WHICH
IS THE RUNNING INTO. IN BUDGET.
SUPPOSED DON'T. ON THE CABIN
TRADE BETTER DECLINE IN THE-
LIKE IT'S- PACK. HAVE BEEN. BUT
THERE IS. THAT. IN A LANGUAGE
THAT DOES AFTER FOR AN THEIR
RESOURCES FOR THE MAKING. BUT
BUT THEY CAN ALSO ARE YOU UP
RULED WHEN THEY THEY APPROVED.
UNDER A THREE NINETY EIGHT WHAT
WE DIRECT THE MAKE AND RULE MAY
BECAUSE CHANGE. IS THERE ABOUT
A THREE YEAR IMPLEMENT. I'M NOT
OF THE- PROPOSAL IS NOT PART OF
OUR REVISION PROPOSAL BECAUSE
IT OF A LOT. BUDGET PACKAGE.
YEAH SO THE- PROPOSAL VERY WITH
REGARD TO NEXT YEAR AT PAYS YOU
MACINNES FOR THE PRO. BUT I
BELIEVE THIS. AT PROPOSED
CHANGE THAT YOU'RE- ARE NOT OF
THE IN THE- PACKAGE TO. IN
OTHER OTHER ISSUES. WITH SAY
BUDGET CRISIS WE FOR TO CRISIS
IS ONE HELL AND ONE ECHO. THIS
IS ON THE ARE PORSCHE THEY ARE
IN THE TAX. REMOVING IT WE'RE
LITTLE TO ON THE SCIENCES
INDUSTRY TO THE ARE IN THE TO
SOLVE OUR HEALTH. AND WE TO PAY
UPON LIFE SCIENCES AN ERROR IN
THIS. FOR THE JOB TO GO US OUT
OF THIS ECONOMIC PROBLEMS SO
WAS. YOU KNOW MORE THAN EVER WE
HAVE THAT. SO LIKE THE ARE IN
THE THIS NOW FOR THE FOLKS. YES
ARE HERE A HARPER REFER TO THE
TEMP. SUSPENSION OF CORRECT
OKAY SO I THAT WE UNDERSTAND
AND- YOU KNOW THIS NOT. EASY
AND THERE SHORT TERM YOU KNOW
THIS WILL GO ON FOR TWO YEARS.
A I DO. TO RAISE THAT THESE
CRIED WILL. TO BE AT THE AFTER
THREE YEARS PATTERSON TO STAND
AT A CERTAIN THINGS WILL EXPIRE
YOU KNOW FOR AND WELLS WE ARE A
EXTENSION. SO THAT THIS CREDIT
THANKS WE CAN BE. I THINK THAT
PROVIDE. SOME CERTAINTY TO THE
PEOPLE WHO HAPPENS TO ENTITIES
HAVE THOSE. A WE RELY ON SO WE
LIKE IN FOR AND WE DO BUT IT IS
A REASONABLE WAY TO GO THROUGH
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS WHILE
CONTINUING TO INCENTIVIZE KIND
OF. SINCE ABOUT. THE CITY NOW.
A MOVIE IMPACT THESE POTENTIAL.
HAVE PUBLIC SAY. IN THE CITY SO
SEE SEE I PROGRAM. ENGINE DO
NOT HAVE THIS WITH THE FIFTH.
YES ON THERE I'VE GOT A LIKE A
AND WERE ON THE LAW YOU KNOW WE
DO A AS YOU KNOW SO WELL AS
PROGRAM. COMMITMENTS AND OF
CURRENT TRENDS HOLD CLOSE TO
FACILITIES OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
OF BUT ONE AT AREA ADDRESS THAT.
HI LARRY WAS WITH DEPART FIVE.
SO WITH RESPECT TO THE BECAUSE
THERE'S A- CUT TO FACT THERE
ONE IS. WE JUST HAVE A FRIEND
OF REDUCE COURT CAN COMMITMENTS
SO WE'RE GETTING PEOPLE THE
STATE PER FROM A COURT IS WHAT
WE SEE IN RECENT YEARS. ARE WE
ARE ARE. TAKING STEPS. SAFELY
REDUCE THE PRESENT WITH. THAT
THESE THINGS ARE WITH OUR PRIOR
TO THE NUMBER. AND CREATING
STATE PAP RE AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS BACK AND THE
COMMUNITY DEPARTMENT HAS BACK
TO GREAT AND WE YEARS. IN
BOLSTERING ITS APERTURE
READABLE SO I WOULD THAT WE'RE
AND OF BRINGING DOWN ON PRESENT
TO PASS IS BEING DONE IN
CONSISTENT WITH APOLLO SAFETY
OR ANY UP AND I'M BESIDE THE
IMPORTANCE REASONABLE AND
PREPARE PEOPLE TO SAFELY GRAY
AFTER BUT I. ELSE COME BACK AND
ON THEIR ABILITY PART AND WE
KNOW THAT CDC'S REAL BIG YOUR
BILL TATIAN IS RECENT AS AN IN
THE FIFTH PERCENT AND EVEN
THOUGH MY FOCUS THE COUNTY JAIL
NOW THE MINISTER AND NO OF THE
STATE HAS AN IDEA WHAT THOSE
ARE FOR JAIL WHO LESS WAITING
OF PERCENT SO THAT'S THAT'S
TROUBLING FOR ME. AND HOW DO
YOU FOR DISPLAY ESSENTIAL STAFF
WHO HAVE ON THE FRONTLINE OF
THE PANDA. EXCUSE ME AND
RISKING THEIR LIVES WHO WILL BE
BE OF A JOB. ALL THIS TOUCH
VERY BRIEFLY THAT AN ERROR MAY
ONE TO. GO FIRST OPTION AND ALL
THESE CASES IS ALLOW TO A
NEARBY FOR SO OR FOR SO WHERE
THEY ANOTHER MATCH ON WE UNDER
THAT IN ANY. OF STATE AND CITY
OR FOR CELL THERE WILL BE WORD
AND ALWAYS THE FIRST ON IS GIVE
THE- OF THAT TRAINED TO AND FOR
BUT THAT COULD SPEAK MORE
DETAIL ON THAT. SO AT THE WHAT
I CALL THAT COLLEAGUE ACTUALLY
COVER THAT QUITE WHILE I MEAN I
THINK THE- TO. THAT WHEN WE DO
DOWN THE ARE PRISON CAPACITY
THAT WILL HAVE OFFERED. GIVEN
THE NON OF TURN VACANCY. THAT
WE HAVE IN THE DEPARTMENT WHERE
THE IMPACT THAT EMPLOY. WHAT
THE BILL TO OTHER PARTS WE IT
TOOK. THE BY THE END OF THE
GIVEN THE NUMBER VACANCIES WITH
THE WANT NEED TO BE SIGNIFICANT
WHY ARE BUT. WE ARE TURNING
CLOSELY TRACK THAT I THINK THAT.
HERE OF A LOT MEN OF THE IMPACT
A- STATE PLATES. IMPLICIT BIAS.
RACIAL PROFILING COMMITTEE
POLICING. CULTURAL DIVERSITY IN
ORGANIZATIONAL WELLNESS THESE
ARE ALL HOT TOPICS IN A LOT OF
WHAT'S GOING ON THE PAST WEEK.
IN CALIFORNIA CROSS A NATION.
HOW EFFECTIVE IS THIS IS
LEARNING IF YOU'RE DOING. USE
OF FORCE IN THE ESCALATION
LOOKING AT A COMPUTER VERSES IN
THE PAST. THAT'S BEEN CLASSROOM
LEARNING HANDS ALL DEALING WITH
FOLKS. SO WHAT I'D LIKE TO THE
RATIONALE IN DOING THAT BECAUSE
WE GO. WHEN YOU'RE SEEING IN
DOING IT YOU RETAIN MORE. THAN
SITTING IN FOR A COMPUTER. AND
LIKE I SAID ON THE GOVERNOR IS
STILL A QUICKLY ON TV. THAT HE
SUPPORTS THESE. AND YET. IN
THIS BUDGET. THEY WANT A
DISTANCE LEARNING WHICH I THINK
IS NOT GOOD FOR THE COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO HAVE THE
OFFICERS TRAINED TO THE BEST
LEVEL POSSIBLE. MR MINNICH'S
TRAINING SO HOW DO YOU
RATIONALIZE. YES FIRST OF AS A
MEMBER CAREER ON RIGHT THAT THE
LAST COUPLE DAYS HAVE YOU KNOW
REAR FOR. READER THE OF THESE
PROGRAM AND HOW WE NEED DONE I
THINK WHEN IT COMES TO THE
TESTING ONE NEXT THAT FOR IMAGE.
FIRST WAS OUR TO IT IN THE FACT
THAT LOT OF THE PRO LOOKING AT
FOR NEXT YOU KNOW WHAT WE WHAT
WE SEE OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
MIND WE WEREN'T. HOW WOULD BE
TO BRING PEOPLE TO SIGN. OR
WHATEVER THESE TRAININGS TAKE
PLACE TO SAME EXTENT WE GET
INTO. BACK AND- THAT BEING SAID
WE UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN THE
FLAG YOU KNOW THE IS CERTAINLY
AT THE TOP OF THE AGENDA FOR A
OF US I THINK OF THAT COUPLE
DAYS AND AS WE THINK ABOUT
WHERE WE WILL. THIS TRAIN TO GO
AND FUNDS TO BE SPENT THAT WILL
BE TAKEN TO INTO. AND TO GO
OKAY ON THAT IF WE BEACH. AND
THIS IS THE IS NOT FOR THIS I
TAUGHT A OUR CULTURAL CAN MAKE.
IN THEIR CLASSROOM HEARING FROM
YOUR PEERS AND HAVE THAT DIRECT
IN. BACK AND FORTH. THAT IS
HELPS TREMENDOUSLY VERSUS ABOUT
PEWTER WHO KNOWS WAS PAYING IT
OR NOT. ALSO ON THE WHO WERE
SITTING MONEY ON THE YOU'LL THE
PRO. AND SHIFTING IT TO
MEDICARE ANOTHER INSURANCE. AND
LET MY BIG CONCERN IS MEDI CAL
IS FUNDED A LOT OF FOLKS TAKE
ME I'LL- AND WE'RE PER PEACEFUL
BACK FROM STREETS ARE RISK. SO
I'M JUST CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THESE MIL WE'LL FOLKS
ARE HIGH RISK. AND HOW
EFFECTIVE WAS BE. YOU KNOW MEDI
CAL IS ALWAYS BEEN ISSUE SO
WE'RE GONNA SHIFT HIGH RISK
INDIVIDUALS ON THE MEDI CAL.
YEAH SO WHEN IT COMES TO THIS
THIS IS. TED SIMPLY RESPONSE TO
THE BUDGET PRESSURES THAT WERE
FACING SOME ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU'RE RAISING AND JUST NEED TO
FIGURE OUTSIDE OF WORK FOR
SALUTE WE CAN'T BE MONEY OVER
PEOPLE'S. SAFETY IN LIFE AND I
WERE TALKING THESE INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE OUT SO THAT THE
INMATES ARE TRYING TO. GET BACK
IN BUT MILLIS IS VERY TOUGH TO
OVERCOME. WHICH MEANS THE TOUGH
TO OVERCOME ON THAT IN. BUT I
JUST CAN'T. RECONCILE THAT
MONEY OVER SAFETY THAT THEY MAY
SAY TO YOU- AND WITH IT
INDIVIDUAL SAFETY AND ALSO
PUBLIC SAFETY AT SOME POINT I
MEAN WE'RE NOT TALKING A LOT OF
MONEY HERE. INTRODUCTION BUT A
POINT ONE MILLION IN SAVING
IT'S JUST LITTLE THINGS LIKE
ANY PROVIDER. CAN AND SHOULD DO
A BETTER WITH THAT I BELIEVE
THAT'S. ALL I HAVE FOR NOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
COOPER MISSED. FOR THE BILL OF
YOU VERY MUCH THAT'S A BUMMER
FINANCE I NIGHT I NINE AND THAT
THE KIT CAP TRADE PROPOSAL I
GUESS WAS PUSHED BY LET'S I
ALWAYS THAT THE NEW FROM THE
BUT INTO OF THE ROOM MAKING I
JUST WANT TO GET SOME CLEAR IN
TERMS OF THE ANSWER WOULD
PROVIDE THE FOLK. I GUESS FROM
THE ANSWER PROVIDED BY THE BY
THE PART BY AS IS THAT IS N
REVENUE BUT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT WHEN WE NEGOTIATED- CAP
AND TRADE AND TO FOLLOW UP ON
WHAT MISTER COOPER TALKED ABOUT
THE OBJECTIVE OF THE CAPITATE
PROGRAM WAS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
IT WASN'T A REVENUE GENERATING
PROGRAM WAS DESIGNED TO JUST
GENERATE REVENUE CONTINUOUS
THESE CORRECT GENERALLY IT THE
REASON THAT WE DISCUSS REVENUES
SIMPLY BECAUSE WE'RE PUTTING
FORWARD THAT BUDGET PLAN- BUT
CERTAINLY THE IDEA BEHIND
CAPTAIN TRADERS TO STEP AWAY
REDUCE THE NOT BE- EMISSIONS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OKAY SO
THEN IT IS. THERE'S AN
UNDERSTANDING. THAT THAT. IF
INTRIGUED BECOME IS EFFECTIVE
AND- WOULD. THAT THAT THE
MATTER REVENUE WILL PROBABLY
TAKE OVER TIME. CORRECT
CERTAINLY OVER OR TIME ALTHOUGH
THE CAP ALSO DECLINES OVER TIME
SO THEIR NUMBER OF SHIFTING
DYNAMICS- IN THE IN THE CAP AND
TRADE MARKET. RIGHT SO. I GUESS
I'M I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS RULE
MAKING- IS THAT WHY SHOULD.
THIS BE DONE IN THEBUDGET WE
SHOULD WOULDN'T IT BE BETTER.
DONE THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. ESPECIALLY IF. BY BY
REDESIGNING CAP AND TRADE AND-
AND IF THE IF THE IF THE GOAL
IS. EMISSIONS AND NOT REVENUES
THEN THAT WILL LEAD TO A
DIFFERENT- I GUESS A DIFFERENT.
DID WE DECIDE BUT YOU CAN'T
INCREASE REVENUES IN CAP AND
TRADE WITOUT. DIRECTLY
INCREASING THE COSTS. TO
CALIFORNIANS WHEN WRITTEN AT
LEAST WITH INTERVIEW AND IN
RELATIONSHIP TO- GAS PRICES
UTILITY BILLS TO YOU KNOW
WHATEVER COSTS. INTO THE
GENERATING ENERGY- SO I'M JUST
SO I UNDERSTAND. THE REDESIGN
WOULDN'T IT BE BETTER DONE- THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND NOT TO
THE BUDGET. SO I CAN'T SPEAK
WITH TO THAT BECAUSE IT'S SO.
PROPOSAL IN AND WAS NOT OF THAT
NEIGHBOR THAT THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED LAST MONTH- I THINK
GENERALLY FOR THE BUDGET YOU
KNOW WE ARE FOCUSED ON- THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THERE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED REVENUES.
NEXT YEAR WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE
OUR PAY AS YOU GO MACINNES THEM
I WILL SAY THAT- WHILE THAT
PRIMARY PURPOSE A CAP AND TRADE
IS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS
OVERTIME. AT THE REVENUE
GENERATED BY THOSE PROGRAMS-
DOES FIND SOME PRETTY IMPORTANT
INITIATIVES FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE
AND WE SAW IN OUR PROPOSAL TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THOSE THAT WE
BELIEVE ARE ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT SUCH AS COMMITTEE-
PROTECTION- FORCED A WILDFIRE
SAFETY. AND SAID IN A PORTABLE
DRINKING WATER SO WE ARE
COGNIZANT OF THE FACT THAT-
WHILE THE REVENUE CAN VARY OVER
TIME THEIR NUMBER OP IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS- THAT YOU RELY ON THAT
FUNDING BUT I'D BEYOND THAT I
DON'T WANT TO APPLY
SPECIFICALLY ON THE
LEGISLATIVE. SINCE IT WAS NOT
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD DO YOU KNOW
IF THE THAT THE LANGUAGE OF THE
PROPOSAL IS PERMISSIVE SO IF IT
HAPPENS TO BE THAT HERE BE.
ANALYZES THE CHANGES FINDS OF
TO BE DETRIMENTAL TO RATEPAYERS
ARE TO CALIFORNIA'S ARE TO COME
TO ENTITIES ARE INVOLVED IN THE
PROGRAM THAT WOULD IF THEY
CHOSE TO CLOSE THE RULE MAKING
WITH ACTION IS THAT POSSIBLE.
I'D HAVE. TO DOUBLE CHECK ON
THAT QUESTION. OKAY AT MID MAY
THIS IS A THAT I AM IF WANTED
TO. AT THE TIME AND IS. IT DO
THEY HAVE PURSUE. ON PROPOSED.
IS THIS AN ERROR THAT. SHOULD
GO THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND NOT THROUGH THE
BUDGET. AND OVERLOOKED. OH
SORRY. IF YOU START COME UP TO
JUST LOOK TALKING YEAH I KNOW I
THINK I WOULD ALSO NEED TO
CHECK WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON
THAT PARTICULAR QUESTION. I
MEAN I THINK WHETHER OR NOT YOU
WOULD WANT TO DO IT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS REALLY A
DECISION FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
MAKE I MEAN IT- PROVOCATIVE
WHETHER YOU WANT TO DO IT
THROUGH THE LEGEND THE- THE
POLICY PROCESS OR THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS. IS THE MEAN IS
IT IS IT MY INTERPRETATION
CORRECT THAT THAT A LOOK IF
THE BUDGET- LANGUAGE. WHO
DIRECTS THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO CONDUCT RULE MAKING THAT
WERE RELINQUISHING OUR ABILITY
TO. BASICALLY REVIEW AND
REDESIGNED CAP AND TRADE I WAS
PUT THE LEGISLATURE NEGOTIATED
YEARS AGO AND WE'RE GIVING THAT
POWER TO AN AGENCY WOULDN'T IS
A MY INTERPRETATION CORRECT
INCORRECT AND IN THAT AND IN
THIS MANNER. WELL I'M NOT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE THAT WILL THEM TO MY
KNOWLEDGE THAT THAT THAT
LANGUAGES AND NOT FINALIZED AT
THIS POINT SO I'D BE RELUCTANT
TO. SAY ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
BUT THERE'S ACT MY GUESS IS
THAT THAT CONCERNED THOUGH.
POSSIBLE ATTENTION EIGHT
PASSING OKAY NINE I THINK THAT
AND THAT I THINK THAT'S MY OF
MY PERSPECTIVE IS MY CONCERN
AND I AND I CAN ECHO WHAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- YOU COOPER
SAID IS THAT. A SO MUCH
HEARTACHE AND SO MUCH EFFORT
WENT INTO CAP AND TRADE OR WELL
I WASN'T I DON'T GET THEIR
OTHER MEMBERS DID AND INTO IS
TO NOW SOMEHOW. HAVE AN AGENCY
BE ASKED TO CONDUCT RULE MAKING
AT A TIME WHEN THAT PROBABLY
SHOULD BE WITHIN THE PURVIEW
THE LEGISLATURE I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER MOORE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A
UNLESS LIKE TO PIGGY BACK ON
MISTER COOPER MISTER FARMS
QUESTIONS ABOUT CAP AND TRADE
BECAUSE I THINK MOST OF THE
PEOPLE ON THE DíAS HERE WERE
OF MEMBERS THE LEGISLATURE WHEN
THAT PACKAGE WAS NEGOTIATED AND
I WE- WE HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR
THE PURPOSE OF CAP AND TRADE IS
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND THEY REVENUE THAT
RAISE THAT GETS RAISED IS KIND
OF AN ANCILLARY BENEFIT FROM
THE STATE'S PERSPECTIVE SO IT
REALLY KIND OF ANGERS ME. TO
HEAR THE PART IN A FINANCIAL
PINE THAT WE NEED TO MAKE
CHANGES STRUCTURALLY TO THE
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT'S NOT
RAISING OF REVENUE- YOU KNOW
THE FACT THAT WE'RE SELLING
FEWER THAN THE NUMBER OF
EMISSIONS ALLOWANCES THAT WE
HAVE ON THE MARKET IS A GOOD
THING IT MEANS THAT GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS ARE DECLINING
AND- THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK
WE SHOULD CELEBRATE AND NOT TRY
TO FIX- I HAD A QUESTION FOR
THE LA- ABOUT THAT BECAUSE WE I
DON'T THINK WE CAN FORGET. YOU
KNOW WHAT BEFORE FOR MOVE OFF
THE TOPIC IT OVER TO OKAY THE
PROGRAMS A GIFT OUT OF CARE AND
TRADE REVENUES YOU ONE OF THEM
IS HIGH SPEED RAIL GOT A 20%
STATURE TO APPROPRIATION FROM
THAT THOSE FUNDS EVERY YEAR AND
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THAT IS ONE PROGRAM AMONG
ALL THESE COPS ALL BUT CERTAIN
PEOPLE AND. WE'RE WE'RE SO ON
THIS DIET. ABOUT TO EDUCATION
TALKED TELECOM TO HELPING
SERVICE. YOU KNOW HOW RIGHT NOW
SPEED RAIL IS COMPLETE
UNTOUCHED. SO IF YOU WANT TO
SUGGESTION A PROBE. THAT YOU
KNOW MAYBE IF THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM IS HURTING. FOR MAYBE
THAT'S WHAT WE ON A LOW AT OUR
POSTER ONE I JUST WANT. ONE
VERY QUICKLY I BELIEVE THAT.
THE ALTHOUGH I MAYBE MISSED. I
BELIEVE IS A- PROPOSAL FOR
REGARDING AT HOW TO RESPOND IF
THERE IS LESS REVENUE THAN WE
ORIGINALLY ANTICIPATED. BUT I
BELIEVE THAT WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO A IS IN FACT A
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL THAT WE
HAVE NOT YET. YEAH ABSOLUTELY I
WILL I'M AWARE OF THAT I'M NOT
GOING TO BEAT UP ON YOU ABOUT
THAT THE DIET WAS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IT JUST OPINED. IN
ANSWERING MISTER COOPER'S
QUESTION. YOU KNOW THAT THAT
THE PURPOSE OF THE PROGRAM WAS
TO CREATE REVENUE AND THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S WHAT GOT ME GOING
I'M SORRY. IF I IF YOU HEARD
THAT I THAT'S NOT. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT I'M REPURPOSE
OKAY HAPPEN TRADE IS TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF A MISSION. AND I
WANT TO GOOD HERE. I ALSO MIND
EVERY. THAT IT THAT IS EIGHT.
THAT WE HAVE CREATED FOR THESE.
MISSIONS ALLOWANCES AND IN ALSO
PARK FREE MARKET. APPLY HERE.
PART OF THE WITH THE-
LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSAL HERE. IS
TO RAISE THE FLOOR PRICE. FOR
THESE ALLOWANCES AND SO I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR MR PADDOCK YOU
GIVEN THAT THIS IS A FREE
MARKET SITUATION WOULDN'T
RAISING THE FLOOR PROGRESS.
RESULT IN FEWER ALLOWANCES.
SOLD TIONS. IT'S NOT A- I SEE
WHAT. TO THE MARKET. THE I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE A
REASONABLE INTERPRETATION. OKAY
LET'S HOME ON THE MARKET IS
THAT IF WE MOVE FOR WITH THIS
PER. WHICH I THINK CAME OVER
FROM THIS IN WE ARE NOT
GUARANTEED THAT THIS GOING TO
PRODUCE MORE REVS AT MY PRETTY
ROUTE LIE REVENUE IF YOU RAISE
THE PRICE OF SOMETHING PEOPLE
BUY LESS OF IT AND SO I THINK
TO ASSUME THE JUST RAISING THE
FOR PRICE IS GOING TO RESULT IN
THE RESTORATION OF THE FUNDING
TO THE PROGRAMS IN THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM I THINK THAT
THAT'S FOOLISH. I'M WELL I GOT
YOU MISTER PATRICK- I WANTED TO
ASK ABOUT. THE FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF SOME OF THE
THINGS LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSING
TO DO IN THIS BUDGET SO- WHEN
WE FIRST WERE EXAMINING THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE I
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE AMOUNT OF. THEIR PHONE
BORROWING- THE GOVERNOR HE
PROPOSED OVER TEN BILLION
DOLLARS OF INTER FUND BORROWING
THAT MONEY'S GOT TO BE PAID
BACK. WE'RE BORROWING FROM
FUNDS WITH RESTRICTED USES
PUTTING THAT MONEY THE GENERAL
FUND. AND WE HAVE TO PAY THAT
MONEY BACK IN THE FUTURE SO I
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE GOING TO BE
UNDER THE LEGISLATURE'S
PROPOSAL. BORROWING OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS MORE- ALSO
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF DEFERRALS I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY TO FOR OVER JUST
PAYING MONEY WILL. WORK JUST
PAYING OUR BILLS A DAY LATE SO
WE CAN SAY THAT THEIR NEXT
YEAR'S BILLS. INSTEAD OF THIS
YEAR'S BILLS THAT MIGHT HELP US
THIS YEAR DOES NOT HELP US NEXT
YEAR MAKES THINGS WORSE. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN DEFERRALS-
WE'RE DOUBLING DOWN ON THAT
GIMMICK WE WANT TO- IF THE
FEDERAL TRIGGERED. GETS AN
ACTED WE WANT TO BORROW OVER-TEN. BILLION DOLLARS AND
DEFERRALS. SO I I'M I'M
WONDERING BECAUSE MISTER. THIS
ONE EATEN UP. RAISE THE POINT
IN HIS OPENING. THAT THAT WE'RE
ALL CONCERNED ABOUT LONG TERM
STRUCTURAL BUDGET DEFICITS HERE
IN THESE THINGS THAT. WE'RE
PROPOSING TO DO THE BUDGET MAKE
THAT PROBLEM WORSE NOT BETTER
SO- IN YOUR OPINION IS THIS OR
IS IT OR IS RESPONSIBLE STEPS
TO TAKE. I THERE'S A- OF. I
WOULD MAY ABOUT INTEREST. TO
THAT MR OBERNOLTE. THE FIRST IS
THAT THE STATE IS LIKELY TO BE
FACING A STRUCTURAL PROBLEM
UNDER ALMOST ANY OF THE
SCENARIOS THAT. ARE WE ARE ALL
CONSIDERING TODAY. UNDER THE
MAY REVISION UNDER THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE. AND UNDER
THIS SCENARIO IN WHICH WE EVEN
GET ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE MOST LIKELY ALMOST
CERTAINLY THAT FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE WOULD BE LIMITED
TERM IN NATURE ONE OR TWO YEARS
AT THE MOST AND SO. AT THAT
POINT THERE COULD BE
ADDITIONAL- STRUCTURAL PRESSURE
ON THE BUDGET. I THINK AS
MISTER MISS WHEN A THIN SAID-
BUT YOU KNOW HE'S CORRECT THAT-
THAT- THE- YOU KNOW THE FUTURE.
BUDGET OUTLOOK IS THAT TERE IS
NOT A- YOU KNOW. BASED ON OUR
CURRENT ASSUMPTIONS IN WHAT WE
HAVE WITH THE INFORMATION WE
HAVE TODAY. THERE WOULD BE A
BUDGET PROBLEM IN THE OUT
YEARS- IT. UNDER PRETTY MUCH
ANY OF THESE SCENARIOS SO WITH
THAT SAID. THEN THE QUESTION
IS- I THINK ONE OF BALANCE IN
WHAT I HAVE SORT OF THE
LEGISLATIVE. COLLECTIVELY
WHAT'S THE LEGISLATURE'S RISK
TOLERANCE AND TO THE EXTENT YOU
USE MORE OF THE ONE TIME
RESOURCES NOW. IT DOES- REDUCE
PROBABLY THE HUMAN TOLL THAT IS
BEING TAKEN BY THE EFFECTS OF
THE COVERT NINETEEN AND THE
RECESSION. ON PEOPLE THAT ARE-
BENEFICIARIES OF STATE PROGRAMS
SO YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT'S-
CLEARLY ONE CONSIDERATION BUT
THEN ON THE ON THE OTHER HAND
IF YOUR VIEW IS THAT THE
ECONOMY WILL STILL BE IN IT YOU
KNOW DEPRESSED CONDITION NEXT
YEAR AT THIS TIME. WE WILL HAVE
FEWER- ONE TIME RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO US AND THEN MORE
ONGOING TYPES OF SOLUTIONS
WOULD THEN BE NECESSARY. IF ON
THE OTHER HAND YOU FELT THAT
THE ECONOMY IS- ITS JUST AT
SOME LEVEL REACHING- TROUGH
HERE IN THE IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF MONTHS AND THAT WE WILL
BEGIN TO RECOVER AND BY NEXT
YEAR AT THIS TIME THE ECONOMY
IS IN A- MUCH MORE OF A GROWTH
MODE. THOSE KIND OF SOLUTIONS
WOULD BE LESS LESS NEEDED BUT I
DON'T THINK ANY OF US KNOW AT
THIS TIME WHAT THAT WILL WHAT
THAT WILL LOOK LIKE- AND SO TO
SOME EXTENT IT REALLY EPENDS I
THINK ON YOUR- WILLINGNESS TO
ASSUME THAT SOME AMOUNT OF
RISK. ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
OUTLOOK AT THIS POINT. THANK
YOU ARE YOU KNOW I JUST WANT
EVERYONE TO FOCUS ON THE AMOUNT
OF RISK THAT WE'RE CONSIDERING
TAKING HERE WE'RE TALKING AT
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS. EVEN
WHEN THINGS WERE GOING WELL WE
HAD ABOUT A SIX BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET SURPLUS THIS YEAR THAT
WAS A BACK IN JANUARY I MEAN
THAT MEANS THAT IF AT THAT
LEVEL OF ECONOMIC GROWTH IT
WOULD TAKE US THREE AND A HALF
YEARS TO PAY THAT MONEY BACK-
AND IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
SNORT. WE DON'T HAVE ECONOMIC
GROWTH THAT THAT'S GOING TO BE
THE THAT'S GOING TO TAKE EVEN
LONGER AND THAT'S JUST A ONE
YEAR PROBLEM IF YOU'RE ASSUME
IF YOU'RE- ASSUMING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT AS BOTH THE ONLY WHEN
THE DEAL AFTER. PROJECT FOR
THIS YEAR I MEAN THE WE'RE
GOING TO BE. BE BACK NEXT YEAR
WE'RE TO KICK THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD THE WAS JUST GONNA BIGGER
SAY THAT'S MIKE ABOUT THAT AND
LAST BUT FOR MISTER THIS ONE
EITHER YOU KNOW BUT SENATE
OPENING ABOUT. YOU TALK ABOUT
OPTIMISM THAT. FEDERAL WOULD
ACT AND WILL PROVIDE ADDITION.
FEDERAL FUNDING PENDANT ACOSTA
IT'S- AND I'M ON IF YOU COULD
ALLOW A LITTLE BIT A WHAT LEVEL
OF. IS THAT THE GOING TO. ASK I
DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE A GREAT
AUNT TO THAT. I WOULD SAY IN
THE LAST DAYS WE'VE SO HOPEFUL
SIGNALS OUR PARTNER AND WATCH
DC. AND IT DOES THAT SOME KIND
OF PATH DOES TO BE MOVING
PERHAPS ON A MORE BIPARTISAN
BASIS THEN WE MIGHT HAVE
EXPECTED A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
THAT BEING SAID AT THE REASON
ARMY REVISION- STARTS WITH THE
TRIGGER CUTS IF THE FUNDING IT
DOES NOT COME IN ON JULY FIRST
IS BECAUSE- THE GOVERNOR'S
BELIEF WAS A WASTE WHEN HE PUT
UP IN A REVISION ON MAY
FOURTEENTH. THAT WHILE WE ARE
HOPING AND PUSHING FOR
CONGRESSIONAL ACTION WE
COULDN'T COUNT ON IT AT THAT
TIME THE SIGNALS IN THE LAST
COUPLE WEEKS HAVE CERTAINLY
GOTTEN BETTER BUT- AT THIS
POINT I WOULD STILL DESCRIBE
THIS IS VERY CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC. OKAY I HOPE YOU'RE
RIGHT- I'M I'M A LITTLE MORE
PESSIMISTIC THAN YOU ARE ONLY
BECAUSE LOOKING AT THE
CONGRESSIONAL CALENDAR IT SEEMS
TO ME LIKE- THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES ONLY IN SESSION
THIRTEEN DAYS BETWEEN NOW AND
THE TRIGGER DATE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SET UP OF THE FIRST
OF SEPTEMBER. SO THAT'S IMPLIED
HAVE REALLY SHORT TIME HORIZON
TO ENACT SUCH A MOMENTOUS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION SO I WILL
CERTAINLY FIND OUT BUT I WANNA
CAUTIOUS ALL OF CAUTION ALL OF
US THAT. THE PRETENDING THAT
THIS IS GOING TO THE PRETENDING
THERE'S A HOW 2% CHANCE OF THIS
HAPPENING IS VERY ANALYZE.
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I THINK YOU WERE GONNA GOODNESS
MCCARTY NEXT. THE YOU AND
MISTER CHAIR I I'VE SERIES OF
HERE BUT I THINK I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT EVERY
VOTE WE TAKE UP HERE IS A RISK
AND REWARD WE HAVE TO ANALYZE
THE DOWNSIDES. AND OF COURSE
THE UP SIDES AND I DON'T KNOW
WE CAN CONSIDER THIS A PURITY
TEST FOR AN AUSTERITY BUDGET
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE FLIP SIDE
BECAUSE- THIS ISN'T A TYPICAL
RECESSION. WE'VE HAD IN THE
PAST FEW DECADES THIS IS ONE
THAT WAS BORN BY S. LITERALLY
TURNING OFF THE ECONOMY SO IF
WE WANT TO GET PEOPLE BACK TO
WORK GET CONSUMER SPENDING BACK
GOING GETTING OUR R. HEALTHCARE
NETWORK- WORKING PROPERLY AS
DOCTOR ARAMBULA SAID THESE ARE
CHOICES WE HAVE TO MAKE SO-
KEEPING THE STATE OF FLOAT. AND
KEEPING OUR SYSTEMS OF LOW THAT
MAKE CALIFORNIA AT WORK AND
HAVE PEOPLE GO BACK TO WORK IS
A CHOICE WE'RE MAKING- SO I
THINK THAT YOU HAVE TO ALSO
LOOK AT THE FLIP SIDE IF WE
DIDN'T MAKE THESE CHOICES. OURS
IS OUR ECONOMY GONNA BE
FLOUNDERING FOR YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD I THINK DURING LAST
RECESSION WHENEVER NOTABLE
ECONOMISTS AS OUR OUR BUDGETARY
REMINDS US FROM- UC BERKELEY%
DOCTOR D'ANDREA TYSON TALKED
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
STYLIST WAS WELL ABLE TO RE. US
QUICKLY WE MAY SO MUCH
DRACONIAN CUTS TO ALL PROGRAMS
THAT JUST YOU KNOW KEEP
CALIFORNIA. SO I THINK WE JUST
BE MINDFUL ABOUT THAT THE
CHOICES WE MAKE. YOU KNOW FOCUS
ON THE BIG PICTURE AS WELL I DO
HAVE. A FEW QUESTIONS I WANT TO
START RIGHT HERE WITH MY OWN
DISTRICT- THE STATE CAPITAL OF
COURSE- BIG PART OF OUR
CONSTITUENCY OUR OUR STATE
WORKERS. AND IN THE PROPOSAL IN
IN- IN THE MAY REVISED YOU PUSH
FOR THAT AT THAT 10% POTENTIAL-
CUT TO. STATE WORKER SALARY IN
IT WOULD GENERATE A ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION. I THINK WE PULL
BACK A LITTLE BIT OUR BUDGET
DOESN'T DOESN'T- AS ALIEN NOTES
DOESN'T ASSUME THAT AMOUNT AND-
WOULD- PUT TIS TO THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS I
THINK THE- THE LOCAL ENTITIES.
LED BY S. C. ONE THOUSAND. ARE
TALKING ABOUT OTHER WAYS TO
HAVE TO HELP THE STATE AND THIS
IS LOW PREMATURE TO BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH WE'RE
GETTING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO HELP US BRIDGE
NEXT COUPLE YOURSELF. ONE OF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE COULD AND
LIGHTNESS WE'RE AT WITH OUR
STATE WORKERS. YES SO I CAN
ONLY SPEAK ON IT VERY AT
GENERAL LEVEL I'LL MAKE TWO
POINTS I THINK NUMBER ONE OUR
POSITION- IS ALSO WITH REGARD
TO THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
PROCESS THAT THAT IS WHERE WE
DO WANT TO. ACHIEVE THOSE
SAVINGS SO FOR THAT 10% OF
REDUCTION- THAT'S ASSUMED IN
THE BUDGET BUT IN TERMS OF HOW
IT GETS DONE- WE ARE HOPING TO
ACHIEVE THAT AT THE BARGAINING
TABLE OFFER ALL THE- BARGAINING
UNITS- AND THAT'S- THE SECOND
POINT I'LL MAKE IS WITH REGARD
TO THE FEDERAL FUNDING THAT.
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING- THAT IS
ONE OF THE TRIGGER POT SO IF
WASHINGTON DC DOES COME.
FORWARD WITH THE REQUISITE
LEVEL OF STATE AND LOCAL
ASSISTANCE DâN THAT THOSE
CUTS- WOULD BE RESTORED. OKAY
SO WHAT'S THE TIME LINE FOR ALL
THAT HAPPENING I'LL GET ON THE
MAY REVISE YOU YOU PUT AN AD
NUMBER IN THERE AND AMOUNTS AND
IT KIND OF SET DIFFERENT
EXPECTATIONS SO HOW DOES THAT.
HOW HOW'S THAT EVOLVED IN THE
LAST. MONTH SO I CAN I. WOULD
HAVE TO CHECK THAT WITH OURS
FOLKS OR WORKING WITH PEOPLE
THE BARGAINING SO LET ME BACK
TO THAT OKAY I WANTED TO. NOW
THE REVENUE ISSUES REVENUE
IDEAS I KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ELK GROVE REYES
SAID CONCERNS AS FAR AS THE
IMPACT OF CERTAIN INDUSTRIES. I
KNOW THERE ARE ARE ARE MANY
PEOPLE LEGISLATURE THAT WANT TO
PUT. EVEN MORE REVENUE IDEAS ON
THE TABLE POTENTIALLY GO TO THE
BALLOT TO REALLY LOOK AT. THE
OVERALL- FUNDING FOR. KEY
PROGRAMS LIKE EDUCATION OUR
STATE AND I BY PERSONALLY
SUPPORT THAT LOOKING AT AT
REVENUE INCREASES BUT- I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT-
THIS IS AGAIN ABOUT CHOICES AND
RISK REWARD DO WE WANT TO KEEP
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
FLOAT. WHICH IS THE MAJOR ARE
INDEED DRIVER FOR OUR FOR OUR
STATE. OUR C. S. YOUR COMMITTEE
COLLEGES ARE CAR K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS AND SO. HAVING THAT
TIME OUT ON THESE FOR A NUMBER
OF US SEVERAL YEARS AND NOT BE
THE PERMANENT IN THE NATION. I
THINK IS THE CHOICE THAT WE
HAVE TO MAKE SO WE CANNOT DO
THAT. AND WE CAN WE CAN SAY
OKAY WE'RE NOT GOING TO THAT
AND I WOULD JUST TELL PEOPLE
WHO ARGUE THAT. OKAY GIVE US
THE CUTS GIVE US TO GIVE US THE
PLACES YOU WANT TO CUT. YOU
WANT TO CUT WHEN WHAT'S THE
AMOUNT AGAIN ON THE OTHER DAY
FOR THE NEW REVENUES TOGETHER
IT'S ABOUT A LITTLE OVER FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR.
KERR US SO IT CHANGES YEAR TO
YEAR BUT IN THE COMING YEAR
IT'LL BE FOUR POINT FOUR BILL
OKAY YEAH. SO I SENSUALLY AS
THE STATE EQUIVALENT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. SO IF
THERE'S ANOTHER WAY TO GO ABOUT
DOING THAT. I'M ALL YOURS BUT-
I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A
REALITY CHECK ON JUST THE
SIMPLE MATHEMATICS SO THAT- I
ALSO WANT TO JUST. A LIEU THAT
I DO SUPPORT HOW WE'RE RE
EVALUATING THAT THAT CAP AND
TRADE- PLAN IN OUR PROPOSAL BUT
I WILL NOTE THAT I AM. VERY
VERY UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE
HIGH SPEED EL. AUTOMATIC I'M
25% OFF THE BOARD AND I'M
WAITING FOR THE MOMENT RIGHT
CAN VOTE TO. RESEND THAT I
THINK THAT WE ARE BETTER WAYS
TO SPEND THAT MONEY THAT FOCUS
ON OUR NEED. EVEN AND WELL AND
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION AND
TRANSIT. AND COMMUTER RAIL FROM
HERE TO THE BAY AREA FROM LA TO
ORANGE. COUNTY UP AND DOWN THE
ON. THIS THE CENTRAL VALLEY THE
ARE THERE ARE THERE ARE MY
BETTER. TO ON THOSE DAHLE. ON
COMMUTER RAIL THEY CAN ACTUALLY
WORK. THAT WERE POPULAR BASES
LIVE. AND WE HAVE A BIGGER
IMPACT ON REDUCING. OUR CARBON
FOOTPRINT IN CALIFORNIA SO I DO
CONCUR ON THAT- I WANT TO NOW
SHE HAVE TO THE AREA THAT I
FOCUSED MONTHS. MOST ON THE
BUDGET AND THAT'S- EDUCATION
FROM EARLY EDUCATION THROUGH.
THROUGH HIGHER IN K. TWELVE IN
THE MIDDLE- YOU KNOW THE CUTS
POTENTIAL CUTS IN THE TRIGGER
FOR. THAT THEY MAY REVISE. I
THINK. JUST A CUT IN AND OF
ITSELF. THE PEOPLE ARE
EVERYONE'S AGAINST THE CUT AND
I GUESS PEOPLE WOULD HAVE TWO
REASONS I DON'T LIKE THE CATS
ONE. THEY KNOW IT'S CAN IMPACT
A PERSON. AT YOU KNOW FIFTIES.
THOUSAND TEACHERS LOSE THEIR
JOBSAND THE KERR MAY REVISE A
PUZZLE. HUNDRED THOUSAND
CLASSIFIED WORKERS FROM.
CLASSMATES BUS DRIVERS
CAFETERIA WORKERS THAT'S A
PERSON THAT WOULD THAT WOULD
PHYSICALLY LOSE THEIR JOB AND
SO THAT YOU KNOW YOU KNOW WARES
ON PEOPLE MAKING DECISIONS- AND
THEN WE ALL BELIEVE IN THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY PROVIDE. SO
WE GET THAT BUT I THINK THE
BIGGER ICTURE WHAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER. IS THAT. THESE CUTS
DON'T JUST HAVE THOSE TWO
IMPACTS THEY HAVE THE IMPACT
THAT THEY WOULD. SLOW DOWN OUR
ABILITY TO TURN THE ECONOMY
BACK ON BECAUSE- YOU KNOW MY
FAMILY. FAMILIES ALL ACROSS
ACKERMAN AND CALIFORNIA.SCHOOL
AND CHILD CARE DEPEND ON PEOPLE
GOING BACK TO WORK PEOPLE
PARENTS ARE LITTLE A STRADDLED.
IN THEIR HOMES BECAUSE THEY
NEED TO BE. CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS NEED TO BE THE HOME
SCHOOL TEACHER. AND HOW DO
PEOPLE GET BACK AT IT HOW DO WE
TURN OUR ECONOMY BACK ON WITH
SO MANY PEOPLE IN THE WORKING
COHORT. AGE YOU KNOW PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THEIR PRIME WORKING
YEARS. A LOT OF THEM WE NOW
HAVE CHILDREN SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIA KIDS IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
IN OUR CHILD CARE PROGRAMS AND
SO. IF WE DON'T ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE CAN'T TURN THAT LIGHT
SWITCH BACK ON- TO THE ECONOMY
SO. THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT EASY TO
DO THE DEFERRALS. BUT WHAT'S
THE ALTERNATIVE GET GET AN
AWARD PAT ON THE BACK FOR THE
AUSTERITY BUDGET. AND SHUT DOWN
SCHOOLS IN CHILD CARE CENTERS.
THAT'S NOT GONNA HELP. TURN THE
ECONOMY BACK ON SO I THINK YOU
NEED A REALITY CHECK THEIR- AS
WELL. AND THEN I WILL NOTE
THAT- WITH OUR SCHOOLS I'VE
BEEN TALKING TO OUR DISTRICTS
AND TO PROTECT ALL ACROSS THE
STATE FROM MANY OF. OUR
DISTRICTS HERE MY COLLEAGUES
HERE AND THERE'S- A LOT
UNANSWERED QUESTION AS FAR AS
NOT JUST MONEY. AND HOW THAT
WOULD WORK THEY DO PREFER OUR
PLAN MORE THE- LAST CUTS BUT-
THAT THE CONCLUSION IS. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO MORE. WITH
LESS- HERE IN SACRAMENTO THEY
JUST UNVEILED WHAT HOW THEY
WOULD DO ARE. STAGGERED SCHOOL
SCHEDULE AND- MORE RESOURCES
NEEDED AND SO THAT THIS THE RE
OPENING OF THE SCHOOLS AND SOME
IN THE GOVERNOR. IS WORKING ON
WITH OUR SUPERINTENDENT AND-
WE'RE TRYING TO TIME IT BECAUSE
THE SCHOOL YEARS COMING UP AND
WE'RE DOING THE BUDGET SAME
TIME BUT THERE ARE SO MANY.
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
RE OPENING OF THE SCHOOLS I
JUST WANTED TO ASK YOU IF YOU
COULD. HELP AND LIGHTNESS AND
THAT'S ON THIS FRONT. YEAH SO I
KNOW THAT WILL BE HAVE JESSICA
HOMES ON THE LINE I KNOW THAT
GUIDANCE IS FORTHCOMING BUT LET
ME TURN IT OVER TED JESSICA
HOMES TO SPEAK ABOUT THAT THE
RE OPENING CONSIDERATION
SPECIFICALLY. AT HOME
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER MCCARTY FOR
YOUR QUESTION SO AS YOU
MENTIONED YES WE ARE WORKING.
ON VERY. DILIGENTLY AWAY AT THE
SUPERINTENDENT AS WELL AS A
VARIETY OF STAKEHOLDERS THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND DEVELOP SOME GUIDELINES FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR. WE
OPENING TO ENSURE HEALTH AND
SAFETY THAT FAMILIES FEEL
COMFORTABLE PAYING THEIR-
STUDENT BACK TO SCHOOL- WE ARE
PLANNING TO RELEASE THOSE. THAT
VERY SHORTLY- AND ALSO LOOKING
AT THE ISSUE OF- APPLYING AT-
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
FOR- SCHOOL DOES NOT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THE CONCERN-
AMONG OUR SCHOOLS. AND CHILD
CARE CENTERS BUT THOSE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
RIGHT NOW AND WE HOPE TO-
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION- ON
VERY SHORTLY. OKAY THE NEXT
QUESTION AS FAR AS THE
EDUCATION I WANTED TO LIEU TO
IS- RELATED FLEXIBILITY FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SORT OUR LAST
RECESSION BEFORE YOU AND I WERE
HERE. THE WE- OF COURSE WE HAD
REDUCTIONS BUT WE ALSO YOU
KNOW. LACKS THE MONEY GIVE THEM
WITH ALL THOSE CATEGORICAL IS
GIVE THEM MORE AUTHORITY TO
MOVE MONEY AROUND. TO
ESSENTIALLY YOU KNOW STAY ALIVE
DURING THOSE TOUGH TIMES AND SO
I'VE HEARD THAT REQUEST IN THE
NUMBER THE LAST FEW DAYS OF NOT
JUST THE MONEY PEACE BUT WHAT
CAN THE STATE DO AS FAR AS-
FLEXIBILITY FROM OTHER.
EDUCATION POTS AND ONE TIME AND
CARRY OVER MONEY AND WHAT CAN
WE DO TO HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SO THAT SOMETHING THAT WE THINK
WE BE WILLING TO ENTERTAIN AS
WE FINALIZE. EITHER THIS BUDGET
HERE OR EVEN AFTER AT THE NEXT
WHO DO I TRAILER BILLS AND
CLEAN UP IN THE WEEKS AFTER.
YEAH SO WHAT JESSICA SPEAKER
THAT IN THE ONE- POINT ALTHOUGH
THE WAY MAJOR DIFFERENCE HERE
COMPARED TO THE LAST RECESSION
IS THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WHICH ON THE NATURAL
WILL PROVIDE DISTRICTS MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND THEY HAD. A
DECADE AGO BUTLET ME TURN IT
OVER TO JUST GO TO SPEAK ABOUT
THE SPECIFICS. THANK YOU YES
AND SO I WOULD MENTION THAT WE
DO HAVE WE HAVE BUILT THEM
FLEXIBILITY IS AND THEN THE
REVISION- YOU KNOW ONE EXAMPLE
OF THE FLEXIBILITY TO BE
INCLUDED. RELATE TO ENTER FUND
BORROWING AND PROVIDING MORE-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO DO YOU ENTER FUND
BY ROWING TO HELP TO MITIGATE
THE IMPACT WITH. POTENTIAL
REDUCTION BUT WE ARE WE HAVE
RECEIVED CONTINUOUS AD
RESPONSE FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING WITH
LEGISLATIVE STAFF ABOUT- OTHER
POTENTIAL POSSIBILITIES THAT I
KNOW THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTERESTED IN. ADOPTING AND WE
CAN KEY THE CONVERSATION.
INTERESTED IN ENSURING THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICT HAVE AS MUCH
FLEXIBILITY AS POSSIBLE- I
WOULD ALSO ADD TO MISTER GIBSON
OFTEN AND COMMENT ABOUT IN THE
DIFFERENCE BEING LPS PATH I
WOULD TO THE OTHER DIFFERENT.
I'M IN THE COPA NINETEEN-
PANDEMIC AND HOW THAT HAS.
MAYBE CHANGE SOME OF THE NEEDS
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS- IN TERMS
OF FLEXIBILITY SO WE'RE WE'RE
CONSIDERING ALL THAT AND-
WORKING HARD WITH BUT YOUR
STAFF. OKAY I JUST ON THAT NO
WE DO KNOW THAT THEY'LL SEE A
FAT. CERTAINLY HAS MORE
FLEXIBILITY BUT I THINK THERE
ARE SOME. PROPOSALS AND-
TWEAKING THAT WORK THAT TO.
WHETHER IT'S- SCHOOL ACTS- THAT
YOU KNOW SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION AND- THE YOU KNOW
THE RECORD FILE TEACHERS A
CLASSIFIED. EMPLOYEES ARE KIND
OF COALESCING AROUND SOME IDEAS
HOW WE CAN FURTHER THAT
FLEXIBILITY. I WANT TO- PAY A
LITTLE BIT TO HIGHER EDUCATION
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES. IT WILL
BE PUT TO. THE WILL THE THEY
MAY REVISE I THINK HAD REALLY
TOUGH CHOICES FOR AT ALL
EVERYBODY AND THOSE TRIGGERS
WOULD HAVE BEEN. DISASTROUS FOR
SCHOOLS EARLY AT HIGHER AND
COMMITTEE CALL JUST. I THINK
THAT WE'RE VERY PLEASED ABOUT
THE OBVIOUSLY WE EMBRACE IT
TODAY THE ASSEMBLY SENATE
PACKAGE- THE ONE THAT WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO FIND- ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO. IT IN MY IN MY
OPINION IS OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ASSUMING THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACKNOWLEDGE. AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
WE MADE THAT THE CHOICE AND
IT'S YOU KNOW SOME PEOPLE- MAY
NOT LIKE IT BUT I THINK THE
MAJORITY LEGISLATURE BIPARTISAN
THOUGHT IT WAS THE RIGHT CALL.
TO ELIMINATE THE EXPERIMENT OF
CALIBRATE- WE'VE ALLOCATE LAST
TWO BUDGETS OVER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING AND
ONE TIME. TO SERVE. UP SEVENTY
FIVE STUDENTS TO HAVE YOU KNOW.
EXECUTIVES WITH ALMOST THAT WAY
MORE SALARY IN THE GOVERNOR I'M
NOT SURE HOW MUCH IT IS MAYBE
ALMOST ON- POTENTIALLY DOUBLE
WHAT ARE GOVERNOR MAKES. TO
SERVE SEVENTY FIVE STUDENTS AND
SO SERVING SEVENTY FIVE
STUDENTS OR SERVING TWO POINT
ONE MILLION WE THINK OUR
PRIORITIES WE SHOULD PROP UP.
HELPING THE TWO POINT ONE.
MILLION STUDENTS WHO ARE ALL
DOING ONLINE RIGHT NOW SO WE
THOUGHT THT WAS THE RIGHT
CALL. TO HELP THAT WITH THOSE
EXISTING STUDENTS AND PROP UP
THE ONLINE- PROGRAM WE HAVE FOR
EXISTING COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
SYSTEM AND SO- WHEN TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE BE- CAN PUT THAT
ON THE RECORD TODAY. LASTLY I
JUST WANTED TO LAY OUT. AND
THEN ASK YOU- YOUR YOUR YOUR
THOUGHTS I KNOWING YOU'RE
NEGOTIATING RIGHT NOW WITH OUR
WITH OUR LEADERSHIP FROM THE
SPEAKER IN THE PRO TEM ON THE
CELL- I WANT TO RESPECT THAT
PROCESS. BUT WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE- RELATE TO EARLY
EDUCATION LIKE I SAID EARLIER
WE REALIZE IT'S NOT JUST
IMPORTANT NOT JUST IMPORTANT
THAT THE FIRST FEW YEARS OF A
CHILD'S BRAIN AND HELPING
PARENTS GO TO WORK AND BEING AN
ANTI POVERTY PROGRAM AND ALL
THE REASONS WE SUPPORT EARLY
AND WHAT REALLY MATTERS BUT WE
THINK. IT'S SO KEY FOR PEOPLE
TO GET BACK TO WORK AND SO WE
COULDN'T STOP- A PICKUP
APPROVED REGARDLESS OF TRIGGER
Nó TRIGGER THOSE CUTS TO CHILD
CARE IN FULL DAY PRE SCHOOL
PROGRAMS THAT THEY'RE BARELY
AFLOAT NOW BEFORE THAT PANDEMIC
AND- THE FINANCIALLY DON'T
CANCEL OUT AND SELL THAT WOULD
JUST BE- YOU KNOW THE DEATH
SENTENCE TO SOME OF THOSE
PROGRAMS AND JUST FURTHER
HAMPER OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY-
WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT THERE'S
GOING TO BE IN NEXT- HEROES
BACK AT THE CONGRESSIONAL
LEVEL. AND ONE THING THAT AS
BEEN BIPARTISAN SO FAR IS EARLY
EDUCATION FROM THE
CONGRESSIONAL LEVEL FROM
REPUBLICANS FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE IN DID DEMOCRATS AS WELL
AND SO ONE THING THAT WE WANT
TO DO IS TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN
PRE PROGRAM NOT IN FOCUS ON
ACCESS NOT JUST KEEPING A FLOW
BUT HOW DO WE SERVE. MORE
PEOPLE WHO ARE IS TO WORKERS
AND YOU KNOW PRETTY MUCH THE
PEOPLE WHO GO TO THE STATE
FUNDED CHILDCARE PROGRAMS. OVER
I THINK TO ARE BY DEAF THE
SENSE OF WORKERS EITHER IN
HEALTH CARE OR THAT SERVICE
FIELD AND YOU KNOW THERE'S A
HUGE NEED. AND SO AS FAR AS-
ACCESS AND SLOTS AND-
STABILIZING THE RATES TO MAKE
SURE THEY ACTUALLY- CANCEL OUT
AND CAN STAY AFLOAT FINANCIALLY
AND JUST OVERALL INFRASTRUCTURE
SO- WE PUT FOR THAT A PROPOSAL
IN OUR PLAN AND YOU KNOW WE
THINK THAT IT IS NOT JUST RIGHT
FOR THE MORAL REASONS BUT RIGHT
FOR OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY. AND
WANTED TO ASK YOU IF YOU HAD
INITIAL THOUGHTS ON THAT. YEAH
I'LL SAY VERY BRIEFLY- AND I
KNOW JUST ON THE LINE AS WELL
THAT THAT GOVERNOR SHARES OF
COURSE SO MANY OF THE ARGUMENTS
THAT YOU JUST MADE AND ONE
THING YOU MADE IN PARTICULAR
ABOUT FEDERAL FUNDING IS IN
ADDITION. TO THE FLEXIBLE
RELIEF THAT WE ARE ALL HOPING
FOR AT THE GOVERNOR IS ALSO
APPRECIATED THE EXTRA FUNDING
FOR THE CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT
BLOCK GRANT THAT CONGRESS
PROVIDED AND WE'RE HOPING FOR
MORE SPECIFICALLY IN THAT AREA
AS WELL- WHEN IT COMES ARE
SPECIFICALLY TO THE CUTS ARE IN
THE NAY REVISION COMPARED TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE. I KNOW
THERE WILL BE MORE TO SAY ABOUT
HOW TO RESOLVE THOSE IN THE
NEXT COUPLE DAYS. OKAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR RENTAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AS I
BEGAN I WANT TO START WHERE-
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO-
WAS WHICH WAS THAT WE WERE NOT
PRESENT DURING THE LAST%
RECESSION. AND I THINK MANY OF
US HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND LOOK
TO OUR PREDECESSORS TO FIGURE
OUT IF THERE ARE SOME LESSONS
TO BE LEARNED. AND IF WE DON'T
STAND. AS WE'VE LEARNED FROM
HISTORY THOSE WHO DO NOT ARE
DOOMED TO REPEAT IT. AND I WANT
TO ASK YOU TWO QUESTIONS MR
THIS ONE EVEN IF I CAN'T. FIRST
CAN YOU HELP ME TO DEFINE WHAT
SUBSIDIARITY MEETINGS WHAT DOES
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CATEGORIZE IT AS- SO THAT WAS
THE TERM- THAT WAS USED OFTEN
BY GOVERNOR BROWN- SO I DON'T
WANT TO SPEAK FOR A GOVERNOR
BROWN- BUT MY RECOLLECTION IS
THAT. IT REFERS TO- GIVING
GREATER RESPONSIBILITY TO
JURISDICTIONS LOCALLY ON THE
GROUND. SO IF I CAN I. THINK
IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT
SUBSIDIARITY HAS NOT BEEN
PERFECT. AND I WOULD USE AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THE FACT THAT IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE AND IN
TWENTY ELEVEN WE'VE HAD TO DO
REALIGNMENT. AND SO I THANK MY
QUESTION FOR YOU MY FINAL
QUESTION AND I'M SORRY FOR
BEING SO POINTED. IS THAT GIVEN
THE FISCAL CONSTRAINTS THAT ARE
COUNTIES NOW FACE. IS THE
ADMINISTRATION CONSIDERING
DISCUSSIONS WITH COUNTIES ON
HOW BEST TO REALIGN PROGRAMS
AND FUNDING TO BETTER PROTECT
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
AND TO BETTER REFLECT OUR
CALIFORNIA VALLEY'S. ON THE
QUESTION I WILL SAY NUMBER ONE
IT JUST AS WITH THE LEGISLATURE
WERE IN TOUCH WITH COUNTIES AND
CITIES AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND ALL THESE ISSUES ESPECIALLY
NOW GIVEN THE STRESS THAT
THEY'RE UNDER AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT STRESS AND- WE KNOW IT'S
EASY TO LOOK AT OUR OWN YOU
KNOW FIFTY FOUR POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGETGAP BUT
WE UNDERSTAND THOSE. STRESSES
THAT THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
ARE FACING SECOND- SPECIFICALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO COUNTIES THE
NAY REVISION INCLUDED ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS OF THE
FEDERAL ALLOCATION TO HELP-
COUNTY- HEALTH AND SOCIAL
SERVICES AND SO WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT ALLOCATION IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO ALLEVIATE. ALL
THE STRESSES- THAT- THOSE
JURISDICTIONS ARE FACING- WE
ALSO KNOW FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SO
THIS ISSUE IS TOP OF MIND FOR
US JUST AS IT IS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE SO IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF WHERE THOSE RESOURCES
WILL COME FROM TO BE ABLE TO
DELIVER THE SUPPORT THAT'S
NEEDED. Q. AND- WITH THAT I
THINK THAT'S AN APPROPRIATE
TRANSITION IF I CAN TO THE LA
HOW AND SO. THE NEXT THREE
QUESTIONS I HAVE- WILL BE FOR
YOU MISTER PADDOCK. AND I THINK
WHERE- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JUST. STATED THAT THERE WILL BE
A SHORTFALL CURRENTLY EVEN WITH
THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL THERE'S A
BILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL WITHIN
THE COUNTIES. AND MY HOPE- WITH
THE LA- IS IF. YOU CAN HELP MY
OFFICE TO IDENTIFY WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE CURRENTLY MOST AT
RISK. DUE TO THE NINETEEN
NINETY ONE IN TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT. AND OUR CURRENT
FUNDING SHORTFALLS. YES DOCTOR
RAM YOU I THINK THAT- THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION WE HAVE- YEAH WE
DID NOTE THE CITY SIGNIFICANT
PRESSURE THAT COUNTIES WILL BE
UNDER FOR THE REALIGNMENT
PROGRAMS BUT- I'M GONNA IT- IT
PASS IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
CAROLINE CHU WHO HEIS. A
LITTLE CLOSER TO THE DETAILS ON
ON THOSE THAT PROGRAMS. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR NUMBERS CAROLINE
SURE OF LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WITH REGARD TO HELP
COUNTIES WILL RESPOND TO THE
DECLINE IN REVENUES IN
REALIGNMENT- WE'RE LIKELY TO
SEE A FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT
RESPONSES- IN TERMS OF EXACTLY
HOW THEY PRIORITIZE WHERE TO
MAKE- REDUCTIONS AND HOW TO
EXECUTE THOSE. SOMETHING I
WOULD NOTE THOUGH THAT WE MIGHT
ANTICIPATE IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
WOULD SEE IF THAT REALIGNMENT
HAS A MIXTURE OF ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS AND NON ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS. AND SO COUNTY IS
LIKELY WILL HAVE TO PRIORITIZE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE- STRICT
ENTITLEMENT REQUIREMENTS AND
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS OTHER
ONE ALL OVER THOSE THAT MIGHT
HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY IN THEM.
BUT NOW THAT SAID SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS OVER WHICH COUNTIES
HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY LIKE
PUBLIC HEALTH- THE COUNTIES
HAVE RECEIVED AND WILL CONTINUE
TO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDS BUT THAT COULD BE AN AREA
OF CONCERN FOR THE LEGISLATURE
WHERE ARE THE LEGISLATURE
WOULDN'T OTHERWISE ONE COUNTIES
TO REDUCE FUNDING. WE CERTAINLY
COULD HELP YOU ARE DOCTOR
ARAMBULA I'VE TRIED TO SURVEY
COUNTIES IN TERMS OF HOW THEY
MIGHT PLAN TO GO ABOUT DEALING
WITH THE REDUCTIONS IN REVENUE.
ABOUT LIKELY AS I MENTIONED
WE'LL SEE A REALLY A MIXTURE OF
RESPONSES- OVER THE NEXT YEAR
OR SO. AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK
YOU'VE HIT- RIGHT ON THE NAIL
IF I CAN- THE NON ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS THAT TO REALLY WOULD
BE MOST AT RISK WHETHER OR NOT
THAT POTENTIALLY CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES OR- ADULT PROTECTIVE
SERVICES I THINK WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND TO KNOW AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY- WHO WHAT.
THOSE POTENTIAL CUTS ARE ON THE
TABLE BY THE FIFTY DIFFERENT
COUNTIES. NOW IF I CAN SAY
DURING THE LAST RECESSION I
THOUGHT THERE REALLY WAS A
TRAGIC CHANGE. THAT WE MADE ONE
THAT I HOPE WE CAN IMPROVE UPON
NOW TO OUR CAL WORKS TIME
CLOCKS. AND IN MANY COUNTIES
INCLUDING- THE DISTRICT THAT I
REPRESENT. WHICH WERE SOME OF
THOSE WHICH WERE HARDEST HIT
AND STILL HAVE YET TO QUITE
RECOVER. MY FEAR IS THAT MANY
OF THE POLICIES THAT WE STILL
APPLY TODAY. ONLY WHITE AND THE
DISPARITIES THAT WE SEE WITHIN
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND SO MY NEXT
QUESTION FOR THE LA- IF I CAN
IS. CAN YOU HELP TO IDENTIFY
WHICH POLICIES ENACTED DURING
THIS LAST RECESSION SUCH AS THE
TIME CLOCKS AND WITHIN
REALIGNMENT. THAT COULD HELP US
TO CLOSE THOSE INEQUITIES
WITHIN CALIFORNIA. WE CERTAINLY
CAN WORK WITH YOUR STAFF TO
LOOK AT THE POLICY CHANGES AND
THERE'VE BEEN A NUMBER OF
STUDIES THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
COMMISSION OVER TIME TO LOOK AT
THAT AS WELL THAT WE COULD-
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ALL HAVE
ACCESS TO. AND JUST TO PIGGY
BACK ON TO THIS TIME CLOCK
ISSUE IT'S PARTICULARLY. TIMELY
NOW ONE SORRY FOR THAT POND BUT
I COULDN'T HELP MYSELF. BUT AS
WE GO THROUGH THIS RECESSION
THOSE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE
NEED THAT TIME NOW TO ACTUALLY
BE UTILIZING THOSE PROGRAMS
AND- HAVE A CONCERN THAT WE CAN
HELP TO RECTIFY THAT AND FIX
THAT FROM THE LAST RECESSION
AND IMPROVE UPON IT. MY FINAL
QUESTION IF I CAN IS. FIRST
WANTING TO ACTUALLY START BY
THANKING BOTH LEADERSHIP STAFF
AND ADVOCATES. FOR ALL THE HARD
WORK AND EFFORT THAT WE HAVE
DONE TO GET TO TODAY'S
PROPOSALS. AS MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS WE HAVE PROVIDED WILL
HELP US TO DIRECTLY ADDRESS
DISPARITIES. BUT MY FINAL
QUESTION FOR YOU LA- IS WHETHER
OR NOT YOU CAN HELP US TO
IDENTIFY. WHERE IF ANY. AS AN
EXAMPLE ALL PROVIDE THE-
GOVERNOR'S ANNOUNCED MEALS FOR
SENIORS PROGRAMS. THAT COUNTY
MATCHES ARE IN THIS BUDGET. AND
WHY I'M INTERESTED IS THAT IT'S
MY BELIEF THAT RICH COUNTIES
GET RICHER. AND THAT POOR
COUNTIES LIKE MINE ARE NOT ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS NOT A SINGLE COUNTY IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
PARTICIPATED IN THAT SENIOR
MEALS PROGRAMS AND WANTS US TO
BE AWARE OF WHICH PROGRAMS HAVE
COUNTY MATCHES SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE ARE RECEIVING
SERVICES. SO THAT WE DO NOT.
EXACERBATE DISPARITIES. CAN YOU
HELP US TO IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE
COUNTY MATCHES ARE IN THIS
CURRENT BUDGET. WE CERTAINLY
CAN'T AND TO CLARIFY DOCTOR IN
BILL YOU WANT TO LOOK AT NEW
PROGRAMS NOT EXISTING PROGRAMS
LIKE THOSE WITH AND REALIGNMENT
NOW I'M TALKING SPECIFICALLY
WITHIN THIS BUDGET HERE TODAY
AS I RECEIVED A PRINT OF IT A
FEW MINUTES BEFORE THE HEARING
IT'S- HARD FOR ME TO. PROCESS
FULLY EVERYTHING AND YET I'M
WANTING TO WORK WITH YOU AS THE
NONPARTISAN ARM OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH TO HELP US
TO FIGURE THAT OUT. BUT SURELY
I'M I WILL END WITH JUST SAYING
A SIMPLE REQUEST AND WE CAN
FOLLOW UP OFF LINE WITH THE LA
OUT- BUT THERE'S AN INTEREST
FROM BOTH MY OFFICE AND I HOPE
TO BRING IN- THE CHAIR OF OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE- SUBCOMMITTEE
AS WELL INTO A CONVERSATION
ABOUT FUNDING FOR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOUR
OFFICE AT LEAST WHILE I HAVE
pYOU ON THE LINE HERE TODAY TO
FOLLOW UP EITHER LATER TDAY OR
TOMORROW ON SOMETHING THAT I
THINK IS QUITE TIMELY AND
APPROPRIATE RIGHT NOW. SURELY
BEFORE I PASS IT BACK TO YOU
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO SAY
A BIG THANK YOU. TO EVERYONE
WHO IS HELPING US TO PROTECT
OUR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES WITH
THIS BUDGET. THE HELP WITHIN
HEALTH FOR ALL ELDERS AS WELL
AS THE CHILD TAX CREDIT WITH
AND CAL EITC WILL. GREATLY HELP
OR IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND I
JUST WANTED TO STAND UP THE
RESPECT THAT THàNH RIGHT THANK
EVERYONE WHO'S WORKING ON THIS
BUDGET. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU DON'T WORK. YES I
WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO WORKED
VERY HARD ON THIS BUDGET YOU
KNOW THAT WE FINALLY ARRIVED AT.
ROUGHLY A BETTER CONCLUSION
THAT WOULD START WITH THE FORD
SO IT MAKES IT A LITTLE BIT
BETTER A LITTLE BIT MORE
PALATABLE ARE STILL ASKING A
LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT WE NEED
TO ASK- JUST WANTED TO- IN
DELVING A LITTLE BIT INTO THE-
UNIVERSITY FUNDING AND- LOOKING
AT IT I'VE HAD PEOPLE
CONCERNED. THAT THE LAST TIME
AND I KIND OF LIVED THROUGH THE
LAST RECESSION AS A UNIVERSITY
PROFESSOR. WELL THE LAST TIME%
WHEN WE WERE ENGAGED IN
SOMETHING LIKE THIS- AS WE WERE
CUTTING- POSITIONS DOING FOR
LITTLE SWITCHING ARRANGEMENTS.
ARE INSTITUTIONS WERE SCHOOLING
WAY MONEY FOR OTHER THINGS AND
THEN WE FOUND OUT RECENTLY OF
COURSE THAT THEY HAD OVER
BILLION DOLLARS THAT THEY HAD
TO I HAD A TO STOCKPILE WATER
MEANT WHAT ARE OUR EMPLOYEES
WERE. BEING DENIED TO PAY
INCREASES EXPERIENCING
FURLOUGHS 10% CUTS IN THEIR
SALARIES SO FORTH AND SO ON.
ARE WE REQUIRING THAT FEES.
THESE FUNDS THAT HAD BEEN REYES
NOT NECESSARILY- IN THE BEST
WAY ARE WE REQUIRE THAT THEY
UTILIZE THOSE FUNDS AT THIS
TIME THE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T PUT ANY MORE DAMAGE. AND
HURT ON TO OUR EMPLOYEES AT THE
UNIVERSITY. WHAT ME TURN IT
OVER TO CHRIS FERGUSON HE'S ON
THE PHONE AND HE'LL BE ABLE TO
SPEAK IN DETAIL TO THE NATION.
YEAH CHRIS SERVICE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO OUR
PROPOSAL TO GO LOCAL FIRE THEM
TO A REQUIRED TO SEGMENT THAT
IT'S TO UTILIZE THEIR-
RESEARCH- FOR THE PURPOSES YOU
NOTED. HOWEVER UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. IT
IS ASSUMED THAT BOWL THE UC AND
SEE IF SHE WOULD NEED TO- USED
AS WELL OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WOULD NEED TO. TAP
INTO THEIR RESERVES TO. SUSTAIN
THEIR CORE OPERATIONS. BUT WHEN
REQUIRING WHICH MEANS THEY
COULD DO IT SOME OF THEM DID
AND THAT WAS TO INCREASE
STUDENT FEES- NOT ONLY WITH A
PARKING FEES BUT OTHER STUDENTS
SUPPOSEDLY ACADEMIC FEES.
AROUND THE SYSTEM AS A RESULT
WERE ABLE TO STOCKPILE THESE
RESOURCES- WHILE THEY WERE OF
SUPPOSEDLY CUTTING PROGRAMS AND
CUTTING SALARIES- I JUST THINK
THAT- IF WE IF WE'RE HONEST
ABOUT IT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAREFULLY WATCH THAT
THAT'S AN ONGOING CONCERN. WE
PASS LEGISLATION THAT THOUGH
SUPPOSEDLY DOES NOT ALLOW THEM
TO RAISE FEES WITHOUT STUDENT
INPUT AND MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
I GOT FROM SOMEONE THE OTHER
DAY IS OUR CAMPUSES ARE STILL
DOING IT DESPITE THE
LEGISLATION. AND SO WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
OVERSIGHT ON THAT WE KNOW THAT
TIMES ARE HARD BUT AT THE SAME
TIME IT'S ALSO HARD ON OUR
EMPLOYEES AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN THAT THAT HAPPENS IN A
DIFFERENT WAY. SO THAT THEY DO
DO THAT- I HOPE IT AS WE TALK
WHAT EDUCATIONAL FLEXIBILITY
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT- WE ARE IN
A DIFFERENT PLACE THE LAST TIME
WE DID- WHEN YOU HAD TO DO CUTS
OF WE HAD A LOT OF CHEMICAL OR
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE CATEGORY
BECAUSE NOT THAT MUCH NOW. BUT
I KNOW THERE'S A DESIRE FOR
FLEXIBILITY- AND WHILE I
GENERALLY SUPPORT FLEXIBILITY I
TRY NOT TO SUPPORT IT AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE POOREST KIDS IN
OUR DISTRICT. AND SO I THINK WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE'VE SEEN
THAT IN OUR- AUDIT REPORT THE
USE THE MISUSE OF DOLLARS THAT
SHOULD HAVE GONE TO POOR KIDS
WERE ROLLED OVER TO THE NEXT
YEAR WE HAVE LEGISLATION NOW.
TO PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING
BUT AS PEOPLE CLAMOR FOR
FLEXIBILITY WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE WE KNOW WHAT THEY WANT TO
BE FLEXIBLE ABOUT AN OFTENTIMES
AT LEAST IN OUR DISTRICTS OF.
THE POOREST FAMILIES THOUGH OF
COURSE CHILDREN OF THE LEAST
PERFORMING ONES BECAUSE IT
CLAMOR SOUL IS SO GREAT FROM
OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MORE
AFFLUENT THEY END UP ALL- NOT
HEARING THE VOICES OF THOSE WHO
ARE BEHIND. AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE KNOW THAT
FLEXIBILITY IS NOT INCLUDE USE
OF THE- SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS AND
WE'RE SATISFIED TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP THAT IS A NON.
NEGOTIABLE IN SHOULD BE IN THE
LINE TO GIVE THEM. A NEGOTIABLE.
US BECAUSE THAT JUST DAY TO DAY
HOLE. AND MAKES IT HARDER FOR
OUR KIDS AND OUR AND OUR- AND
OUR TO ECONOMY TO REBOUND. SO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IS CLEAR
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS GOOD ON THE
SURFACE THAT THE ONE
FLEXIBILITY- BUT WE KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED. WHEN THEY HAD ALL THE
FLEXIBILITY AND IN GOOD TIMES.
THEY DID NOT DID THEY USED
WELL. I KNOW IN MY COUNTY AND
IN ANOTHER. TWO DISTRICTS- OVER
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WERE.WERE ROLLED OVER TO BE
USED TO OF THE FOR PENSIONS AND
A HOST OF OTHER THINGS. SO WE
CAN'T AFFORD TO ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN FOR KIDS TO. UNDERSTAND
IS ABOUT SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS THAT DID NOT GET TO OUR
CHILDREN THAT SHOULD HAVE GOT
TO OUR KIDS AND IT FIVE YEAR
PERIOD. SO WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT
UP WHEN WE TALK FLEXIBILITY
IT'S NOT ABOUT FLEXIBILITY ON
THE BACK OF THE POOR. AND THOSE
WHO BEHIND SO ON MAKE SURE OF
THAT BECAUSE I THINK WE CAN. IT
SOUNDS GOOD ON THE SURFACE BUT
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT DOES
NOT- YOU KNOWS US CDC ARE HIS
IT HASN'T SUFFERED AS MANY CUTS
AS EVERYBODY ELSE IN AND
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT LITTLE.
GENERAL PUBLIC'S FEAR OF
OPENING THE GATES OF THE
PRISONS. IS PRETTY. SIGNIFICANT
AND AS A RESULT FOLKS ON TO
MAKE SURE. THE PRISON DOORS AT
THEIR- MY- MY CONCERN CONTINUES
TO REMAIN THAT THINGS ARE
HAPPENING DESPITE WHAT WE HAVE
SAID IN. COMMITTEE THAT WE WANT
TO SEE FIRST. YOU KNOW. THE
YEAH I STILL PLAN TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF. OF THE VALUE
WAITING AND ALL AND SHUTTING
DOWN PRISONS- AND MAYBE EVEN.
ONE IN THE COMING YEAR THAT
PEOPLE DON'T THE CALIFORNIA
SOMETHING PRISON I FORGET WHAT
IT IS IT'S A- PRIVATE PRISON.
BUT I'M LOOKING AT THAT AND WE
HAVE CONSISTENTLY SAID- TWO. OF
YOUR OPERATION AND OTHERS.
WHERE ARE THE STANDARDS BY
WHICH WE CLOSE PRISONS. AND
MEMBERS ARE CONCERNED BECAUSE
IT CAN BECOME VERY ARBITRARY.
AND WE SHOULD BE IN A POSITION
WHERE WE CAN SAY. OF THESE ARE
THE STANDARDS THESE ARE THE
EXPECTATIONS AND THIS IS WHAT
WE FOUND AND WHY WE CLOSE X.
PRISON VERSES Y. PRISON. THAT
IF WE CAN ARTICULATE THAT TO
THE PUBLIC THEY WILL BE MORE
THAN LIKELY WILLING TO ACCEPT
IT RATHER THAN THING IS SOME
KIND OF POLITICAL DECISION.
THAT WE MADE BASED ON WHO THE
MOST INFLUENTIAL MEMBER WAS IN
THE ROOM WITH THE TIME. AND SO
WE REALLY HAVE TO HAVE THAT
FIRST AND I GET FRUSTRATED WHEN
I SEE THAT IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
WHAT WE'VE DONE FIRST- WE'RE
WORKING ON IT I KEEP BEING TOLD
AND THERE'S SOME THINGS
FLOATING AROUND. BUT THEN I
HEAR ABOUT PEOPLE MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR CLOSE
CERTAIN PLACES AND I'M SAYING
BUT DID THEY MEET THE STANDARDS
THAT I HAVE THAT WE HAVE NOT
SEEN. AND WEARABLE STANDARDS
AND THAT AND THAT IS CRITICAL-
I'M NOT SURE WHERE WE PLAN TO
MAKE THOSE SAVINGS WITH S
GOING TO BE IN THIS BUDGET OR
THE NEXT BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
THIS. PROCESS FOR DOING AND
THAT'S A CONCERN. WANT TO MAKE
SURE SOMEONE MENTIONED THAT THE
MOVEMENT OF DJJ ONCE AGAIN
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT IS SO OVER
YEAR OLD- AND WHAT MOST OF US
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
IDENTIFY THE PROGRAMS IN
ADVANCE THAT WILL BE IN DJJ. SO
WE MAKE SURE THAT THE YOUNG
PEOPLE GETTING WHAT THEY
DESERVE. AS WELL AS- OUR ROLE
IN OVERSIGHT THAT WAS RAISED
BEFORE THAT WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT AS WE MOVE THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO THE VARIOUS COUNTIES
IN PROGRAMS. THAT THEY'RE NOT
WINNERS AND LOSERS YOU KNOW
THEY'RE NOT COUNTIES WHERE THEY
HAVE LOTS OF MONEY IN THE KIDS
ARE GETTING OUT. OF A CADILLAC
EDUCATION AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
OTHERS AND THEY'RE DRIVING TO A
BURNOUT PANTO SO WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE. THAT THERE IS
OVERSIGHT ON OUR PART AND I
HAVEN'T YET TO SEE WHAT WE'RE
SAYING THAT EVERY EVERY KID HAS
TO GET. OUR WHAT OUR OUTCOME
SHOULD BE AND IF WE MOVE IT TO
THE COUNTIES WHERE THE NOT THE
COUNTY SO PREPARE TO RECEIVE
THEM- SO- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DOING A LOT OF THINGS AND I AND
I'M CONCERNED THAT WE HAVEN'T
DONE THE PRELIMINARY WORK TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN. THAT THAT COULD
BE DONE SO. WHAT THANK YOU GUYS
FOR THE WORK YOU'VE DONE I'M
I'M GLAD THAT I JUSTICE FOLKS
TONIGHT IS GOING TO BE AS HURT
AS AS WE THOUGHT THEY WOULD BE.
IN A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT
APPEAR BUT- OF MY PERSPECTIVE
FROM A CDC ARE. THE BUT THE
PUBLIC SAFETY THAT WE MAKE A
LOT OF RECOMMENDATIONS. AND WE
DON'T DO A WHOLE LOT OF PLAN. I
THE REASON. IT WAS LIKE THEY'RE
EXPENDABLE PEOPLE BE. IF WE
FAIL THE PROCESS. OR WILL THEY
JUST WAS A BUNCH OF PRISONERS
ANYWAY- RATHER THAN THINKING
THAT THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT WE
HAVE EVEN A GREATER
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN THE CARE OF THE
STATE WITH THE REST OF THE
FOLKS AND NOT. AND WE OUGHT TO
BE MUCH MORE CONSCIOUS OF THE
HEALTH CARE- I'VE YET TO SEE A
REALLY GOOD PLAN. THE DEALS
WITH COVERT IN THE PRISONS-
THAT TELLS ME THAT- THAT. THAT
THEY'RE HANDLING IT
EFFECTIVELY. AND THAT WOULD
FLOW LIKE DON'T. THEY ARE. HAVE
BEEN TESTED IN QUARANTINE IN A
PUT BACK INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. WITH SOME SAFETY.
AND WE YOU KNOW. WE TILT I'M
TOLD EVERYBODY'S WORKING ON
THAT. IT WAS WILL MAKE IT
HAPPEN. BUT IF WHAT WE'RE
WORKING ON IT IT'S HAPPENING
ALL AT THE SAME TIME WHICH IS
REALLY KIND OF SCARY HOPE WE'LL
GET SOME. A LITTLE BIT MORE
STRUCTURE AND WHAT WE'RE DOING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS CARLY.
A GOOD MORNING THAT QUESTION
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
THERE BEEN ANY ANALYSIS OF
SAVINGS FROM REFORMING- POST
EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS SUCH AS-
HEALTH BENEFITS I'VE HEARD-
ESTIMATES THAT WE COULD SAVE
BILLIONS IF WE JUST HAD- THEM
STRUCTURED IN A WAY THAT WAS ON
PAR WITH SOME OF OUR FRIENDS IN
THE WESTERN STATES PACKED LIKE
COLORADO AND OREGON IS THAT
SOME OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
LOOKED AT. SO THOSE TYPES OF
CHANGES ARE NOT CONTEMPLATED IN
OUR MAY REVISION- THAT DATA IN
ADDED AT A GENERAL LEVEL IS
AVAILABLE YOU KNOW BOTH. IN
SOME OF OUR DOCUMENTS AS WELL
AS IN CALIFORNIA IS A
COMPREHENSIVE ANNUAL FINANCIAL
REPORT- BUT IN TERMS OF THE
SPECIFICS- I'D HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON MORE DETAILS WHAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE. I IS IF THE LA-
STILL HERE IS THIS I MEAN THAT
YOU'VE LOOKED AT. HELLO YES- WE
HAVE WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT
THAT QUESTION OVER TIME AND- IT
IS VERY COMPLICATED I THINK
THAT IN GENERAL THE- BENEFITS
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVIDED. OVER
TIME- YOU KNOW YOU- TYPICALLY-
CHANGES TO THE BENEFIT PACKAGE
WOULD. FROM A LEGAL STANDPOINT
THE SAFEST WAY TO APPROACH IT
WOULD BE TO MAKE CHANGES TO
FUTURE EMPLOYEES RATHER THAN
EXISTING BENEFITS. BUT THERE IS
SOME LEGAL QUESTION ABOUT HOW
MUCH. THE WAY THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD HAVE TO REDUCE BENEFITS
PARTICULARLY FOR- EXISTING
RETIREES SO- YOU KNOW IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE COULD WE
COULD WORK WITH YOU YOU AND
YOUR STAFF TO PROVIDE A MORE
DETAILED RESPONSE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE BUT- YOU KNOW. IT EIGHT.
SORRY I HAD. NICE GOING TO SAY
I MEAN IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A
FAIRLY COMPLICATED ISSUE THAT
HAS SOME- QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF CHANGING
BENEFIT LEVELS AND PARTICULARLY
WITH REGARD TO HOW THE STATE
HAS APPROACH TO FINDING THE
BENEFIT IN RECENT YEARS- ASKING
EMPLOYEES TO MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE BENEFIT US YOU KNOW
COULD COULD SET UP A AN
ARGUMENT THAT THE- BENEFIT IS
MORE DIFFICULT TO CHANGE-
RETROACTIVELY SO- IS FAIRLY.
COMPLEX I THINK TO PUT IT
BLUNTLY. SURE WELL I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT- IF NOT PART OF THIS
BUDGET I MEAN I EVEN IF IT'S
JUST FOR ON A FORWARD GOING
BASIS THERE ARE SUCH A STANCE
ALL SAVINGS HERE AND I YOU KNOW
THE LEVEL OF THAT WERE
SUBSIDIZING RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT
EVEN CLEAR HOW MUCH OF VALUE IT
PROVIDES TO THE RETIREES IN
TERMS OF THEI HEALTH AND WELL
BEING AND FINANCIAL SECURITY-
DOES MAKE ONE COMMENT ON THE
ISSUE OF EDUCATION FLEXIBILITY
AYE AYE AT THAT SPENDING
FLEXIBILITY AYE. I AGREE
ACTUALLY WITH DOCTOR WEBER AND-
MISTER MCCARTY- IT IN AS MUCH
AS THERE IS A DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THE CONCENTRATION
FUNDING FOR LCF OUT FOR WE HAVE
PROVIDED A DISPROPORTIONATE
SHARE OF STATE EDUCATION
DOLLARS TO DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS AND IT'S-
WE'VE SEEN THAT THAT FUNDING
HAS NOT ALWAYS BEEN TARGETED AT
THE STUDENTS IT'S MEANT FOR- IT
IN THE WAY THAT WILL ACTUALLY
LEAD TO A CLOSING EDUCATIONAL
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND THAT'S WHY
I'VE SUPPORTED DR WEBER'S
EFFORTS. TO TRY TO BRING-
GREATER OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT PROCESS
THAT ON THE OTHER HAND THERE
ARE SOME RESTRICTIONS OF
GENERAL FLEXIBILITY THAT TO ME
DON'T SEEM PARTICULARLY WELL
GROUNDED WHICH I YOU KNOW
MISTER MCCARTY ALLUDED TO A
COUPLE OF THEM I'VE HEARD
ABOUT- THE FUN DEALING WITH
THAT IS BOTH SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS I AND STUDENTS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WHERE
THERE ARE RESTRICTIONS- OR EVEN
POTENTIALLY DEVELOPMENT FEES-
AND THAT SORT OF THING SO IF
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT THIS.
THROUGH NOT JUST THE LANDS OF-
YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT'S BEING PROVIDED BUT ALSO-
THE VALUE THAT FUNDING
PROVIDES- YOU KNOW LIFTING
RESTRICTIONS WHERE THEY DON'T
NEED TO EXIST- IS ONE WAY THAT
YOU CAN ADD VALUE I WITHOUT
HAVING TO HAVE EXTRA DOLLARS
AND FRANKLY I WOULD EXTEND TO
THAT POINT TO A MUCH BROADER
SWATH OF EDUCATION POLICY AND
WE HAVE A VERY THICK EDUCATION
CODE. THAT HAS A LOT OF.
MANDATES ARE NOT NECESSARILY AT
THAT ARE DONE ARE REALLY
NECESSARY FOR DISTRICTS AND THE
REASON WE KNOW THAT IS BECAUSE
THERE'S A PARTICULAR. A SUBSET
OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM
THAT ISN'T SUBJECT TO A LOT OF
THOSE MANDATES THE CHARTER
SECTOR. SO IF WE COULD THINK
ABOUT WAYS TO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY IN THAT SENSE WHERE
WE'RE NOT. HAVING SO MANY
MANDATES IMPOSED ON DISTRICTS
THEN THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER WAY
THAT I THINK WE CAN ALLOW THEM
TO DO THEIR JOB OF. OF
PROMOTING STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
BETTER- I HAD A TIME WHEN WE
DON'T HAVE AS MUCH FUNDING TO
BRING TO THE TABLE. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY THEN I'M GONNA
GET TO MY QUESTIONS I JUST
GOING TO GO ON CAN YOU DESCRIBE
THE DIFFERENCES IN STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSAL AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL- AS A- AND
ALSO WHEN WE GET THE FOURTEEN
BILLION. AND WHEN WE DON'T GET
THE FOURTEEN DAY. ONCE YOU. YES
MISTER KING I KNOW I KNOW THAT-
UNDER THE MAY REVISION AS WE
FIRST LOOKED AT IT THERE WERE-
STRUCTURAL DEFICITS IN THE
SEVERAL BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
RANGE. AND THEN THERE IS
ACTUALLY SOME INCREASE IN THE
FINAL YEAR OF THE MULTIPLE YOUR
OUTLOOK IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AT THAT POINT IT
WOULD INCREASE TO- AROUND
SIXTEEN BILLION PARTLY BECAUSE
SOME OF THE REVENUE PROVISION
ANDS. WOULD HAVE DROPPED OFF BY
THEN AND SOME OTHER CHANGES
THAT WERE OR WERE PROPOSED IN
THE MAY REVISION. I MUST SAY I
DON'T KNOW THAT I HAVE SEEN A
MULTIPLE YEAR- I HAVE NOT SEEN
A MULTIPLE YEAR OUTLOOK FOR-
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE AT THIS
TIME SO I THINK THAT'S A
DISCUSSION THAT YOU KNOW WE
COULD CONTINUE TO HAVE WITH
THAT WITH THE DATA YOU KNOW
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. GREAT AND THEN
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL DO YOU ALSO FACTOR IN
ALL THE SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
LAYOFFS WOULD HAVE TO DO
BECAUSE OF ALL THE BUDGET CUTS
IN TERMS OF TEACHERS. ON IN
HEALTH POOR SERVICE CARE GIVERS
PEOPLE WHO STAFF THESE ADULT
DAY HEALTH CENTERS- ALL ALL THE
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO- WORK THE-
DDS CENTERS WHAT WAS THAT A
FACTOR IN YOUR IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS THAT IS A- VERY. GOOD
QUESTION AND IT REASONABLE
CONCERN BUT THAT'S AND THAT IS-
KIND OF A- AN EFFECTIVE THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE DID NOT TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT IN OUR INITIAL
ANALYSIS OF THE OF THE PACKAGE.
WHAT WOULD BE A FAIR ASSUMPTION
THAT TERM. YOU KNOW YOU KNOW
UNEMPLOYMENT CASELOAD AS WELL
AS ALL THE DIFFERENT TIME ONE
CASELOAD PROGRAMS WOULD. GO UP
BECAUSE OF THOSE MAILS. FOR THE
PEOPLE AFFECTED BY BY THAT-
YEAH I THINK IT'S REASONABLE TO
THINK THAT THEY MAY IN SOME
CASES YES BE BE- NEEDING TO
UTILIZE THOSE KIND OF SERVICES
YES. GREAT THANK YOU TO JUST GO
BACK TO OUR DEPARTMENT FINANCE-
LOOKING AT THE FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
MEDI CAL. CAL WORKS- CASELOAD
ASSUMPTIONS. BECAUSE OF THAT-
BECAUSE OF THE HUGE INCREASING
CASELOADS IN YOUR PROPOSAL THAT
DROVE MANY OF THE BUDGET CUTS
AND HUMAN SERVICES AND THE-
PUBLIC HEALTH AREA SO IF THE
ASSUMPTION WAS INCORRECT AND
YOU DIDN'T HAVE THE- CASE LOAD.
THE U. IT ANTICIPATED WHAT
WOULD BE DONE WITH THE MONEY
THE SAFETY. SO IF IT TURNS OUT
THAT EXPENSES ARE LOWER THAN WE
ARE PROJECTING THEN THAT MONEY
IT CERTAINLY WOULDN'T GO AWAY
IT WOULD SIMPLY- ROLLING TO THE
NEXT YEAR FOR APPROPRIATION BY
THE LEGISLATURE. SUSAN RESERVE.
YEAH IT WOULD BE- THE- AND
ASSUMING EVERYTHING ELSE WAS
EXACTLY HOW WE PROJECTED IT-
THE AND YOUR BALANCE- SO THE
KERRY AND SURPLUS- WOULD BE
THAT MUCH HIGHER BY HOWEVER
MANY BILLION DOLLARS- THEN WE
ARE PROJECTING. I SHOULD NOTE
THOUGH AS WE ALL KNOW THAT. FOR
THE YEAR AFTER THIS YEAR- WE
ARE CURRENTLY PROJECTING A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT OF SEVERAL
BILLION DOLLARS SO IT WOULD
MORE ABOUT THE FACT IF
EVERYTHING WERE TO GO WAS WE'RE
PROJECTING. OF REDUCING THE
SIZE OF THAT STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
RATHER THAN CREATING A SURPLUS.
GAGAN BUT THE SAME TIME. THE
ONE THE ONE IMPACT WE WOULD
HAVE THIS. MANY OF THE SERVICES
THAT WERE PROPOSED CUTS WOULD
BE CUT SEE YOU WOULD HAVE
SENIORS WHO WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
GET MEALS YOU HAVE SENIORS
COULDN'T GET. HELP AT HOME YOU
HAVE- PEOPLE WHO WORKED RELY ON
MEDI CAL COULDN'T ACCESS MANY
OF THESE ADDITIONAL SERVICES
LIKE DENTAL CARE A DIFFERENT
OPTIONAL BENEFITS- PICNIC THEY
COULDN'T GET THOSE SO THAT THE
PART WE WOULD KNOW FOR CERTAIN.
THAT'S CORRECT SO ON. ONE ONE
THING AS WE AS WE TALKED ABOUT
AND I THINK MISS MCCARTY FRIEND
A VERY WELL. IS WE- NONE OF US
KNOW WHERE THE ECONOMY'S GOING
I THINK I THINK THE ONLY THING
WE KNOW FOR. EVERY BUDGET THAT
WE PUT TOGETHER IS WHATEVER WE
WHATEVER BUDGET WE PUT TOGETHER
IS GOING TO BE WRONG. IT'S AN
IT'S NEVEREXACTLY AS WE
PROTECT WE OBVIOUSLY WANT TO
INSURE. THAT WE ARE BEING-
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE. BUT I
THINK THE QUESTION ISIN ORDER
TO PROTECT OUR BOND RATING WE
HAVE SNOW INTO CALIFORNIANS
WHO. CAN'T GET ACCESS TO FOOD
CAN'T GET ACCESS TO HOUSING-
HAVE- CHALLENGES GETTING HEALTH
CARE ACCESS IN I THINK WE ARE
TRYING TO- TO SOME EXTENT.
BROUGH SAY IT'S OKAY THAT IF.
WE HAVE A LOWER BOND RATING IN
ORDER TO PROTECT. THOSE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS I
THINK THAT'S WHERE I WOULD SAY
IS- ONE OF THE PRIMARY
DIFFERENCES IN IN OUR BUDGET
THAT WE ARE. ASSUMING GREATER-
FINANCIAL RISK. FOR THE MILLING
TO CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ABLE TO
SAY FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS CAN'T
GET ACCESS TO CREDIT CAN BORROW
ANY MONEY CAN'T ASSUME. ANY OF
THAT- ANY OF THE FINANCIAL RISK.
I THINK GOING BACK TO THE-
SISTER BUT DOCTOR WEBER SAID
ABOUT THE STATE PRISON CLOSURE-
WE DID IT- PUT FORWARD- TRAILER
BILL- WE REALLY HOPE THAT- THAT
WE CAN FIND A FIND A PATH TO
AGREEMENT ON THAT TRAILER BILL.
I KNOW THAT ONE OF OUR- ONE OF
ONE OF THE POINTS OF FOCUS WE
HAD IN THAT TRAILER BILL. WAS
TO ENSURE THAT THEIR WORK COST
SAVINGS THAT IF WE WERE GOING
TO DO THE TO PRISON CLOSURES.
THAT WE WERE ALSO GONNA HAVE
COST SAVINGS BUT ALSO HAVE
MINIMUM IMPACT TO BOTH THE
WORKERS BUT ALSO TO THE
FAMILIES OF THE INMATES AS
WELL. AND WE REALLY HOPE THAT-
THAT WE CAN FIND AN AGREEMENT
NO THE ADMINISTRATION SHARES
SHARES IS EXACT SAME GOALS. AS
THE- THE WAY THE TRAILER BILL
PUTS WRITTEN BUT WE HOPE THAT
WE CAN. HAVE A CONVERSATION OF
THAT. BUT I THINK. OVER ALL.
WHERE AS AS WE PUT TOGETHER THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THIS BUDGET-
YOU KNOW IT'S HARD TO KIND OF
IMAGINE THE WORLD BEFORE. MOVE
IT BUT IF WE THINK ABOUT WHERE
WE WERE IN FEBRUARY. I THINK
IT'S A GOOD REMINDER WE WERE AT
FULL UNEMPLOYMENT. BUT YET WE
HAD MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO. NEVER HOW. FULL EMPLOYMENT
FOR DOES A UNEMPLOYMENT I'M
SORRY EXCUSE OKAY THANK YOU FOR
THAT CORRECTION- WE HAVE WE
HAVE FULL WE HAVE FULL
EMPLOYMENT- BE AT THE SAME TIME
WE HAD MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WHO NEVER- REALLY RECOVERED
FROM THE LAST RECESSION AND I
THINK. THAT IS- MAINLY DUE TO
MANY THE DEVASTATING CUTS TO
OUR SOCIAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
THAT- MANY MANY FAMILIES RELY
ON A AND BECAUSE OF THAT-
BECAUSE OF THOSE CUTS WE HAD
SOME OF THE LARGEST INCOME
INEQUALITY AT THE WE'VE EVER
SEEN IN THE STATE'S HISTORY.
THIS STATE HAS TRADITIONALLY
ALWAYS BEEN A STATE WHERE WE'VE
HAD VERY A VERY STRONG MIDDLE
CLASS WE'VE HAD PROSPERITY FOR
PEOPLE WHO'VE COME FROM OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY OR THE
PARTS OF THE WORLD TO REALLY
COME HERE WITH A NOT A WHOLE
LOT TO BE ABLE TO FINANCIALLY
SUCCEED. IT IS HARDER EVERY DAY
FOR PEOPLE WHO COME HERE BUT
ALSO FOR THE PEOPLE WHO GREW UP
HERE TECHNICALLY TO CD AND I
THINK PART OF THAT IS THE
SOCIAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT ARE-
BUDGET PUTS TOGETHER WAS REALLY
HAMPERED IN THE LAST RECESSION.
SO I THINK WHAT WE WANTED TO DO
WAS BEFORE. WE ARE MAKE THESE
DEVASTATING CUTS. THAT ARE
BASED ON FISCAL ASSUMPTIONS
THAT AGAIN NONE OF US KNOW HOW
ACCURATE. THEY WILL BE A IS TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
DO THOSE CUTS UNTIL WE
ABSOLUTELY. HAVE TO DO THEM.
WE'RE AT A POINT WHERE THE
ECONOMY IS STARTING TO RE OPEN.
WE HOPE IT WILL RE OPEN-
WITHOUT ANOTHER SPIKE IN COVERT
CASES- BUT WE DON'T KOW- AND
IF NOT- WITHOUT A CURSE THE
HOPE IS THAT PERHAPS- WE'RE
GOING TO BE IN A BETTER
ECONOMIC SITUATION. THEN I WILL
HAVE PROJECTED DEPARTMENT
FINEST PROJECT I KNOW THAT'S
WHAT WE ALL HOPE FOR WE'RE NOT
HOPING FOR A DIRE PREDICTION.
SO AND GET ON HOPES OF THAT I
THINK IT MAKES SENSE IN JUNE.
TWO NOT PULL THE BUTTON BECAUSE
ONCE YOU CUT THESE PROGRAMS.
THE VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO
BRING BACK- WE CAN IF THE
ECONOMY CONTINUES TO GO BAD WE
OBVIOUSLY CAN REVISIT THESE
DISCUSSIONS IN AUGUST. I
MEASURE WILL BE REVISITING
ISSUE THESE ISSUES IN JANUARY
WHEN WE COME BACK TO SESSION. I
THINK THERE'S PLENTY OF TIME TO
REACT TO THE SITUATION TO. DO
WHAT WE THINK IS BEST AT THE
TIME THAT WE DO THEM. SO I
REALLY WOULD JUST URGE. THE AS
WE GO IN THIS DISCUSSION. TO
JUST THINK VERY CAREFULLY
ABOUT- THESE CUTS BEFORE YOU DO
THAT BECAUSE ONCE YOU DO THEM
AGAIN. EVEN IF THE PROJECTIONS-
COME IN MUCH MORE OPTIMISTIC
THAN WE HAD PREVIOUSLY HOPED-
YOU CAN'T JUST BRING BACK
TEACHERS TO BEEN LAID OFF
BECAUSE THEY'RE GONE. YOU CAN'T
JUST BRING BACK THESE PROGRAMS
TO START AT THE TAKES A YEARS
OFTENTIMES TO START UP THESE
PROGRAMS AGAIN. SO AGAIN- I
THINK IT IS IT IS IMPORTANT I
THINK WE HAVE PUT TOGETHER. A
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE BUDGET--BECAUSE WE'VE WAITED THE COST
OF NOT HELPING THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO WOULD GO WOULD
GO HUNGRY WOULD GO ON SHELTER-
WOULD REALLY BE IN DIRE NEED
WITHOUT THE ASSISTANCE THAT WE
COULD. PROVIDE THE SO WITH THAT
I SEE A DARK MIST MISTER BLOOM
HAS SOME THANKS IF I COULD JUST
ASK A QUICK QUESTION WHICH I
HOPE WILL BE INFORMATIVE- HOW
ARE ACTUAL REVENUES DOING
COMPARED TO THOSE. PROJECTED IN
THE MAY REFLECTS. SO I HAVE- J.
CHAMBERLAIN ON THE LINE WHO
COULD SPEAK TO IN TERMS OF JUST
THE LAST COUPLE MONTHS I SHOULD
CLARIFY THAT THE REAL- WE'LL
GET A BETTER SENSE ON JULY
FIFTEENTH BECAUSE THAT'S THE
APRIL FIFTEENTH- PUSH THREE
MONTHS FORWARD- BUT J. CHAMBER
ONE CAN SPEAK TO THAT EVERY
MONTH WE MOVE FORWARD IT.
BECOMES MORE ACCURATE. HI MA'AM
THIS IS KATE CHAMBERLAIN OUT
ARMED FINANCE. SO NAY REVENUES
CAME AND- HIGHER AND I DON'T
HAVE THE EXACT NUMBERS YOU WANT
ME TO HIM AND HIGHER THAN THEM
WITH PROJECTED ARE STILL DOWN A
VERY SIGNIFICANTLY FROM THE
PRIOR YEAR- BUT THROUGHOUT
NINETEEN. BUT OKAY BUT THE TO
ME TO MAKE THE PAYMENT STRONGER
THAN WE PROJECTED. THAT'S
RATHER VAGUE CAN YOU A CARE OF
US LIKE AN ORDER OF MAGNITUDE I
HAD AND I CAN FALL. I OF
ROUGHLY IT'S ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OVER OUR-
PROJECTION I THINK IT WAS IT
WAS PRIMARILY WITHHOLDING CAME
IN STRONGER THEN WE HAD
pDECIMATED. THANK I WON'T HOLD
YOU TO THE PRECISE. A NUMBER
BUT I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
JUST TO FOLLOW UP THAT SIR YOU
DO THESE ARE JUST THE CAR FRONT
THAT'S INCOME TAX WITHHOLDINGS.
THAT'S CORRECT DO BILL. WITH
ALL. THANK YOU I THINK MISTER
BLOOM HAS TO QUESTION I WAS
THINKING ABOUT SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THE QUESTION IN AGAIN I
THINK IT DEMONSTRATES- THE
POINT TO INSURE THAT WE HAVE
TO- MAKE SURE WERE ONLY CUTTING
THINGS WHEN WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE
TO CUT THESE PROGRAMS I WANT A
SITUATION WHERE THESE FAMILIES
ARE IN DIRE NEED. AT A TIME
WHEN PEOPLE NEED GOVERNMENT THE
MOST OUR RESOURCESARE
SHRINKING BUT IT YOU KNOW IT
MAKES SENSE THAT WE NOT CUT
THESE PROGRAMS AND TO WE
ABSOLUTELY ARE CERTAIN THAT WE
HAVE TO SET. UP WITH THAT
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS I WAS GOING TO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE. PLEASE COME TO THE
PLEASE COME TO THE MICROPHONE-
YEAH PLEASE COME ONE AT A TIME
THERE'S NO NEED TO LINE UP. IS
IT IS IT ON GO AHEAD IT IS ON
OKAY- MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF
THE COMPUTING TECHNOLOGY
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION- IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO THE
REVENUE GENERATING PROPOSALS.
THAT IS THE NET OPERATING LOSS
DEDUCTION SUSPENSION AS WELL AS
A LIMITATION ON TAX CREDIT
USAGE. I WANT TO RAISE A COUPLE
OF ISSUES FIRST AND FOREMOST.
WHETHER YOU IN ACTED ON THE
FIFTEENTH OR AT SOME OTHER
POINT IT IS RETROACTIVE TO
JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR. SO
MANY COMPANIES WHO WERE
ANTICIPATING USAGE OF THOSE
CREDITS HER AND A WELL
DEDUCTIONS WILL BE ADVERSELY
IMPACTED. SECOND IN ORDER TO
PAY THE FOUR PLUS BILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S ESTIMATED TO BE
GENERATED BY THESE TWO
PROVISIONS. IT REQUIRES
BUSINESSES TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CASH FLOW BECAUSE INSTEAD OF. A
REDUCED TAX BILL FROM THAT AND
A WELL DEDUCTION INDOOR TAX
CREDIT USAGE THEY'LL NEED THE
CASH TO PAY THAT HIGHER BILL.
THIRD THESE ARE UNPRECEDENTED
THERE THREE YEARS OF SUSPENSION
WHICH WE THINK IS ON WARRANTED
AT THIS STAGE. AND LASTLY ON
THE CREDIT USAGE THE BIGGEST
IMPACT IS ON RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT AS MISTER COOPER-
NOTICED EARLIER TODAY. AND I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT IN ORDER
TO GENERATE THAT CREDIT. YOU
HAVE TO DO VERY SPECIALIZED
RESEARCH PURSUANT TO FEDERAL
LAW IT HAS TO OCCUR WITHIN THE
CONFINES OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND MOST OF THE
CREDIT IS GENERATED BY WAGES
PAID TO THOSE WORKERS INVOLVED
IN THAT RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT FOR THOSE REASONS
WE URGE YOU TO REJECT THOSE
PROPOSALS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK.
CHECKING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- JET HAMPTON WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS REPRESENTING FORTY
SIX HEALTH PLANS PROVIDING
COVERAGE TO TWENTY SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN MILLION
BENEFICIARIES IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME HERE TODAY-
WE ARE DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THAT
THE BUDGET AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE HOUSES DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
SENATE INITIAL REJECTION OF THE
MANAGED CARE RATE CUTS. WE DO
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT
THESE CUTS AND THEIR IMPACT ON
THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM A
SPECIFICALLY THE MANAGED CARE
PLAN CUTS IF ENACTED SHOULD NOT
BE RETROACTIVE THE
RETROACTIVITY- TO JULY TWENTY
NINETEEN IS PARTICULARLY
BURDENSOME AS THE PANDEMIC AND
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN BEGAN IN
MARCH OF THIS YEAR WE BELIEVE
THAT ANY CUT IF ENACTED. WE
PERSPECTIVE ONLY TO ALLOW
PLANTS TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO
PROTECT TO PROTECT THE PROVIDER
NETWORKS AND INSURE MEMBER
ACCESS. I WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE- TO HOLD OFF ON
SCORING OPEN ENDED CONCEPTS
LIKE THE EFFICIENCY FACTORS AND
OTHER RATE CHANGES. UNTIL THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE ECONOMIC
IN CASE OF IMPACTS OF THE
NINETEEN. I WOULD ALSO
REQUESTED A GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS MATERIALIZE WORK THE
STATE IS GRANTED ANY ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT THOSE
RESOURCES SHOULD BE USED TO
OFFSET OR ELIMINATE. CLOSED AND
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE- RATE
CUTS THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WAS ONE LET YOU KNOW THAT
WE DO UNDERSTAND THE PRESSURES
STATE IS UNDER- AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO BE AT THE
TABLE TO DISCUSS THAT THANK YOU
HAVING TROUBLING WHICH THANK
YOU. HELLO JENNIFER BESTER FOR
EDUCATE OUR STATE- I'M HERE TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
PAY ATTENTION TO DELAYING
EASTON'S. SUBMITTED PUBLIC
COMMENT DILLON WAS THE FORMER
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS. IT REGARDED THE
PENALTIES FOR COUNTIES WHO
MISCALCULATE THE EDUCATIONAL
REVENUE AUGMENTATION FUN. ARE I
THINK YOU KNOW THAT THE LA-
WONDERFULLY DISCOVERED THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. OF MISS ALLOCATED.
PROPERTY TAX THAT PROPERTY TAX
ACTUALLY ROB THE POOREST.
SCHOOLS IN OUR STATE. ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. I'M I THINK
WE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE
ADMINISTRATION TAKING THE STEP
OF PUTTING IN LANGUAGE THAT
CREATES PENALTIES FOR DOING
THIS AGAIN. PROPERTY TAX IS YOU
ALL KNOW THE MOST STABLE. AND
RELIABLE OF SOURCES YOU ALL
KNOW THAT COUNTIES HAVE
INCENTIVE TO MISCALCULATED THEY
CANNOT BE ALLOWED TO SELL FEEL
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU MAINTAIN THIS IN YOUR
LANGUAGE THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT PRESENT IN. THE ROOM.
GREAT DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT DOWNSTAIRS SORTS ONLY
ON THE PHONE OKAY SO WE'RE
GONNA GO TO THE PHONE LINE.
OPERATOR ARE YOU THERE. AND I'M
WONDERFUL HAVE WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL LIKE YOU ALREADY IF
YOU'VE ALREADY CUED UP PLEASE
DO NOT YOU UP AGAIN FOR THOSE
THAT HAVE NOT CUED UP YOU CAN
PROCESS ONE ZERO WE'RE GONNA
START WITH THE LINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO THANK YOU. I IN
MATH. NINE THIRTY EIGHT. ONE
MOMENT. YOU HAVE A THOUGHT MUTE.
ONE MOMENT. A LINE FORTY FIVE.
IF YOU'RE TAKING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING US TO
SUBMIT PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
PHONE YOUR BILL THOMAS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER I WANT TO START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING HOW DIFFICULT THE
BUDGET CYCLE HAS BEEN GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY AROUND THE GLOBE IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HE ARGUED THE
WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY FOR
NEGOTIATING A BUDGET AGREEMENT
WITH THE SENATE THAT FOCUSES ON
PROVIDING HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
SAFETY NET PROGRAMS
CALIFORNIANS. REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THE MEDI
CAL ACCESS. TO ARE UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS AND PROVIDING THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT TO
THOSE WORKERS THAT FILE WITH
THE NIGHT IN. AND HAVE A CHILD
AGE SIX AND UNDER WILL ALLOW
FOR CALIFORNIANS TO RECOVER
FROM THIS PANDEMIC. IN A MORE
EQUITABLE WAY AND WHY WE WILL
PUSH FOR EARLIER IMPLEMENTATION
ON HEALTH FOR ALL SENIORS. AND
ALLOWING ALL I CAN WORKERS THAT
QUALIFIED TO RECEIVE THE EITC.
THIS BUDGET AGREEMENT-
CONTINUES TO BUILD A FOUNDATION
OF HEALTH ACCESS TO AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE. AND FINALLY I
WANT TO THANK OUR LEGISLATIVE
CHAMPIONS IN THE ASSEMBLY DR
ARAMBULA FAMILY MEMBER CHIU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSONASSEMBLY
WOMAN REYES. FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT THEY PUT FORWARD THIS YEAR
CONTINUOUS SIGN A LINE ON IT
LOW LIGHT ON IN EQUITY AND
ACCESS TO BASIC NEEDS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE NEXT
DEADLINE FORTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS BARBARA
GLAZER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION ALTHOUGH
THE BUDGET AGREEMENT EXCLUDES
CRITICAL FUNDING THAT HOSPITALS
HAVE BEEN SEEKING WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT IT DOES
REJECTING MANAGED CARE
EFFICIENCY PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED
PAYMENTS TO HOSPITALS IN MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE THAT WOULD BE
DEVASTATING TO A HOSPITAL AND I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE FOR
REJECTING IT. YESTERDAY THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION RELEASED A REPORT
THE FINANCIAL IMPACT OF KOBE
NINETEEN ON CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
THE AUTHORS OF THIS REPORT
ESTIMATE THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL NET REVENUE WILL HAVE
FALLEN BY AN AVERAGE THREE
POINT TWO BILLION PER MONTH IN
EACH OF THE FIRST FOUR MONTHS
OF THE PANDEMIC MARCH THROUGH
JUNE AMOUNTING TO LOSSES OF
NEARLY THIRTEEN BILLION. AGAIN
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
REJECTING THE MANAGED CARE CUT
TO HOSPITAL IN RECOGNIZING THAT
THIS IS NOT THE TIME TO BE
CUTTING HOSPITALS THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE FORTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU CHAIR
KING AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JULIE MCCORMICK I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE CHILDREN
BLOCK BANNER CALIFORNIA WE
PROVIDE DIRECT LEGAL
REPRESENTATION TO THE THIRTY
THREE THOUSAND CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE IN LOS
ANGELES SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER
COUNTY. ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT
WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR DEEP
GRATITUDE TO BE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY THE WORK
DONE BY SUBCOMMITTEE ONE IN
FIVE THE PUTTING FORTH A BUDGET
THAT PROTECTS CRITICAL CHILD
WELFARE PROGRAMS AND
DEVASTATING CUTS ENTERTAINING
THE CURRENT LEVEL OF FUNDING
FOR DEPENDENCY COUNCIL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. LIMITED
ACCESS TO THE COURT A GROWING
BACKLOG OF CASES IN AN INFECTED
INCREASE THE FOSTER CARE
POPULATION THE ADVOCATE THE
NEEDS OF OUR YOUNG CLIENTS OR
MORE CRITICAL NOW THAN EVER
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF
THE SIXTY THOUSAND CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
AND FOR ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
A MEANINGFUL VOICE. NEXT
DEADLINE FIFTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE
MODERATOR AND I THINK HE CANNOT
GOING TO HELP ON BEHALF OF TO
CLIENTS- PRIMARILY WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
APPROACHED THE BUDGET AND THE
ADMONITION THAT WE MUST LOOK
OUT THE MOST VULNERABLE DURING
THESE TIMES AND NOT CUT UNTIL
IT IS ABSOLUTELY POSITIVELY
CERTAIN THAT YOU NEED TO DO SO.
ON THE HAVE BEEN A FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP AS STATEWIDE
EVIDENCE BASED HOME VISITING
PROGRAM WE ARE JUST GOING TO BE
A ONE TIME THIRTY MILLION
DOLLAR REDUCTION PLAN ON
VISITING SERVICE IS AND WILL BE
WORKING WITH STAFF AND
APARTMENT ON THAT SHOULD THAT
YOU REALIZED MATT MANNER TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT MANY FAMILY
CONTINUE TO BE SERVICE
POSSIBLE. HOWEVER WE DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WITHIN THEIR HOME
VISITING PROGRAM THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS MADE
AVAILABLE TO RESEARCH NEW HOME
VISITING PROGRAMS THAT FINDING
COULD BE DEPLOYED IMMEDIATELY
TO PROVE AN EXISTING PROGRAM
THOUGHTLESSNESS FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP COUNTY THERE
ALREADY FACE. AND BUDGET
SHORTFALL ON BEHALF OF HEALTH.
ACADEMY THE FAMILY PHYSICIANS
TO BE. DAY ACROSS AND THANK YOU
FOR BECAUSE- AT THE LONG BROWN.
CARE PROGRAM. AND WE GREATLY A-
ALL THE MEASURE. MADE ON BEHALF
HOW ACT THAT THANK YOU AND LOOK
FORWARD TO. CALVET INITIATE.
NEXT DEADLINE THIRTY EIGHT. YOU
HAVE A TIME YOU YOUR LINE IS
OPEN OUTLINED THIRTY EIGHT.
HELLO GOOD MORNING IS RONALD
COMMON ON BEHALF OF HEALTH ACT
OF CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BUDGET PLANET
REJECT PROPOSED CUTS TO SENIOR
COVERAGE AND ENSURES ALL THING
IS OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE
REGARDLESS OF AGE DISABILITY
THE AMOUNT OF THEIR SAVINGS AN
ASSET TO THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FULL
SCALE MEDI CAL. WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTING WITHDRAWAL THE
PROPOSAL TO PENCILS GO MEDI CAL
DOING DOCUMENTING AS WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DELAY
SENIORS ARE PARTICULARLY
SUSCEPTIBLE TO COVET NINETEEN
COMPLICATIONS AND WE ARE TO A
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THE
EXPANSION HAPPENS IMMEDIATELY
WE NEED TO GET THE THING IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MANAGE THEIR
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS IN A
PANDEMIC THAT IS. ESSENTIALLY
PREYING ON AND WE ALSO
APPRECIATE SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE'S PLAN TO REJECT
THE DRIVEWAY CUTS TO MEDICALLY
NECESSARY BENEFITS AND DATA CAL
FOR MILLIONS OF ADULTS WITH
MEDICAL COVERAGE MANY SERVICES
HELP PREVENT WORSE OUTCOMES AND
MARK EXPENSIVE INTERVENTIONS
LATER ON WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
REJECTION TO SEE THAT AND THE
FIFTEEN ND I JUST SAT.
ENSURING ALTERNATIVE TO NURSING
HOMES WE ALSO SPOKE THE
REJECTION OF PROPERTY SIX- CUTS
FOR PROVIDERS HOWEVER WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED WITH A CUTS TO
COVER TO COVER CALIFORNIA AND
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE GOVERNOR'S
AND TAKING BACK YOU'RE READY
ALLOCATED AFFORDABILITY
ASSISTANCE FUNDS FROM
CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA
STRUGGLING TO BUY COVERAGE. WE.
HOPE THE LEGISLATIVE. LISTEN
THANK. CONNECT EIGHT. THANK YOU
MARTY A MOTO FAN MEMBER CALL
DISABILITY COMING ACTION
NETWORK HE CAN FIRST OF ALL
JUSTICE AND PRAYERS FOR GEORGE
FLOYD IN THE FAMILY INTO OUR
NATION STRONG SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE'S- PROPOSED VERSION
THE STATE BUDGET THAT IS PER
CONTAINER ESPECIALLY IN THE
REJECTION OF ALL THE TRIGGER
CUTS TO MSF PC THAT REGIONAL
CREDIT I COULD SET THAT THE
FIGHT OF THE MEDICAL EDUCATION
AND MORE THANKS TO ALL OF YOU
FOR THE GOOD WORK WITH THE
BUDGET THAT UNDERSCORED THAT WE
TAKE THE UNPRECEDENTED PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR DOING THIS HEARING. NEXT
DEADLINE FORTY SEVEN. YES GOOD
MORNING CAN LIVE WITH THEM
REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW AND
WE APPRECIATE THE PACKAGE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE PUT FORWARD TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY IN THE AREAS OF
EDUCATION AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES I'M WE APPLIED YOUR
SUPPORT EVERY PAINTING THE
FAMILY URGENT RESPONSE WITH
THEM IN EXPEDITING IT
IMPLEMENTATION PROTECTION OF
PROPERTY SIX FIND AND CHILD
CARE PROGRAM NAME THAT YOU WE
REALLY ARE YOU TO STAY STRONG
AND FINAL NEGOTIATIONS WRAP UP
BUT THE GOVERNOR. AND THEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YEARS AND THEY
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
PROTECTION OF HUMAN SERVICE
PROGRAMS AS WELL AND PREVENTING
THEM FROM AG ADMITTING YOU CAN
THE HOMELESSNESS WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT THERE IS A BENEFIT FOR YOU
ANYTHING. SHOP IN THE STATE AND
YOUR COLOR AND LGBT Q. YOU
CONTINUE TO BE ARE OVER
REPRESENTED YOU TO DISCONNECT
POLICIES AND PRACTICES THAT
DISADVANTAGE THE BEER. ANYTHING
ABOUT 50% OF YOUNG PEOPLE LOSE
THEIR JOBS AND ANTICIPATE THAT
THE LONG TERM ECONOMIC IMPACT
WILL LEAD TO AN INCREASED
NUMBER OF YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. NOW MORE THAN
EVER WE NEED THE STATE TO
ADDRESS THE MEDIA THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE THIRTY THREE.
KELLEY BEAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND POSITION MEMBERS YOU
MAY COMMENCE THE LEGISLATURE
FOR CRAFTING A BUDGET PLAN THAT
PRIORITIZES ACT WITH THE
HEALTHCARE FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA
AT A TIME WHEN CALIFORNIANS ARE
STRUGGLING FINANCIALLY AND THE
MEDIC HOW KIDS THOUGHT AS
EXPECTED TO INCREASE BY MORE
THAN TWO MILLION PATIENT. WE
MUST PROTECT VITAL SERVICES FOR
THOSE WHO NEED THEM OUT. THIS
BUDGET IMPASSE IN PROGRAMS THAT
IMPROVE MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO
CARE BY INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF PHYSICIANS CARING FOR MEDI
CAL PATIENTS. BUDGET THIRD
STATEMENT OF VALUES AND THE
PLAN SHOWS THAT ENSURING ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE INCLUDING LOW
INCOME RURAL AND MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IF THE
COURT CALIFORNIA VALUE THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTY EIGHT
ZERO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL
GET THE EXACT DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
AGENCY THEY WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR INCLUDING THE STATUTORY
RELIEF MEASURE IN THE VERSION
OF THE BUDGET UNDER REVIEW
TODAY THE RELIEF MEASURE
MEASURES WILL PROVIDE HUGELY
CRITICAL SUPPORT TO TRANSLATE
AND HE STATEWIDE THE GRABBED
THE FINANCIAL OPERATIONAL
IMPACT BECAUSE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. IF ENACTED THE
FEDERAL RELIEF MEASURES WOULD
PROTECT TRANSIT FUNDING
ENCOURAGE TRANSIT AGENCIES ARE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
LIFELINE TRAIN SERVICE THE
COMMUNITIES AN ESSENTIAL WORKER
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE WE THANK
YOU YOUR STAFF AND MEMBERS IN
BOTH HOUSES RECOGNIZING THE
NEED TO INCLUDE THE STATUTORY
RELIEF MEASURE THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET AGREEMENT
AT YOUR CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS WITH YOU
ADDITIONAL MEASURES INCLUDING
POTENTIALLY FUNDING THAT WOULD
BE NECESSARY TO FURTHER SUPPORT
TRANSIT AGENCIES. DURING A.
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE. EIGHTY FIVE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRENDAN
KILLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
ENDING THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
SMALL THIRTY FIVE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS WE APPRECIATE AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE FIFTY
MILLION IN IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING FOR THE EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY AIR
PROTECTION PROGRAM IN THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET PACKAGE-
THIS COMMUNITY BASED GRAHAM IS
MAKING SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS. IN
REDUCING AIR POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA OVER BURDEN
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT THIS
CRITICAL FUNDING WORK BEING
DONE BY A COMMUNITIES AIR
DISTRICTS AND THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO CLEAN UP
AIR POLLUTION IN OVER BURDEN
COMMUNITIES OR SLOW
DRAMATICALLY OR STOP ALL
TOGETHER. WE KNOW THAT FOR THE
PROGRAM TO CONTINUE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL ADEQUATE AND ONGOING
FUNDING IS ESSENTIAL AND WHILE
LESS THAN ACTUAL PROGRAM COSTS
THE FUNDING WILL AT LEAST
ENSURE THE WORK CONTINUES AND
AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS
REALIZED IN OVER BURDEN
COMMUNITIES AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
THAT BOTH HOUSES HAVE PROVIDED
THIS IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH
FUNDING. FOR SOME OF CALIFORNIA
PHONE USE MOST OVERBURDENED
COMMUNITIES AND WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORT THE. FUNDING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT DEADLINE.
EIGHTY SIX. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT THE MARK APART
ON BEHALF THE WESTERN STATES
PATROLLING THE FIFTY SHOULD NOT
BE LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE LEGISLATURE'S%
INCLUSION AND THE CAP AND TRADE
PROPOSAL AND IN THE JOINT
BUDGET WE CERTAINLY BELIEVE
OUTLINED PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
THE LOWER PRICE THAN OTHER
WHITE METAL THE PROGRAM ONLY
THIRD ACTUALLY INCREASE AFTER
CONSUMERS AND- I THINK WE CAN
ALL AGREE THAT. OR AT THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NO DOUBT. FOR THE-
CHANGE HAPPENS AT WORK WHILE
THE CALIFORNIA KIND OF PROGRAM.
WE ARE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR YEARS
EARLY. NOT TO MENTION A RB
ALREADY HAS THE AUTHORITY TO DO
SUCH A WILL TO DO THAT HAVE A
BILL MAKING THAT OUTLINED IN
THE PROPOSAL AND WE THINK THAT
THIS IS. AN UNNECESSARY-
ANNETTE ANNETTE THAT THEIR
ACTIVITY BY THE LEGISLATURE-
AND WE BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW
CAP AND TRADE. I AM ALWAYS
INTENDED TO REDUCE EMISSIONS AT
THE REC NEW GENERATION IS A
SECONDARY BENEFIT THAT. WE
WOULD. ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK
SERIOUSLY AT THE PROPOSAL AND
ASKED WHETHER OR NOT CONSUMERS
CAN WITHSTAND. ADDITIONAL PART
AND- LIKE. NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAKING PAPERS ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATE OF PRESENTING THIRTEEN
HUNDRED COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND HER
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK WE
APPRECIATE AND ARE THANKFUL FOR
THE LEGISLATURE INTERJECTING
MANY OF THE TRIGGER CUTS TO
CRITICAL HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE VITAL FOR SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS AND FOR REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD HAVE
ELIMINATED AND ASK YOU EACH
SHEET ABILITY TO CARVE OUT
PHARMACY SERVICES. ADDITIONALLY
WE'RE THANKFUL THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AT RESTORING THE
FUNDING FOR THE FONG BROWN
PROGRAM AT A TIME WHEN
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE SHORTAGES
NEVER BEEN MORE APPARENT AND
FINALLY WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S LEADERSHIP AND
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT THE MEDI CAL
PHARMACY TRANSITION WILL HAVE
ON HEALTH AND RISK BY RESTORING
THE COUPLE METAL PAYMENT FOR
HEALTH CENTERS WE MAINTAIN. OUR
CONCERN THAT THE PHARMACY
TRANSITION AND ENVIRONMENT
RIGHT FOR FURTHER DESTABILIZING
A FRAGILE SAFETY NET AND
DISTRACT CLINICAL CARE TEAMS
THE PLANT THE CRITICAL WORK TO
MAINTAINING THE COMMUNITY THAT
WE RE OPEN CALIFORNIA WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND. OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON THAT THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE NINETY ONE.
MISTER SHARON MEMBERS BUT
REALLY YOU ON BEHALF OF THE C.
P. U. I. JOINT EFFORT BETWEEN
UT W. AT THE ARE YOU
REPRESENTING OVER FORTY
THOUSAND FAMILY CHAPTER
PROVIDERS WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP TO REJECT THE
10% CUT TO TALK YOUR RATE. WE
URGE THE FAMILY TO DOT THE SAME
HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION FOR
TITLE POINT YOUR FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS THAT THE READY
PROPOSED FOR TITLE FIGHT
CENTERS SO WE ARE APPRECIATIVE
OF THE TRACK YOUR SITE AND WE
BELIEVE THIS SITE AND SHOULD
NOT REPLACE THE PROVISION OF
FAMILIES ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
BRING YOUR CHILDREN TO CARE
PROVIDERS NEED TO BE
FINANCIALLY PROTECTED DURING
THAT TIME. WE ALSO URGE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE BEFORE
POLICY SPECIFICALLY EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE SB ONE SEVENTY FOUR
TO BE A DOCTOR IN THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND FINALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE U. D. W. WE
OPPOSE ALL THE CORRECT I JUST
THAT IN THE TYPICALLY
HIGHLIGHTING THE NUMBER THANK
HIGH. THE UPON THE ASSEMBLY FOR
REJECTING THIS MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL TO PROTECT. OUR
PROVIDERS AND CLIENTS. THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE. ONE OH
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS STILL
A CRAB ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT AND GREAT
APPRECIATION TO THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE FOR WORKING TOGETHER
TO PROVIDE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING THE LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
PACKAGE. THIS FUNDING IS
CRITICAL TO ALLOW WORKERS RIGHT
HERE DISTRICTS IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE COMMUNITY TO CONTINUE
TO CLEAN UP LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
THIS IS EXACTLY IMPORTANT GIVEN
FINDINGS THAT EXPOSURE TO AIR
POLLUTION COMBINED THE CALL THE
NINETEEN WILL RESULT IN
INCREASED AT AND CHESTER BUT
NEGATIVE HEALTH IMPACTS. THIS
FUNDING WILL HELP TO ENSURE
THAT THE HOW THE COMMUNITY IS
PROTECTED. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE TWELVE OF THE
HUNDRED TWELVE. IF YOU'RE SURE
MEMBERS PER CHILD DISABILITY
RIGHT CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO
THANK YOU THE MEMBERS AND THE
STAFF FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE TO CRAFT A BUDGET ALONG
WITH THE SENATE THAT WOULD
PROTECT THE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES AND SENIORS WHO
TAKING THE BRUNT OF THAT
PANDEMIC KIDS WHO CONTINUE TO
REMAIN CALL NORMAL. WERE
SPECIALLY CHRISTIAN UPLAND
SUPPORT THE REJECTION OF THE
ELIMINATION OR REJECTION
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY SEA BASS
MS US BE AYE HSS 7% REDUCTION
SS I SS BE THE MEDI CAL
OPTIONAL SERVICES IN THE
EIGHTEEN T. SENIOR PENALTY AND
WANTED CLUED IN THERE ALSO THE
RICH WE APPRECIATE THE
REJECTION OF THE REDUCTION TO
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
AND- FINAL WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE REJECTION OF THE
REDUCTION. PROGRAM SERVING
PERSONS WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL. DISABILITIES
THANK YOU. NEXT. ONE THANK YOU
MEDICARE MEMBERS MY EXPENSE ON
BEHALF OF BOTH THE CALIFORNIA
PODIATRIC MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
CDMA AND AMERICAN COLLEGE BILL
WHICH YOU ANSWER NINE A COG
LIKE THANKYOU MISTER CHAIR IN
THE ASSEMBLY LEADERSHIP FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE BUDGET PLAN IS
BEFORE US IF YOU MAY AND A CAR
PROPERTY WE PLEASE WITHIN IN
SUPPORT OF THE PRESERVATION THE
MEDICAL PAYMENTS FOR POSITION
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX.
INDIVIDUALLY SEAT MAY WOULD
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RECOGNITION OF THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF OPTIONAL BENEFIT
COVERAGE IN THE KIKWIT PODIATRY
AND FRANKLY THAT'S COVERED
COVERAGE IN THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
PLAN YEAH BREAK BECAUSE THEY'RE
VERY PLEASED WITH AND SUPPORT
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL TO MAINTAIN
THE FUNDING ANEST AFTER THIRTY
THAT EXTENDS MEDI CAL FOR POST
PARTUM WOMEN WITH MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS WILL
HOLD FOR THE PROPOSAL'S REMAIN
IN THE BUDGET AS NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE- MOVE FORWARD. YEAH
BEHALF OF THE CHANGE I ASK THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO CONSIDER FISCAL
SUPPORT TRADITIONAL TELL A
PROGRAMS MOST NOTABLY HE
CONSOLE THAT ARE SEEKING THAT
CONNECTS TO HELP THEM PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE CARE DURING THE
LONG AFTER DISCONTENT THANK.
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO COMMENT
TODAY. MAC DEADLINE ONE SIXTY.
HI THIS IS JUSTIN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR GRATITUDE TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR PROVIDING ONE
BILLION AS AYE REALIGNMENT BACK
STILL IN RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
HELP PRESERVE THE SAFETY NET
SERVICES THE COUNTY PROVIDE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE ABOUT THIS
FUNDING PUBLIC HEALTH SOCIAL
SERVICES AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH
SERVICES WOULD SUFFER
DEVASTATING CUTS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION TODAY
ABOUT THE SERVICES WILL BE
IMPACTED. AND THAT THIS FUNDING
TO UTILIZE FOR BOTH NINETEEN
NINETY ONE AND TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT SO THAT IT CAN HELP
PROTECT THE FULL RANGE OF
COUNTY SERVICES. AND FINALLY WE
STRONGLY URGE IMPOSSIBLE ONE
BILLION IN FUNDING FOR SAFETY
NET SERVICES BE MAINTAINED TO
THE FINAL BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS
BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE NINETEEN. HELLO
THIS THEIR INDICATING ALL FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I WANT
TO REITERATE MY COLLEAGUE JUST
COMMENT MAYBE IF WE JUST NOW ON
THE REALIGNMENT BACK FAILED FOR
STATE UN STATE SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS THAT ARE RUN BY COUNTY
I WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THE COMPROMISE ON TAKING
MORE TIME TO LOOK AT THE
GOVERNOR SPEAKING TAX PROPOSAL-
WE SUPPORT- HAPPEN ABOUT THE
TAXES THEY HELP REDUCE USAGE
BUT ALSO TO BACK. UP ON OUR
FIRST FIVE COMMISSION PROVIDE
IMPORTANT SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
AGED ZERO TO FIVE AND WE
BELIEVE THE COMMISSION SHOULD
ALSO BE INCLUDED IN THE
CONVERSATIONS ON THE NEW BIG
BIG PACK AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE AND THE
ENTIRE LEGISLATURE FOR COMING
TOGETHER IN THE IMPROPER. THAN
AT HOME THANK YOU. NEXT ONE
EIGHTEEN. KAREN MEMBERS MY
DEFENSES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE LEGISLATIVE CAP AND
TRADE PROPOSAL THAT REQUIRED A
RB TO RE OPEN OR MAKE CHANGES
TO THE PROGRAM WE'D LIKE TO
THINK IT'S A MEMBER COOPER FONG
AND OBERNOLTE FURTHER
COMMENTARY ON TO BEGIN HE TO BE
OPPOSED TO THE PROPOSED BUT
THEY WILL VERY LIKELY LEAD TO.
INCREASED COST AND ON CONSUMERS
AND MANUFACTURED AS WE ATTEMPT
TO RECOVER FROM THE ONGOING
ECONOMIC RECESSION. OVER IT
THAT LEGISLATURE JUST RECENTLY
EXTENDED CAP AND TRADE AND THE
PROPOSAL UNDERMINED THE WORK
ALREADY COMPLETED WE
RESPECTFULLY ENCOURAGE YOU
OUGHT TO RE EXAMINE THE
PROPOSAL BEFORE MOVING FORWARD
WITH THAT WE ALSO LOOK FORWARD
TO PARTICIPATING IN ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS AROUND EACH YET
THE GOVERNMENT OF THE CO REFORM
WE WOULD LIKE THE PROPOSAL THAT
CREATES A RESPONSIVE AND
TRANSPARENT DEPARTMENT AND ARE
CURRENTLY OPPOSED. TO MAYBE BUY
ONE. THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
ONE TWENTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THE
SO CALLED LONDON LONDON
GONZALEZ ADVOCACY TO HIM
REPRESENTING THE ALLIANCE
SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES AND ALSO BE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION. FIRST OF THE
ALLIANCE OF LIKE TO THINK THE
ASSEMBLY FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND PROPOSING RESTORATION OF
THE FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS WITH
IDT IN THEIR FAMILIES. IN THE
CASE OF EARLY INTERVENTIONS
THAT CAN LITERALLY BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A CHILD IN
HIS OR HER ABILITY TO LEARN TO
WALK OR SPEAK THE REST OF HIS
OR HER LIFE FOR ADULTS THE
TRANSLATE TO THE ABILITY OF
THEM TO LIVE WITH ID D.
ALONGSIDE A IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
ON BEHALF OF THE PHYSICAL
THERAPY ASSOCIATION YOUR
SUPPORT YOUR REJECTION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
ELIMINATE PHYSICAL THERAPY FOR
THE MEDICARE PROGRAM UNDER THAT
PROPOSAL PATIENT CO LITERALLY A-
I HAVE A NEW YEAR HIP
REPLACEMENT BUT NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO THE PHYSICAL THERAPY THAT.
THAT SAVINGS IS ONLY FIVE POINT
SIX MILLION BUT WE LOSE FORTY
MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS SIMPLY
PUT NOT A GREAT IDEA THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
WE. READY TO ASSIST YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE WANT. ONE GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS DOCTOR DEBBY
KLEIN PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FACT IS
GRATEFUL TO THE ASSEMBLY FOR
ITS COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUDGET
PROPOSAL WHICH MAKES IT
POSSIBLE FOR US TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY AND
ACCESSIBLE EDUCATION FOR OUR
TWO POINT ONE MILLION STUDENTS.
ELIMINATING HOW BRIGHT IS A
FISCALLY PRUDENT DECISION THAT
PRIORITIZES FUNDING FOR OUR ONE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN COLLEGES
TO MEET ONLINE STUDENT DEMAND
ACROSS THE STATE. ANY FUNDING
FOR PART TIME FACULTY IS A
STUDENT CENTERED AND MUCH
NEEDED INVESTMENT FOR OUR 7070%
OF THE FACULTY IN OUR SYSTEM.
WE WANT TO COMMEND THE ASSEMBLY
FOR REJECTING CUT STRONG WORK
FORCE AND THE ACADEMIC SENATE
FOR ADOPTING A HOLD HARMLESS
EXTENSION OF THE FUNDING
FORMULA AND FOR KEEPING CURRENT
FUNDING LEVELS FOR ETHIOPIA.
FINALLY THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL
TO INCLUDE A BASIC NEEDS BLOCK
GRANT IS THE TYPE OF INVESTMENT
ARE COLLEGES NEED RIGHT NOW TO
COMBAT HOUSING AND INSECURITY
INCREASED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. AND PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR ONLINE INSTRUCTION FACT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND TREMENDOUS SUPPORT OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE TWENTY TWO. HI JAN
DIETRICH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL
ADVOCACY ALLIANCE WE WANTED TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE FOR OPPOSING THE TRIGGER
CUT AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND
APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS
UNDERSTANDING THAT MANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS WILL NOT COME
BACK IF THEY ARE CUT NOW- AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS CAN'T MEET
INCREASED MINIMUM WAGE
REQUIREMENTS THE ADDED COSTS
FOR HELPING FIFTY PROTOCOL FOR
CO THEY'D- AND SERVE THE SAME
NUMBER STUDENTS ALL WITH A 15%
CUT STATE FUNDING. AND AS
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE WITH THE
GOVERNOR WE HOPE THAT YOU CAN
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR IT. RIGHT
THE CAT FOR AFTER SCHOOL ADD TO
THAT THE MOST IMPACTED STUDENT
FAMILY CRITICAL OF HAVE THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED RIGHT NOW TO
RECOVER THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
DEADLINE EIGHTY TWO. JERRY
BROWN WITH THE COUNTY BE EVER
ALL CHARACTERS THE VISION THE
COUNT OPERATE VERY UNSETTLING
CRITICAL PROGRAMS ON BEHALF OF
THE REALIGNMENT INCLUDING
MEDICAL SPECIALTY MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES COUNTY THEY'RE BEING
AT YOUR DRESS AND GOING TO EVER
HOPE THAT BUT THEN I BUT 1120%
LESS REVENUE WILL FILL
COMPLYING WITH FEDERAL APRIL IN
TOTAL COUNTY BUILDING OVER
THREE POINT THREE BILLION OVER
TWO YEARS. COUNTIES LED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ARE AT THE WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND ADMINISTRATION TO PRESERVE
REALIGNED PROGRAMS AND AVOID
MATH OF CUT OR SERVICE THE
DESTRUCTION SERVICE THE LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS NEED THE MOST
DURING THE TIME THANK YOU A
MEMBER ARAMBULA FOR MENTIONING
THEM FOR THE WORKING THE COUNTY
PARTNERS ON REALIGNMENT ON WE
ALSO THANK THE LEGISLATURE PART
OF ONE BILLION DOLLAR
REALIGNMENT BACK STILL. THANK
YOU AND- NEXT. ONE FIVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS SAMANTHA TRAN
REPRESENTING CHILDREN NOW WE'D
LIKE TO THINK THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE FOR PROTECTING EARLY
LEARNING FUNDING AFTER OPENING
AND EDUCATIONAL FUNDING- WE
ALSO- LIKE TO ELEVATE AND
THINK- THE NUMBERS FOR THE
INCLUSION OF PROVISIONS FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER IS. A
LEGISLATION AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE TO CLOSE THE UP THE FACT
SENTINEL CONCENTRATION FUNDING
LOOPHOLE IN THE BUDGET HI THIS
IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE
SUFFICIENT SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIA I NEED KIDS- WE WANT
TO ELEVATE AND ALSO TALK ABOUT
THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE- WITH
RESPECT TO COLLECTING
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES IN THE
CONVERSATION IF CURRENTLY
HAPPENING ENGLISH LEARNERS FOX
YOU PRESSURE LEGISLATION LOW
INCOME STUDENTS ARE BEING
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. BY
THE AND EVEN TO SUPPORTING
THAT'S HAPPENING ACROSS THE
STATE AND THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
ARE LEARNING OFTEN TRAUMA THAT
THAT'S OCCURRING- GETS CRITICAL
THE ANY FLEXIBILITY- THAT IS
PROVIDED IS COUPLED WITH
NECESSARY SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS ARE NOT NEITHER.
CONSTITUTIONALLY GUARANTEED
RIGHT AT. ACCESS TO PUBLIC AT.
THANK YOU. NEXT THE WANT FOUR.
BY THIS IS PATRICK WELL TO THE
CALIFORNIA MINUTES BE UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION COMMENTING ON THE
CAP AND TRADE PROPOSAL WE
APPRECIATE DISCUSSION THAT WE
HAD WITH LEGISLATIVE STAFF TO
DISCUSS OUR CONCERNS WE REMAIN
OPOSED MAKING CHANGES THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS. WELL WE GET TO
SEE THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THE CHANGES
BEING DISCUSSED COULD INCREASE
COP THE PROGRAM COMPLIANCE
WHICH WOULD BE PASSED ON- FOR
OUR MEMBERS TO ELECTRICALLY AT
CALIFORNIANS AROUND THE STATE
ARE ALREADY TAKING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS MENTIONED MANY
TIMES AT POTENTIALLY MADE WORSE
BY THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THE COURTESY BY THE CAPTAIN
TRIP PROGRAM IS WORKING
AFFECTED. AT ENDED. DO YOU HAVE
GAP MISSION. I FORTY OR DO
GREENHOUSE EMISSIONS BY ALMOST
30% MORE THAN A OTHER STEP
CAPPING TRADED EXPECTED TO
RESULT AND ANOTHER MISSIONARY
DOT OF AT LEAST 38% BY TWENTY
THIRTY WE- RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO RECONSIDER- INCLUSION OF
THIS PROPOSAL IN THE BUDGET.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE FORTY
NINE. HI MY NAME'S MATT USUALLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION WE GOT CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PROPOSED FACILITY
CLOSURES AND I'D LIKE TO ECHO
THE ISSUES RAISED BY A FAMILY
MEMBER COOPER IN REGARDS THE
STAFF DISPLACEMENT. WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT THE FEDERAL CAPS THE
SPECIALLY THE POPULATION TRENDS
DON'T CONTINUE TO HOLD IN TWO
CULTURES COULD SIGNIFICANTLY
IPACT THE FIFTH ABILITY TO
ADAPT IN THE POPULATION CHANGES.
ON THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE
CLOSURES ALSO RAISED CONCERNS
WITH THE WORD LIVE DJ HAVE
UNIQUE AND HIGH LEVEL NEED IN
OUR MEMBERS ARE CLEARLY BEST
SUITED AND NOT ABLE TO SERVE
THE NEEDS OF THESE AWARDS. OUR
COUNTY THEY'RE ALREADY
OVERBURDENED AND STRUGGLING TO
KEEP UP WITH CASE LOADS AND
THEY'RE UNLIKELY TO BE ABLE TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK DR WEBER FOR
SOME OF HER COMMENTS IN REGARDS
TO CONCERNS WITH THE PROCESSES
WELL IT SEEMS THAT THERE'S A
LACK OF A- CLEAR PLAN STANDARDS
AND CRITERIA FOR THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS MOVING FORWARD
AS WELL. THANK YOU. MAC LINE
NINETY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOONMR
CARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMISSION
OR NO INCLUDE JACK ON BEHALF OF
OUR GLOBAL THIRTY ASIANS AND
COMMISSION- BIRTH IN OPPOSITION
OF THE STATE WATER BOARD
APPROVAL OF ONE POINT THREE
NINE MILLION FOR THE ASSESSMENT
OF SURFACE WATER QUALITY AND
ONE POINT EIGHT THREE MILLION
FOR WATER RESILIENT OR POLIO
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO THE
PROGRAM BUT WERE OPPOSED TO THE
FACT THAT THE DOCTOR WOULD BE
PAID BY INCREASING RATE ON.
PERMIT HOLDER- WHICH IS VERY
CONCERNING WHICH IF THE IMPACT
THE AG INDUSTRY FROM KOBE-
SECOND WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE.
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD I'M ALL OF FOR EIGHT.
THIS OR SAFE DRINKING. THIS
WELLTHE POSITION FOR LAST YEAR
WITH THEM OVER CAP THAT LEADS
QUITE AS THE TO HAVE. BRED
MINISTER OF CAR BUT WE THINK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD WE-
THE FROM OF THIS. FIND WE ARE
THE CAP AND TRADE THAT A REAL
REAL MAKING IMAGES LIKE TO ONE
OUR COM. WITHOUT OF MARGOT PART
THAT WITH THE ENOUGH THAT THE
LEGISLATURE RECONSIDER THEIR
AND REJECT THE PROPOSAL. THE
BUDGET PROCESS THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE FIFTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON KEVIN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION PDA STRONGLY
APPRECIATE SO LATER STOP
APPROACH TO BALANCING THE
BUDGET AS IT PERTAINS
HEALTHCARE THE MAY REVISED TO
DECIMATE THE DENTAL PROVIDER
NETWORK IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
HEALTH CARE CRISIS ENDED A TIME
WHEN MORE CALIFORNIANS THAN
EVER WILL NEED THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM TO HELP THEM. WE
SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE'S
PROPOSAL TO REJECT DEVASTATING
CUTS IN THE MEDICAL PROGRAMS
BUT THE PROP SIXTY IT DETECTS
FUNDING AND ADULT DENTAL
BENEFITS AND OTHER TIME FOR
FEDERAL ACTION ANY BEEN NINETY
PROPOSED ADDITIONAL REVENUE
SOLUTIONS IF NEEDED. THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE NINETY SEX. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBER ANY MAGANA
HALF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC POWER AUTHORITY WE
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION AROUND POTENTIAL
CHANGES THAT THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAMS DURING THE HEARING AND
ARE OPPOSED TO MAKING ANY
CHANGES TO THAT PROGRAM THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS. OVER
UNCERTAIN WHAT EXACTLY THE
LANGUAGE WHICH DAY WERE
CONCERNED WITH DISCUSSION
AROUND AN INCREASE OF THE FLOOR
PRICE AND AFTERMARKET
MODIFICATIONS. WHICH WOULD
INCREASE THE COST FOR
COMPLIANCE UNDER THE PROGRAM AT
ANY INCREASES WOULD HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO INCREASE COSTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS RATE PAYERS WE ARE
ALREADY FACING AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS. OBLIGATED ENTITIES
SUBJECT TO CAP AND TRADE.
BUILDING IN THE PROGRAM AND A
CARP FEEL THAT THERE ARE
NECESSARY CHANGES THAT NEED TO
BE MADE THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY. ALREADY TO RE OPEN
THAT WILL MAKING AND DO THAT ON
THEIR OWN. WE THINK THAT IT'S
AN APPROPRIATE AT THIS POINT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS TO DIRECT THEM.
TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES THANK YOU.
NEXT. SIXTY ONE. GO AHEAD LINE
SIXTY ONE HI I'M HERE- OF THE
STAR WAS SAYING I'M WITH THE
FOR OUTPATIENT I'M OPPOSED TO
CUTTING OUR PROGRAM A PROGRAM
TRANSITION SLOWLY FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES HELPING THEM GET
JOBS. FIND HELPING GET THEIR
IDEAS AND DRIVER'S LICENSE
PREVENTS BUT SINCE THE NEW FROM
FURTHER ESTABLISHMENT OF.
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH CLINIC
DO NOT DO WHAT WE DO AND OFTEN
DO NOT WANT TO DEAL WITH THE
POPULATION WE DEAL WITH WE WORK
WITH SEX OFFENDERS LIE BIRTH
HELLO CONVICTED OF VIOLENT
CRIME. WE ARE HERE ARE TOTALLY
FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS IN
ADDITION WE HAVE THE USE THE
POTENTIAL OF BILLING. MEDI CAL
FOR OUR SERVICEMEN. I KNOW IN
CAN YOU. EVEN FIRED THE KORAN A
CRISIS THAT WOULD PUBLIC OUT
OVER THE BURGEONING NUMBER OF
HOMELESS AND INCREASING CRIME.
WE ARE A STRATEGIC PROGRAM
WHICH ADDRESS WILL BE A PROBLEM
WHAT LOW ASSEMBLY LITTLE
EXPENSE THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE TWENTY THREE.
THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
COMMON KANAME ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ARC IN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION WE
WANT TO THANK YOU AND ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL THE ENTIRE ASSEMBLY FOR
ALL THE HARD WORK IN LEADERSHIP
THAT WENT INTO THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL. ORTON APPRECIATE THAT
YOU HAVE REJECTED THE GOVERNOR.
OPPOSED CUT ANSWER CUT THROUGH
THE DEVELOPMENTAL. THEM I JUST
LAST VIDAK THAT THE P. AND
OTHER IMPORTANT COMMUNITY BASED
SERVICES THAT ARE ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL. FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. REALLY APPRECIATE ALL
THE HARD WORK YOU GUYS HAVE
DONE- AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
FORTY SIX. GO AHEAD NINE FORTY
SIX. JAB AT THEM YOU. WE'LL GO
TO THE NEXT ONE MONTH LINE ONE
TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT THE THING UNDER QUIRK
HARVEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT CD HA REPRESENTS OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
WHO SUFFER FROM A MENTAL HEALTH
OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS.
THE IMPACT OF HAVING NINETEEN
ON CBS AND PROFOUND IN A
GROWING OUR AGENCY THAT HAD A
FURLOUGH AND LAY OFF STAFF
IMPACTING THE SERVICES THEY ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE CLIENT CODE
THANK YOU FOR PROPOSAL THAT THE
MONEY BACK ON THE TABLE FOR THE
VULNERABLE POPULATION THE THIRD
INCLUDING KIDS CONTAINER. WE
APPRECIATE THE BEHAVIORAL
COUNSELOR AND EMERGENCY ROOM
PROPOSAL THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
THE PROPOSAL AND THE ONE
BILLION IN NINETY ONE
REALIGNMENT BACK FILLING
FUNDING HOWEVER THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DEPENDED ON THE VERGE OF
COLLAPSE AND WE MUST TAKE STEPS
NOW. TO BACK WILL NOT ONLY
NINETEEN NINETY ONE BUT ALSO
TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT
DOLLARS FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
TO SHARE THE COMMENT. ON BEHALF
OF PEDIATRIC NUMBERS. NEXT
DEADLINE. ONE OH TWO. HI MY
NAME MIGUEL CANNELLA- WITH THE
VOCAL GROUP COUNTY UP THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FROM BY
MALEK MOM FOUND LIKE THAT
THANK- CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS-
SPECIFICALLY LIKE TO THANK
MISTER COOPER MISTER FONG
INDUSTRIAL RUN IF YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS. WE THE
CAPTURE WILL MAKE BEING AS JEER
AT WILL MAKE. RIGHT WELL
MAKING. YOU CANNOT INCREASE G.
EUROPE REVENUES WITHOUT
INCREASING COSTS OF TO
CONSUMERS AND REPAIRS THE
CHANGES WILL NOT ATTRACT
INVESTMENT TO CLIMB OUT OF THE
RECESSION RESULTING FROM GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. OPPOSE BUDGET HOLDERS
IN AND UP TO SENATOR TO IN ITS
SIMPLEST TERMS DEMAND
INCREASING TALK TO THE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM IS
PERFORMING TO EXPECTATIONS ONE
EMISSIONS ARE BELOW THE TARGET
AND WE JUST ENTERED INTO A
RECESSION. THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FROM SUN TO
PROVIDE NOT OF THE
CONSIDERATIONS REQUIRED MAYBE
THIRTY TWO SB THIRTY TWO OR
EIGHTY THREE NINETY EIGHT THAT
THAT'LL BY THE- LEGISLATURE.
SEVENTEEN SUCH CONSIDERATIONS
FOR ADDITIONAL WE CAN
ASSISTANCE YOU RELOCATION-
PRODUCTION AND JOBS IMPACT
REPAIRS AND CONSUMERS THESE
PROTECTIONS ARE WHY- THIS WAS
SO TIGHTLY KNIT DEDICATED ALIVE
YOU WERE ASKING LEGISLATURE'S
TO REJECT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION TERMINATION-
URGENTLY. REJECTION OF THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. REJECT
PERSONALLY BEING THANK YOU THE
ENTIRE MARKETS CAMPER. THIS IS
NOT THE TIME THE. NEXT DEADLINE
EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS STILL
ROSA GREATER SERVICE GENERAL
MANAGER FOR THE SOLVENCY OF
FORTY. IT WAS PART OF FORTY
CRISIS OF. EACH DISTRICT QUIRK
MARTINEZ. KILLED BY WATER.
SPEND THE COUNTY RIVERSIDE IF
CURRY ALL WE'RE WORKING
COOPERATION. CONSULTATION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA'S. THE REVERSE
CLIENT CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
LAKE THE SALTON SEA I'M
INTERESTED WE APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT FOR THE TO STRUGGLE
INVESTMENTS IN THE BUDGET THAT
WILL HELP. ADDRESS THE DANGERS
POLLUTION AND NEW RIVER.
ARGUABLY THE MOST POLLUTED AIR
AMERICA. WHILE ALSO CREATING
DEEPWATER HABITAT FOR THE
PACIFIC FLYWAY. THE LARGEST
MOST DIVERSE. MY TO CRY WHAT
ONES. IS LAW FIRM. WHAT MOR
SPECIES THERE THE ANYWHERE
BECAUSE THE GULF COAST. THESE
AREAS ARE AT THAT SUFFERING
DECLINE. THIS INVESTMENT BY
THIS BUDGET CYCLE WILL BE TO
REVERSE THAT. GET FREE OF
DESPAIR TURN THIS TROUBLE
WATERSHED A ROUTE AND PUT ON A
PATH FOR A HEALTHIER MORE
PROSPEROUS FUTURE WE THANK YOU.
AT THE MENU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
NEXT DEADLINE ONE THIRTY. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS EMMA THOMPSON. WITH DOWNTURN
ADVOCATES FOR YOU. AT. SORRY A
LITTLE BIT OF AN ECHO HERE. WE
CAN HEAR YOU FINE WELL
EVENTUALLY WE WANTED TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP HER
CHILDREN IN YEARS CONTRACTING
PARTICULARLY FOSTER USE. WHO
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY YOUTH OF
COLOR LGBT Q. YEARS OR YEARS
BUT THE FACILITIES. AND OUR- AT
HIGH RISK THE HOMELESSNESS AND
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITIONS
AND INCARCERATION OUR LAST. ARE
YOU TO OUR TRANSITION AGE YOU
ARE FOOD HOUSING EMPLOYMENT AND
EDUCATION INSPECTOR DURING THIS
TO ALL THE HEALTH PANDEMIC AND
WE APPRECIATE THE ACT AND HE'S
TAKEN TO PREVENT AND REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS AMONG USERS
TRANSITIONING TO USE AND THE
YOUNG PARENTS THANK YOU. THE
ELECTED LINE ONE THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEAN HEARD HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF TO CLIENTS BIRTH
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO EXTEND
OUR APPRECIATION OF FOR THE-
LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT AND
ACTION WE NEED TO SUPPORT THE
SAFETY NET IN PARTICULAR WE
APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION OF
THE IMPACT OF REALIGNMENT
REVENUES AND STRONGLY THE COURT
ARE YOUR EFFORTS TO BACK FILL A
PORTION OF THOSE REVENUES. WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REGULATE COMMENT HIGHLIGHTING-
THOSE IMPORTANT SERVICES THAT
YOU PROVIDE UNDER THE REAL
LINES PROGRAMS A WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT TRIED TO
THE RECEIPT OF FEDERAL FUNDS
BUT NEED LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON
IMPLEMENTATION. SECOND ON
BEHALF OF THEIR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE
WANT TO ECHO SUPPORTIVE
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
INVESTMENT- TO THE ALTON THE
I'M PARTICULAR FOR THE NORTHERN
PORTION OF THAT PERIMETER LAKE
WE APPRECIATE YOUR WORK. IN
THIS AREA AS WELL THANK YOU.
NEXT LINE. ONE THIRTY FOUR. HI
THIS IS NANCY WILL BECOME
JEWISH FAMILY SERVICE OF LOS
ANGELES I WILL JUST ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF SEVERAL OF THE
PREVIOUS COLLEAGUES THINKING
THE LEGISLATURE- AND ESPECIALLY
THE ASSEMBLY. AND SENATE LEADER
SHIP FOR OUR PROTECTING
SERVICES FOR FRAIL OLDER ADULTS
INCLUDING AND I THINK HE HE
BASS HSR. OF THE FEAR SEAT AS
WELL AS ALL THE OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ALLOW THEM TO RING MAIN
SAFELY AND HEALTHY IN THE
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY AT A TIME
OF BECAUSE IT NINETEEN. THE
SHEIK S. A WELL MISTER TEN.
ABOUT IF YOU DISMANTLE THE
SYSTEM NOW WHAT DO YOU GET
LATER AND APPRECIATE YOUR
INVESTMENT IN PROTECTING THE
TRAIL POPULATIONS WHICH FOR
STATE FINANCING MONEY FOR THE
STATE THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
NEGATIVE LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN BILL WITH
YOUR PRESIDENT THAT HAVE BOYS
NOW THAT THE DETAILS IN SCHOOL
ACCOUNTS ARE ALREADY PROPOSED
THE DOUBLES WEAVING MORE STRONG
SUPPORT STREAMLINED HARDSHIP
EXEMPTIONS FOR LOW WELL SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
WHICH DON'T HAVE THIS IN CASH
FLOW FLEXIBILITY IN PROPERTY
TAX BASES LARGE DISTRICTS. WELL
TO GREATER TRANSPARENT ON THE
UNUSED LTFS FUND ORIGINALLY
APPROPRIATED FOR SUPPLEMENT
CONCENTRATION GRANTS TO ADDRESS
THE STATE AUDITOR FINDINGS. AS
PROMOTED BY DR WEBER THE CHAIR
AND MANY THE MEMBERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE WE ALSO URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER CALLS FOR FLEXIBILITY
FOR INSTRUCTION IN A CAN
ATTENDANCE ACCOUNTING VERY
CAREFULLY. AND THROUGH THE LINE
TO STUDENT LEARNING AND
SAFEGUARDS THAT ARE NECESSARY
UNFORTUNATE EXPERIENCE FROM THE
REASON I'M A YOU CAN CONTRACT
WITH DISTRICTS AND LEARNING
ACTIVITIES AT SPRING. WOULD NOT
UNIFORMLY ENCOURAGING WE KNOW
THERE WAS VERY UNEVEN LEARNING
LOST SOME SCHOOLS READY TO FLIP
THE SWITCH AND WORK WELL WITH
STUDENTS AND PARENTS BUT TOO
MANY WERE STUCK IN THE
NINETEENTH AND TWENTIETH
CENTURY. AS YOU CONSIDER BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IN
ADDRESSING SCHOOLS RE OPENING
IN THE FALL WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO BALANCE
FLEXIBILITY WITH MINIMUM
SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE ALL
STUDENTS INCLUDING STUDENTS
POVERTY NEIGHBORHOODS IN
RESPONSE CAN THANK YOU OUR-
SPECIAL NEEDS. WE. HAVE ACCESS
TO BASIC EDUCATION YOU. ELECTED
LINE NUMBER ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO. AFTERNOON ERIN ASK YOU A
PUBLIC ADVOCATE THE NUMBER OF
THE EQUITY COALITION WE COMMEND
THE ASSEMBLY PRIORITIZATION OF
EDUCATION AND THE DATE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET BUT CALLING
YOU TO MAKE THE PACKAGE MORE
EQUITABLE WE APPRECIATE AFTER
MY FIRST COMMENT THE
FLEXIBILITY NOT BE ON THE BACK
OF THE POOR AND SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF THE LVF ETHICAL
CARRYOVER GUIDANCE IN THE
BUDGET. WE NEED STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ALL PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND FEDERAL
EDUCATION FUN LEARNING LOTS OF
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
EXPERIENCE BY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND WE
URGE YOU TO DISTRIBUTE THE TWO
POINT NINE BILLION OF MONEY
MARKET FUNDS ACCORDING TO EACH
LEN SHARE OF SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION BY AND- NOT TOTAL
ALTHEA FACT AND- EQUAL
TREATMENT FOR CHILDREN AND
UNEQUAL SITUATIONS IS NOT
JACKSON. WE URGE FURTHER
GUIDANCE ON HOW YOU USE THE
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS
INCLUDING EXPLICIT LANGUAGE
REQUIRING MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT- WITH STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND PLANNING LOCAL
BUDGETS AND CORPORATION AND
FAMILY AND THE DESIGN OF
WHATEVER START OF RETURNS
GLOBAL LOOK LIKE TO THINK IT'S
IMPROPER SHOULD READ OUT OF THE
EL CAP. LASTLY IN HIGHER
EDUCATION WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S REINSTATING
ELEVEN POINT FOUR MILLION OF
ONGOING FUNDING FOR FOOD PANTRY
WE RECOMMEND A FULL TIME
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
RECEIVE EMERGENCY AID AS THEY
HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT OF FEDERAL
CARES FUNDING AND WILL NOT BE
COMPARABLE STATE FUNDING FOR
THE DISASTER. RELIEF FUND THANK
YOU. NEXT LINEUP ONE HOW FORTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
JUST NOT YOUR MEMO CALLING IN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL WE ARE BOTH
THE CHANGES THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM AN ECHO OTHER COMMENTS
IN OPPOSITION WE ARE TO THE
PROGRAM TO WORK AND AS IT IS
CURRENTLY DESIGNED AROUND TO
PUBLIC AND STAKEHOLDER
PARTICIPATION AND ABOUT MAKING
PROCESS. THE GOING BACK ON THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY DECIDED
AND INDUSTRY CANNOT
SUCCESSFULLY OPERATE WITH WILL
BRING POLICY MAKING THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
THREE. YOUR MEMBERS RANT MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF I'LL BE ON A
HEALTHCARE OF YOUNG AS ONE OF
THE LARGEST PROVIDERS OF HOME
HEALTH CARE AS WELL AS RESPITE
SERVICES FOR PERSONS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WE
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT- YOUR
SUSTAINING THE PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX SUPPLEMENTAL RATES.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR
REJECTION OF THE IDEA- CUTS
ESPECIALLY AND RESPITE CARE
SERVICES WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL TO BETTER ALIGN-
FUTURE PDS RATES WITH-MINIMUM
WAGE INCREASES IN THE FUTURE
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE NUMBER
ONE FORTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARED MEMBERS CAME INTO THE
TREE WITH TECH THAT PREGNANT
WOMEN TO POSE TO THE INCLUSION
THE NET OPERATING LOSS
EXPANSION AS WELL AS THE
BUSINESS TAX IMITATION THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET PROPOSAL.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THE RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
TAX CREDIT IS PRIMARILY BASED
UPON WAGES PAID TO OUR AND THE
PROFESSIONALS ACTIVITY THAT
MUST OCCUR IN CALIFORNIA. THUS
THE ARM BE CREDIT COULD BE
CONSIDERED AS A CREDIT TO HIRE
AND KEEP EMPLOYED WELL PAID
NINETY PROFESSIONALS IN A TIME
OF RECORD HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT.
THANK YOU. CONNECTED LINE ONE
FORTY SIX. A GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENTING FIVE CLIENT
FIRST ON CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF NURSE ANESTHETISTS AND WE SO
APPRECIATE THE REJECTION OF THE
MEDICAL OPTIONAL BENEFIT
ELIMINATION THERE ARE NINE
COUNTIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO AN A STUDENT SERVICES
IN FACT GOT GO FOR TO GO
THROUGH TO WE APPRECIATE BOTH
THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
STOP PLAN FOR THAT. TECHNICALLY
ON BEHALF OF ALZHEIMER'S LA
ALZHEIMER'S ORANGE COUNTY ALL
CHRISTINE DIEGO AND CONSUMER
ADVOCATES RCMP REFORM WITCHER
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE ELDERLY WE SO APPRECIATE
THE REJECTION OF THE
ELIMINATION OF BOTH HE SEA
BASS AT THE END OF THAT THE-
PROGRAM THAT ARE CRITICAL
PROGRAMS ARE COST SAVINGS AND
IT KEEPS THERE ARE VERY
VULNERABLE SENIORS AND THEIR
HOMES THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU YOUR STOP THE
SENATE AND THEIR STOCK IT WE
APPRECIATE IT WE HELP YOU HOLD
STRONG WITH THE GOVERNOR AND AS
TO GO SHE. XIN THANK YOU AND
HAVE A GOOD DAY. NEXT IN LINE
THE ONE FOR FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS SHORT
MUHAMMAD ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE OPPOSE THE FAMILY LEAVE
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD LEAD- THAT
WOULD IMPOSE A SIGNIFICANT
BURDEN ON SMALL EMPLOYERS BY
REQUIRING A TWELVE WEEK LEAVE
OF ABSENCE ON EMPLOYERS WITH
ONLY ONE EMPLOYEE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ALREADY EXTENDED
LEADS TO DRESS CODE NINETEEN
AND THIS PROPOSAL IS A POLICY
ISSUE THAT SHOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED AS PART OF THE
BUDGET. AND WITH THAT WE OPPOSE
THAT THAT PORTION OF THE FAMILY
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. NEGATIVE
LINE ONE FIFTY ONE. HI KATIE
HARDENING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
BUDGET PLAN ESPECIALLY
REJECTING THE 10% CUT THAT
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
AND YOU GET THAT AND FUNDING
FOR YOU FORMULA WE ALSO PUT A
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
TEMPORARILY SUSPEND THAT NET
OPERATING LOSS AND OTHER TAX
CREDITS. IN THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REQUIRING COUNTY
ACCURATELY CALCULATE THAT THE
RAPPER SCHOOL THANK YOU. NEXT
IN LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A NEW WEB
SLINGING CALLING FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THAT LEGISLATOR
VERSION OF THE BUDGET AND
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
RECOGNITION THAT CUTS TO ANY
SERVICES THAT SUPPORT PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. ARE CRIPPLING SO
RECOGNIZE AND APPRECIATE.
THE
CHAIR MEMBERS WILL CALL RIGHT
HELP CLEAN MANY FACTORS IN
TECHNOLOGY SAYS THE ASIAN
PERSONALLY WANT TO THAN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR JOINT
AGREEMENT AND REJECTING THE K.
TO TWELVE FEET HE- CUTS IN THE
ELIMINATION TO THEIR CONTINUE
WITH APPROPRIATIONS. WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHT ACT THE
REQUIREMENT TO PROVIDE TWELVE
WEEKS OF LEAVE AN INCLUSION OF
A NEW PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
WILL BE A MANAGEABLE AND COSTLY
TO SMALL MANUFACTURERS
ESPECIALLY DURING THE TIME OF
RECOVERY WE BELIEVE THAT THE
POLICY DISCUSSION AT OTHER
BILLS ARE CURRENTLY MOVING
THROUGH THAT THEN YOU SUGGEST.
AND WE WERE REQUESTED THIS
DISCUSSION TO BE HAD IN THAT
CAPACITY AND REMOVED FROM THE
BUDGET DISCUSSION. FINALLY WE
ALSO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
THREE YEAR SUSPENSION AT THE
NET OPERATING LOSS DEDUCTION
AND THE FIVE MILLION DOLLAR CAP
ON THE TRACK CREDIT UTILIZATION
WE JOIN MANY OF YOUR COLLEAGUES
AND ASKING YOU TO RECONSIDER
THIS PROPOSAL I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND YOU THAT OUR ABILITY TO
SUCCESSFULLY RECOVER AND CALM
AND COMBAT. THE CO THAT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS CONNECTED
TO PROGRAMS LIKE THE STATE'S
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT TAX
CREDIT THAT IT CAPTURED UNDER.
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU. NEXT
NUMBER. ONE HUNDRED SIXTY. YES
SIR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN TO DRIVING
REPRESENTING AND THAT I'D BE-
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE PAID
FAMILY LEAVE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WE THINK THIS IS A
SPECIALLY- DIFFICULT AND COSTLY
TO- SMALL BUSINESSES THAT ARE
JUST RECOVERING- ON BEHALF OF
MAXIM HEALTHCARE WE- SUPPORT.
THE COMMITTEES- EFFORT TO
REMOVE OR TO SUPPORT THE-
RESPITE HEY AND ALSO- THE PROP
FIFTY SIX FUNDING FOR HOME
HEALTH. CARE RATES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEGATIVE LINE NUMBER
ONE SIXTY ONE. AGAIN MY NUMBER
ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS DEANNA STILL
WHILE CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER IN
AUBURN CALIFORNIA I WORK WITH
THE DIVISION OF ADULT PRO
OPERATIONS AND THE PAROLE
OUTPATIENT CLINIC. WE ARE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CLINIC
DESIGNED TO ASSIST PAROLEES
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS AND
TRANSITIONING SUCCESSFULLY IN
THE COMMUNITY. THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED TO ELIMINATE OUR
SERVICES ON THE PREMISE THAT
THE POORLY POPULATION HAD
ACCESS TO COUNTY MEDICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH CARE. ARE
MENTALLY ILL GROWING POPULATION
SUFFERS FROM COMPLEX ISSUES
INCLUDING PROPENSITY FOR
VIOLENCE CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
ELIMINATING OUR SERVICES WOULD
ONLY INCREASE CRIME AND
HOMELESSNESS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE. COUNTY CLINICS DO NOT
HAVE ADEQUATE TRAINING OR
RESOURCES TO MANAGE AND TREAT
THE PROLES. RELATION FOR ALWAYS
ARE MOST OFTEN DENIED COMMUNITY
BASED CLINICS AND HOSPITALS TO
THE CONCERN OF HER SAFETY AND
STAFF AND LACK OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE. TO
LEGISLATIVELY FINAL OUR WORK TO
LOCAL HEALTH CLINICS DOES NOT
SPEAK TO THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
OUR CLIENTS INTO THE HANDS ON
CARE WE PROVIDE WHICH
ULTIMATELY LEADS. TO A MORE IN
SHORT THICK THAT'S GREAT THE
WORK WE DO WILL NOT BE DONE BY
OUTSIDE CLINICS. ELIMINATING
OUR PROGRAM WILL COMPOUND IN
ALREADY GROWING COMMUNITY
BECAUSE AFTER OF HOMELESSNESS
AND CRIME THE COUNTY JAIL
POPULATION WILL INCREASE. ALL
OF THIS WILL INCREASE AND
THAT'S CRIME RATES WILL LIKELY
BEGIN TO INCREASE. THE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA DESERVE TO LIVE
STATE AND FULFILLING LIVES THAT
ARE NOT IN JEOPARDY OF
INCREASED CRIME RATE AND
POTENTIAL DEATH. UNIQUE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT WE PROVIDE IS
ALREADY HELPING OUR COMMUNITIES
AND REMOVING ARTHUR WITH THIS
COULD CAUSE GREATER LONG TERM
CONCERN. PLEASE THE PARK
SERVICE IS INTACT SO WE CAN
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF
HOMELESSNESS. CHRONIC MENTAL
ILLNESS REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND
ASSIST WITH COMMUNITY
INTEGRATION. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NEXT DEADLINE NUMBER.
FORTY NINE. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS LEE IS THE
RETURN OF THE CALIPHATE CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED OF THE PROPOSED CAP
AND TRADE LANGUAGE THE BUDGET
WITHOUT ANY POLICY THAT HE BY
THE LEGISLATURE'S COMMITTEES
AND DISCUSS IN A PUBLIC FORUM
FOR THE FIRST DAY OF MERE DAYS
FROM BUILDING ON THE BUDGET.
PROPOSAL RESULT IN SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASES IN THE COST OF GAS
ENERGY CALIFORNIA MAKE GOOD
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT
CORRESPONDING EMISSIONS
REDUCTION YOU RESPECT THE FACT
THE GROUPS THAT TRADITIONALLY
RELIED UPON YOU YOU'RE A
FUNDING WILL BE IMPACTED THIS
YEAR WHICH INCLUDE MANY OF OUR
CALTRAIN REMEMBER THE PARTNER.
HOWEVER THEY ALSO UNDERSTAND
TEND TO BE INCREASED URIC
BUDGET FUNDING BY PUTTING MORE
ON THE BACK OF ALREADY
STRUGGLING CALIFORNIA I WOULD
DO FOR YOU MISSION AND IN DOING
SO WAITING PUBLIC NODDED NOTICE
COMMENT ECONOMIC IMPACT NOW
ONLINE. WORKING TO AN ATTACK ON
CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK BY PART
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD ENACTED AFTER MUCH HARD
WORK SMALL PARTY EXACTLY BY MY
COLLEAGUE BEGINNING AT RISK
TODAY'S GOOGLE ABOUT THE LIKELY
EVEN RESULT IN YOU WILL REVENUE
AS SUCH THE PROPOSAL SHOULD BE
REJECTED FROM. THE BUDGET THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT IN LINE
NUMBER. ONE THIRTY EIGHT. HE
AGAIN MY NO ONE TO HIDE THIS
YEAH THE BAD RAP CASTING
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
WITH THE PAROLE OUT PATIENT
CLINIC. WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
ADULTS PEARL OPERATION. I WON I
HOPE FOR THE- CLOSER UP THE
PEARL OUTPATIENT CLINIC. BASED
ON THE FACT THAT WE PROVIDE
VERY UNIQUE SERVICES TO A VERY
UNIQUE POPULATION IT'S VERY
HARD TO REPLICATE. AND OUR
POPULATION CONTACT VERY
DISENFRANCHISED AND- WHAT LOSS
OF MOTIVATION LOCK UP WHOLE AND
THAT- DIFFICULTIES. PLANNING
FOR THE FUTURE WE AT HELP THEM
STABILIZE. AND FIND- OTHER WAYS
TO COPE WHICH ARE NOT ARE
HANDLED EFFECTIVELY BY PEOPLE
WHO DID NOT KNOW THAT
BACKGROUND BECAUSE OF THE
CRIMINAL AND VIOLENT BACKGROUND
THAT THEY HAD BECAUSE OF THE
LABELS ASSOCIATED THE STIGMA
ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR- CRIMES
FACT ABOUT A PROBLEM. A THANK
YOU HELLO I RESPECTFULLY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
RESPECTFULLY CONSIDER THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND HOW DO NEED OUR
PROGRAM IS HOW UNIQUE OUR
HISTORY AND TRAINING HAS BEEN.
FIELD. NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE SIXTY SIX. GO AHEAD LOW
SIXTIES YES YES HI MY NAME IS
PATRICIA TOWARDS BETTER KNOWN
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE- IN ON BEHALF OF OUR
OUR CHILDREN THIRTY BUSINESSES
IN LOS ANGELES AND FOURTEEN
HUNDRED MEMBERS WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES.
BUSINESSES EXPAND PAID FAMILY
LEAVE BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY
MOTHERS ARE COMPLETELY SHUT
DOWN NOT GENERATING THE LEVEL
OF REVENUES RECALL THE
NINETEEN- THE CREDIT THE
PANDEMIC CAPTURED AND ECONOMIC
CRISIS AND SESSION AND MANY OF
THE BUSINESS OR JUST TRYING TO
SURVIVE THE APPLICATION TO.
EVEN SMALLBUSINESSES THE VERY-
TROUBLING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ALREADY HAD HAD A
LEAGUE OF ABSENCE REQUIREMENTS-
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
PARTY TAKING CARE OF AND IT IS
AN UNDUE BURDEN ON SMALL
BUSINESSES. I ALSO WANT THE AND
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THE- OF
THE LANGUAGE ON. THE COMMENT
THAT HAD BEEN MADE ON THAT CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THOSE WITH THAT LANGUAGE. NEXT
CALL THAT A LINE ONE FIFTY
THREE. NOTHING YEAH I WENT AND
BOUGHT A HOT NAKED AND PORT
NUMBER OF GENDER CATHOLIC
BALLET I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF HEALTH FOR ALL SENIORS OUR
LIVES ON THE LINE AND THIS
MATTER IT'S URGENT UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE ARE EXCLUDED AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL AND WE NEED OUR
STATE TO TAKE TANGIBLE STEPS
LIKE HEALTH FOR ALL SENIORS THE
STATE THAT MANY CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF STATUS
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS ARE
ESSENTIAL AND HELP THEMSELVES
ON THE FRONT NINE SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF TOUCH PANDEMIC FOR
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD. FROM OUR FARM LAND FOR
WHERE THE SUPERMARKETS REST
EVERYTHING HI IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM THE POINT. IN
ADDITION WE SUPPORT FOR THE
TRANS ONE INEQUITIES. TRYING
PEOPLE HAVE A HISTORY OF BEING
NEGLECTED AND EXCLUDED WITHIN
OUR INSTITUTIONS. THERE IS A
NEED FOR SPECIFIC FUNDING FOR
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY. AND THAT
IS WHAT IS NEEDED TO THE CRAFT
THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS. THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WILL THAT ALIGN ONE
SIXTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
STEPHANIE GOLDEN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THE SPEECH AND
PRACTITIONERS OCCASION WE
DEEPLY APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM STRONG
WORK FIRST PROGRAM CREATED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SELECT ONE
MILLION WORKERS WITH A LIVING
WAGE CAREER THREE INNOVATIVE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS. DESIGNED
TO OFFER THE INDUSTRY'S MOST
ADVANCED TECHNICAL SKILLS
TRAINING THE PROPOSAL TO
MAINTAIN STRONG WORK FOR
FUNDING AT THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TWENTY LEVELS WILL OUR
COLLEGES TO CONTINUE TRAINING
WORKERS AT A TIME WHEN
UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT A RECORD
HIGH AND HE DID NOT. THANK YOU.
NEXT OF MIND ONE SIXTY EIGHT.
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MISSY UP I'M AN LCSW
WITH PAROLE OUTPATIENT CLINIC I
AM SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF PRO
AGENT CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
POLICE AND THE COMMUNITY IS AT
THE TIME INCLUDING MID CITY
SOUTH LOS ANGELES SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CONTENT LONG BEACH AN
ANIMAL VALLEY IT'S CRUCIAL THAT
BEAUTY REMAIN INTACT COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH CLINICS ARE NOT
EQUIPPED TO MAKING SAFETY OF
THEIR SEVEN OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ACCESSING THEIR
SERVICES. HAVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND MENTAL HEALTH
UNDER THE SAME ROOF IN SHORT%
FOR A SPECIAL CONDITIONS OF
PAROLE WHICH ARE PUT IN PLACE
TO PREVENT CONTINUED CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY THIS IN HOUSE SERVICES
STREAMLINED OUR RESPONSIBILITY
EFFICIENTLY TO PROVIDE MENTALLY
ILL PAROLEES AND PROTECT
COMMUNITY PLEASE RECONSIDER THE
CLOSURE QC. THANK YOU. NEXT IN
LINE. ONE SEVENTY ONE. MY NAME
IS JUSTIN WEBER A MECHANICAL
SOCIAL WORKER WITH FOR ALL
OUTPATIENT CLINIC I'VE BEEN A
STATE EMPLOYEE FOR FOURTEEN
YEARS CLOSER PROGRAM WILL HAVE
AT FIRST NEGATIVE EFFECTS ON
THE CLIENTS AND COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE PSE PROVIDES ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY. APPEAR SEQUENCES
COME ON POLITICAL STORY FROM
STATE HOSPITALS AND PRISONS
PROVIDING SPECIALIZED TRAINING
COMPASSIONATE CARE TO PRO IS
ATTEMPTING TO REINTEGRATE INTO
SOCIETY WE ARE NOT A
DUPLICATION OF SERVICES WE
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT AND COMMUNITY
RISK ASSESSMENT TO EACH PATIENT
DURING THE CLINICAL CONTACT.
PSE PROVIDES PROMPT MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO SINCE THE
POPULATIONS. CLOSING US WILL
NOT LET ALLOW PATIENTS TO BE
SEEN AT COMMUNITY CLINICS.
THESE ARE PATIENTS THAT HAVE
SPECIALIZED NEEDS AND NEED CARE
FROM BOTH SPECIALIZED PROVIDERS
THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE ONE
SEVENTY THAT'S ONE SEVEN ZERO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR LEE AT BARUCH
ON BEHALF OF MISSION
NEIGHBORHOOD CENTERS I HIGHLY
RESPECTED ORGANIZATION BASED
OUT OF SAN FRANCISCO THAT
PROVIDES COMPREHENSIVE CHILD
DEVELOPMENT THERE'S A LOW
INCOME FAMILY. WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE MILLION ET INFRASTRUCTURE
FINE THAT IF THE CODE COULD BE
ELIMINATED PLEASE BENEFACTOR
SHOVEL READY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS EVEN FOR STRUCTURE
FUND OUR EXPANSION TO COMPLETE
SHOVEL READY CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS AND MAKE MODEST
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
NECESSARY TO FACE WILL BE OPEN
EXISTING SITES. AND COMPLIANCE
WITH THE- CURRENTLY THERE IS
NOT ENOUGH. CARE NOT CHILDREN
WITH THE NEW THAT THE PROJECT
CAN LOOK. AND THEN FRANCISCO
ALONE THE F. BECAUSE OF THESE
NEW AN- THERE WILL BE FOR
THOUSAND FEWER NOW. CHILDREN
COMPARED TO THE NUMBER OF THE
WITH THE FACT THAT I CHILD CARE
PRIOR TO BE AT THAT. PANDEMIC
EXAM INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING IS
NOT PRESERVED PARENTS WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO FIND CHILDCARE WHICH
WILL MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO GO BACK TO WORK AND HELP
GROW THE ECONOMY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION ON
THE COMPARTMENTS FOR. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE SEVENTY SIX. THANK
YOU DON CAP KEY WITH MCCUE
CAPTAIN DISSOCIATES FIRST ON
THE HALF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S DECISION TO DEFER
ACTION ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL
GOVERNMENTS AND FISCAL REFORM
WE LOOK FORWARD TO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE ISSUE IN THE
WEEKS TO COME ADDITIONALLY ON
BEHALF CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION
CENTER IN CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RESOURCE ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
EFFORT TO MITIGATE THE CUTS TO
CHILDREN FAMILIES TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE.
INCLUDING FOR FOSTER YOU AND
WITHIN THE BLACK INFANT HEALTH
PROGRAM IN LNE WITH COMMENTS
MADE BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
OUGHT TO REVISIT THE NICOTINE
BEEPING TAX INCREASE WE URGE
ANY SUCH FUNDING TO BE DIRECTED
TO FIRST FIVE CONSISTENT WITH
pCHILDREN FAMILIES. AND FINALLY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR ADULT EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIA DOLE EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT OF AND MAINTAINING
CURRENT FUNDING. FOR ADULT
EDUCATION THANK YOU. NECK BUT
MINE. ONE SEVEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AMOS FIFTEEN STEVEN
MORE CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
WITH THE PEARL OUTPATIENT
CLINIC I'D LIKE TO OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE PAROLE
OUTPATIENT CLINIC PROGRAM ROUTE
THE RATIONALE FOR CUTTING THE
PROGRAM WAS THE ROLE YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE TO CAL CAN USE THAT
FOR COUNTY. GETTING INVOLVED A
COLUMN STAYING AND ROLLED IN
CAN BE A COMP PROCESS INVOLVING
ONLY ON THE PHONE NAVIGATION
AVOIDS VOICE MAIL SYSTEM AND
SOMETIMES VISITS TO COUNTY
SOCIAL SERVICE OFFICES.
PROBABLY IS WITH LOW DISORDERS
AND SOMETIMES LEARNING
DISABILITIES ARE OFTEN. WILLING
TO GET THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
ROLL OUT PATIENT CLINICS SOCIAL
WORKERS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS. THE
ALLMAN LEGAL PROLIANT BECAUSE
WE'RE IN THE OFFICES THE PROLIX
AUTOMATICALLY FEELS WHEN THEY
COME TO THE OFFICE REGARDLESS
OF MEDI CAL STATUS. ALSO WERE
MUCH BETTER IF YOU CLICK AND
COUNTY CLINICS TO DEAL WITH
MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE WITH
ONGOING BEHAVIOR PROBLEMS. THAT
CAN HELP PREVENT COSTLY. COSTLY
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALIZATION.
YOU TO RETAIN THE PAROLE
OUTPATIENT CLINIC CAPTAIN THEIR
CURRENT. FORM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT IN LINE. ONE EIGHTY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE COLD
WAR WOMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WITH THE DOWNTURN OF THE
ECONOMY AND NUMBER COUNTY
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE THE MOST
VULNERABLE TROOPS REALIGNMENT
INCLUDING PUBLIC. ARE IN
JEOPARDY WE ARE VERY
APPRECIATIVE AND SUPPORTIVE OF
THE ONE BILLION IN REALIGNMENT
BACKFILL INCLUDED IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET. THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE ONE SEVENTEEN.
THAT WAS ONE A GOLD RING ON
BEHALF OF THE OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT YOUR
INFECTION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BECAUSE THE LIMITATION OF
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY AS AN
OPTIONAL MEDI CAL BENEFITS
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST PLAY
CRITICAL ROLE IN THE DELIVERY
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA AND
ELIMINATING THE BENEFIT WOULD
NEGATIVELY IN DRASTICALLY IN
FACT THE DOC ABOUT LEADERS IN
CALIFORNIA. MANY PROVIDE EVERY
BECAUSE THE NINETEEN OR NOW BE
CONDITION AND IN NEED OF ALL
LEVELS OF REHABILITATION
SERVICES INCLUDING OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY HEALTH RESTORETHEIR
EMPLOYMENT CAPACITY IN DAILY
LIVING SKILLS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS ISSUE IN
STRONG SUPPOR YOUR OBJECTION
AND AGAIN GOVERNOR'S THE PUT
THE LIMITATION. OF OCCUPATIONAL
AND I PROGRAM GET. NEXT TO ONE
A FOUR. HONORABLE MEMBERS I'M
KARIM JAN CEO FAMILY BRIDGES
THAT RUNS TO LARGE FEEDBACK
CENTER SERVING ASIAN IMMIGRANTS
AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF DOUBT
A SERVICE I'D LIKE TO THANK AND
APPLAUD YOU FOR COMMITTING TO
PROTECT SERVICES FOR FRAIL
REJECTING THE ELIMINATION OF
THE BATH AN MXF P. AND
THEREFORE PRESERVING THEIR
LIFELINE FOR OVER FORTY
THOUSAND ELDERLY AND ADULTS
WITH DISABILITIES. ARE ELDERLY
TYPICALLY HAVE LESS OF A VOICE
TO FIGHT FOR THEIR LIVES AND
YOU HAVE TO LISTEN TO AND
ANSWERED THEIR CLEVELAND
PRAYERS THEY WILL NOT FORGET
THAT YOU HAVE STOOD. UP FOR
THEM THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
THE FINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ROBERT
SPIEGEL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION AND WE
TO WORK HOPING TO CAPTURE VOCAL
INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET PLAN
ULTIMATELY WE BELIEVE THAT THE
PROPOSAL WILL RAISE COSTS AND
CALIFORNIANS AND COMPLIANCE
COSTS AN INDUSTRY TO TIME WAY
IN FINANCIAL AND ECONOMIC
CERTAINTY IS VERY MUCH NEEDED.
SECONDLY WE ARE ALSO OPPOSING
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
TAKE MONEY FROM THE
AGRICULTURAL FUND FOR
PROPOSITION TWELVE
IMPLEMENTATION THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE ONE NINETY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS VERY
DIRTY ON BEHALF OF HE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT
PROVIDERS OF SERVICES ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES JUST
WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY FOR-
COMING TO AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
SENATE ON A BUDGET PROPOSAL
THAT KEEPS THE CUTS AWAY FROM
VULNERABLE- CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING THOSE WHO
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
URGE YOU TO STRONGLY HOLD THE
LINE IN THE FINAL NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE GOVERNOR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NEXT DEADLINE. ONE TWO.
HELLO MY NAME IS SHOULD HAVE
ANY MIDDLE INITIAL
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY- WE WORK WHICH
COMMUNITIES- A LOT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND ROLE IN A LOT
CALIFORNIA I'M IN THE SHOW
ABOUT ANYTHING FROM OPTION
VALLEY I'M CALLING IN TWO VOICE
SUPPORT NEED FUNDING FUNDING
STOPPING BASIC FOR DRINKING
WATER FIND IN ADDITION THE
FUNDING ALLOCATED. TODAY
PROGRAM WALK FROM THE POLLUTION
CONTROL FUNDS DOES NEED BE A
DEDICATED TO ACT PRIORITY
WITHIN THE COMPANY. BACK IN A
COUPLE TO ATTEND OVER. THE PATH
COUPLE YEARS ADDITIONALLY. LIKE
I'M JUST GOING TO GREAT NEED A
CHAT AND THEY REVENUE FOR THE
STATE CLIMB AND ENERGY.
PROGRAMS OTHER THAN THE TEACHER
UP WHICH HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
FALSE AND COOL PER. MECHANISM
TO FIND THE IMPORTANT PRO IN
THE STATE CLIMATE WORK. OUT
LAST. WE REALLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE BACK BUT WHEN I OF MY
FIVE THREE. AND I COULD EVEN
STATE BACK IN BACK MEDIA TAPE
AND THE DAY. AND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MUST RESOURCES. BY
BACK TO BUT HEALTH DISPARITIES.
THANK YOU. ACCESS LINE ONE
NINETY. THIS IS CATHERINE WITH
HERE QUOTE CAL. I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE BUDGET FOR
REGARDING CALLIE A THE RESOURCE
AGENT YOUR OFTEN ENSURE THAT
HEALTH AND ARE HEALTH AND
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ARE
MAINTAINED IN A VERY DIFFICULT
BUDGET YEAR- FOR THE SAKE OF
TIME I'M NOT GOING TO GO INTO
DETAIL ABOUT ALL OF THAT WE
LIKE BUT I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THE
PROPOSAL TO REVIEW THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM STRUCTURE AT THIS
TIME IT IS IMPORTANT AND
VALUABLE THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAM. IS A UNIQUE PROGRAM
WE'RE- CURRENTLY- EXPERIENCING
AN UNUSUAL ECONOMIC TIME AND WE
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED BEING AND
NECESSARY DEMAND TO REDUCE
CLIMATE CHANGE WHILE WE
SIMULTANEOUSLY ENSURE THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING SUFFICIENT
FUNDS TO- PREPARE FOR- THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE SO
AGAIN WE SUPPORT THAT PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE ONE
FORTY SEVEN. HI THIS IS-
MICROBES IN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE GLASS PACKAGING AND WE-
SUPPORT- THE COMMENTS MADE BY
INCOME AND COULD BURNISH
SOMEONE FONG ON A CAP AND
TRADE- ISSUE AND- WE SHOULD
WOULD ONLY ADD THAT THERE'S
NOTHING IN A CREATING MAKING IN
THE BUDGET PROCESS THAT WILL
IMPROVE THE STATE'S BUDGET
SITUATION OR IMPROVE THE BUDGET
THAT FOR THE WORD THE G. G. R.
F. ON IT JUST CREATES. GOING TO
CREATE A MOVIE MAKING THAT WILL
HAVE LONG TERM COSTS
IMPLICATIONS ON ON THE ENTITIES
AND HAVE NO IMPACT ON YOUR
CURRENT BUDGET DISCUSSIONS
PROBABLY JUST TAKE IT OUT OF
THE BUDGET PROCESS TO DO THIS
FROM THE POLICY. GONE THANKS.
MAC DEADLINE FIFTY FOUR.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS BRIAN LITTLE WITH CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION I'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION TO THE BUDGET
TRAIER BILL CONCERNING- NEW
FAMILY MEDICAL LEAVE- TO BE
ANDATED SIMILAR TO WHAT'S
REQUIRED UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
FAMILY RIGHT TO ACT ON THIS
WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT EXPENSIVE
NEW BURDEN FOR VERY SMALL FARM
EMPLOYERS IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW TO RECOVER
FROM THE ECONOMIC SHOCK OF CODE
NINETEEN. THIS IS THE SORT OF A
PROPOSAL THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED IN THE NORMAL POLICY
PROCESS IN FACT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE REJECTED A SIMILAR
PROPOSAL AS RECENTLY TWENTY
NINETEEN AS A RESULT WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE TO A
ONE. HI THIS IS GAIL DEL HANNAH
WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION- TODAY I AM CALLING
IN TO ASK TO ALIGN OUR OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE EXPRESSED
BY THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. OPPOSING THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT TO SPEND
THE NET OPERATING LOSS
DEDUCTION AND THE LIMIT
UTILIZING. IS THE FACT THAT
SENATOR THE END CREDITS.
ADDITIONALLY WE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE MADE BY-
LAUREN HEY JACK THE ROOTS
REPRESENTING MANY AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATION- BY OPPOSING THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BY A BOARD SPENDING PROPOSAL
THAT WOULD INCREASE FEES. FOR
NEW POSITION FOR THE WATER
REPELLENCY PROGRAM THE ACCURATE
AND TIMELY ASSESSMENT AND
CALIFORNIA'S SURFACE WATER
QUALITY PROGRAM AND THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM. WE ARE
NOT OPPOSED TO THE PROGRAM WE
ARE JUST SUPPOSED TO THE
FUNDING- THE WAY THEY PROPOSED
TO FUND THE PROGRAM- BY RAISING
PLEASE ON A- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT DEADLINE TWO HUNDRED.
I'M YES HELLO. MY NAME IS
MARLIN MIGT YELL AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HE IS THE
ARE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND- I'M WOULD LIKE
YOU KNOW TO JUST EIGHTY BACK
AND REITERATE ON THE COMMENT
THAT YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD AND
JUST ESSENTIALLY MY MAIN. POINT
IS THAT WE ARE ESSENTIALLY A
BRIDGE THE BRIDGE THAT. YOU
KNOW IT'S LINKING BETWEEN THE
INSTITUTION AND THE COMMUNITY
AND IF THIS BRIDGE JUST BROKE
AND- ESSENTIALLY WHAT WILL BE
AS EVERYBODY FALLING INTO THE
STREET. THE HOSPITAL. AND BACK
INTO CUSTODY AND I KNOW
EVERYBODY HAS EXPLAINED YOU
KNOW WHO WE ARE- I GIVE ME WHO
WE SAW HER THE POPULATION WE
SERVE HER EXPERIENCE VIOLENT
OFFENDER SEX OFFENDER AND
PEOPLE OF. SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ISSUES. AND OTHERWISE HAVE MANY
HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME WITHOUT THE
SOCIAL SKILLS THE FILLED NEEDED.
IN A GREAT SUCCESSFULLY. AND AS
YOU FELT THE WE ARE THAT BRIDGE
THAT HELL PEOPLE DO THAT THE
BILL WITHOUT IT I AM VERY
CONCERNED WITH THE ELIMINATION
OF THE PEARL OUTPATIENT CLINIC
AS NOT ONLY WHO WE SERVE BUT
ACTUALLY WHAT WE DO FOR THEM.
AND THE LACK OF SERVICES THAT
MAY BE AVAILABLE WITH OUR THAT
ARE NOT THE THERMOS THAT WILL
NOT BE AVAILABLE FOR NOT THERE
FOR THEM I REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOU TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION.
YOU KNOW WHO WE ARE. AND WHAT
WE DAM. AND THANK YOU VERY TIME.
NEXT DEADLINE TO FOR. YES I'M A
HELLO GO AHEAD YES I'M ARE
ALSO- LCSW WITH THE BILL A- AND
WOODLAND- PO SEE CLINICS AND
JUST TO TAKE THE BAG BACK ON
WHAT WAS SAID- WE ARE BRIDGES
FROM THE PRISONS TO THE
COMMUNITY AND- WORK WITH THE
DIFFICULT MENTALLY ILL
POPULATION LIFERS AND SEX
OFFENDERS AND IT WOULD HELP
SAVE MONEY TO HELP THEM REMAIN
IN THE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NEXT DEADLINE TABLE
TO. THANK YOU ADRIN SHELTON
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES WE
REPRESENT A HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
NONPROFIT THIRTY MORE THAN HALF
A MILLION PEOPLE DOUBLE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE. THE PANDEMIC'S
IMPACT ON MENTAL HEALTH IS
UNPRECEDENTED AND DEVASTATING
YOU WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
CALIFORNIA MUST RESOLVE TO
PROTECT HERE HEALTH SAFETY NET
STAGGERING DECLINES REALIGNMENT
REVENUE COUPLED WITH THE
DRAMATIC RISE IN THE NEED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THREATEN
TO COLLAPSE OUR SYSTEM WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
REALIGNMENT BACKFILL PROPOSAL
INCLUDED OF NINETEEN NINETY ONE
AND TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT
TO AVOID GREATER COST BOTH
DOLLARS. AND HUMAN LIVES
ALLIANCE MEMBERORGANIZATIONS
ON THE FRONT LINES OF
SUPPORTING CHILDREN YOUTH AND
FAMILIES WHO WALKS ABOUT BASIC
SUPPORT WE'RE LOOKING AT
DRAMATIC PROGRAM AND STOCKING
CUTBACKS AND PERMANENT DAMAGE
TO THE ESSENTIAL SAFETY NET FOR
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES WITHOUT. THAT'S
CRITICAL SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT IN LINE TO AFFECT. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS A MODEL AND MARTINEZ WITH
THE IMPERIAL IRRIGATION
DISTRICT WE DELIVER POWER
BEFORE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN RIVERSIDE
AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES AND
WATER- JAFFA MILLION ACRES OF
AG LAND. THANKYOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE BUDGET AND
PROTECTING THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES A SPECIFICALLY WE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT FUNDING
FOR THE SALTON SEA AND THE
RIVER THE FALCONS HE OUR WATER
LEVEL IS DECLINING DUE TO WIRE
TRANSFER AGREEMENT TO UP THE
STATE THEY WITHIN FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION I WATER ALLOCATION
FROM THE COLORADO RIVER AND
HELP BRING WATER TO URBAN
CENTERS- THIS IS IMPACTING OUR
PUBLIC KHALKHIN AREA DIDN'T.
EXPOSURE HAS CRITICAL FOR BIRDS
ON PACIFIC FLYWAY INTEGRATED
WHY QUALITY OF THE CALL THE
MASSIVE FISH DIE IN ORDER THAT
HAVE REACHED OUT LATE THE NEW
RIVER DIRECTLY INTO THE TALKING
TO YOU HIGHLY POLLUTED OVER
WITH CO IN NINETY THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE ALREADY
MULTI BURDENS INCLUDING HADN'T
AMONG THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT
AND POVERTY RATE IN THE STATE
THEREFORE WE SUPPORT THE
FUNDING THAT RECOGNIZES THE
STATE OBLIGATION ADDRESS ONE OF
THE MOST PRESSING.
ENVIRONMENTAL CHALLENGES AND
ONE OF THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
AREAS IN THE STATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR WORK. NEXT
TO. YOU'RE NOT SURE REPORT ON
THE QUOTE THIS ORDER HOUSING
I'M QUITE RIGHT SO I CLARITY
ABOUT OKAY FIRST BOOK AND THEIR
OUTLOOK LOOK OKAY EXACTLY BUT
IT FINALIZED WE STRONGLY
OPPOSED. YEAH WE ARE
CALIFORNIANS THERE'S ONE
ILLUSTRATIONS PROPOSED BILL NOT
REALLY TALKING MORE THAN ONE
PEOPLE AGUIAR-CURRY. IN WE WERE
OF. NINE TO FIVE THOUSAND BOB
I'M BEHALF OF YOU PAGE AND THE
CAL OF WHAT ANGELES I ALSO TO
THANK YOU AND DOCTOR INCLUDE
THREE FIFTY MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND VENDETTA FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE IN CORONA BY REALLY
FUN WITH THE POOREST LOCAL ACT
AQUAMAN. HOW MANY PEOPLE WITH
OF THAT OKAY WE WHAT WE USED TO
THE PHONE WHAT PEOPLE LIVING
THE COMING OUT AND WE URGE OF
QUESTION THE FUNDING. FOR THE
COSTS HOW CREATED THROUGH THE.
THE THANK YOU I. NEXT ONE FIFTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE A
MEMBERS MY NAME IS FRANCESCA
FELLOWS ARE LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER WITH THE PAROLE
OUTPATIENT CLINIC TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF ADULT AND CO
OPERATION IN SAN DIEGO ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUES NINE.
WE AFER YOU OPPOSED THE
ELIMINATION OF THE PRO
OUTPATIENT PROGRAM A CLINIC
PROGRAM ELIMINATION WILL ONLY
LEAD TO A LESS RESOURCES FOR A
PRO LEAGUE MENTAL HEALTH AND
DECOMPENSATION INCREASE
HOMELESSNESS POVERTY ANY
INCREASE IN CRIME. IN ADDITION
IT WILL LEAD TO MAJOR OVER
BURDENING OF OUR PUBLIC
SERVICES. LOCAL JAILS IN
HOSPITAL. AB COOPERATION CLINIC
THE PROGRAM CAN TAKE MUCH MORE
MONEY THAN THE ALTERNATIVE
EVERY IN CART WE RE ANCHOR
CARBURETION AND CRIME THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION NEXT
DEADLINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE. ONE
EIGHTY FIVE GO HEAD. OVER THE
NEXT ONE THAT PLANE TO THREE.
MR KERRY MEMBERS WILL BE THE
LEASH ON BEHALF OF THE TEN
PARKING VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THEM VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE FIFTY
MILLION AND AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL FUNDING WHICH WILL HELP
US CONTINUE IMPLEMENTING KEY
AIR QUALITY PROGRAMS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THANK NEXT IN
LINE TO ELEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
JAY SEEGER SAKE AND I HAVE
WORKED FOR THE PRO OUTPATIENT
CLINIC IN COMPTON CALIFORNIA
FOR TWENTY YEARS WE SET ALONG
SIDE PRO AGENTS TO PROVIDE AND
MEDIA SPECIALIZED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO MENTALLY ILL PRO
LEAST INCLUDING LINKAGE I
NEEDED RESOURCES- PSYCHIATRIC
MEDICATION WE HAVE A UNIQUE
FRIENDS AND TRAINING THAT THE
COUNTY DOES NOT POSSESS AND
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO PROVIDE. WE
SERVE THE NEEDS OF A VERY
UNIQUE SPECIALIZED POPULATION
THAT LEFT UNTREATED WILL
INCREASE CRIME IN OUR
COMMUNITIES JEFF WEAVING
PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES IN PLACE
WILL BE DEVASTATING AN
OVERWHELMING TO OUR DOCTORS AND
OUR POPULATION PLEASE DO NOT
VOTE TO INCREASE CRIME AND
UNTREATED MENTAL ILLNESS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES LOW TO KEEP THAT
PEARL OUTPATIENT CLINIC OPEN
AND OPPOSE CUTS. TO OUR CLINIC
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE TO
TWELVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARK BECAUSE THEY'RE ABOUT
THE DS AND I AM REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER I WOULD
LIKE TO TANK THANK THE
LEGISLATURE AND LEGISLATIVE
STAFF ON THEIR HARD WORK AND
CRAFTING A BUDGET THAT PROTECTS
OUR CHILDREN IN THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES WITH
RESPECT TO DISTANCE LEARNING
AND LEARNING A LOT OF THESE
REQUESTED THAT STRATEGIES AND
BEST PRACTICES. BE TARGETED TO
OUR MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS
INCLUDING ENGLISH LEARNERS AND
TO A LANGUAGE LEARNERS DUE TO
THEIR UNIQUE INSTRUCTIONAL
NEEDS WE ARE CONCERNED
REGARDING THE FLEXIBILITY
PROVIDED REGARDING
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES WE HAVE
HEARD FROM PARENTS OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS BAD INTEREST
INSTRUCTION PROVIDED TO THEIR
CHILDREN VARY WIDELY DEPENDING
ON THEIR SCHOOLS FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS STUDENTS THIS MAY BE A
DETRIMENT TO THERE WE SEE
ADEQUATE CUP AND SEVEN
STRUCTURE. INCLUDING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE LANGUAGE
PROFICIENCY ENGLISH LEARNERS
REQUIRE LIFE. DIRECT
INSTRUCTION. AWFUL WITH THEIR
TEACHERS YOU KNOW. FOR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT WELL.
WE'VE GOT STOMPER AND OR A
POUND REGARDING THIS
FLEXIBILITY THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE TO SIXTEEN. MR TERRA
MEMBERS ANY ONE BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES
REPRESENTING SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND
PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE FACILITIES
AND THE STATE. APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE LEADERSHIP
AND PUTTING CORD A BUDGET THAT
ATTACKS CRITICAL HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICE PROGRAMS IN
PARTICULAR WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE REJECTION OF PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX- INTERMEDIATE CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED. THE
HOUSE OF HEATHER MEDI CAL RATES
FOR A FEW THOUSAND EIGHT NINE
AND HE'S PROPERTY SIX ARE
ESSENTIAL AND ALLOWED BECOME TO
CONTINUE TO STAY OPEN THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE TO EIGHTEEN.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JOSH ON
WALLENSTEIN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO
TWO ITEMS FIRST- MODIFICATIONS
TO THE CAPTAIN TRADE PROGRAM
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE
WHO HAVE PREVIOUSLY TESTIFIED
IN OPPOSITION- ALSO- IN
OPPOSITION TO THE INCREASE IN
STAFFING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
GEOLOGIC ENERGY MANAGEMENT
DIVISION- WHICH MIRRORS THE B.
C. P. THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WITH TRUE ON MAY FOURTEENTH-
CAL JAM- HAS DOUBLED IN. SIZE
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS MUCH OF
WHICH FIT THE HOUSE JUST
PROPOSE WHEN AB ONE HUNDRED ONE
EIGHT NEW STAY. AT A PRICE TAG
OF TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR- WHICH IS A YOU KNOW
AS I SAID A 40% INCREASE IN
STAFFING AND CAL JAM- I'LL NOTE
THE ACCOUNT JIM HAS OVER THE
PAST FIVE BUDGET YEARS- BEEN-
EXPERIENCE A CHRONIC VACANCY
RATE OF SEVENTEEN PERCENT. THE
EFFICIENCIES THAT CAL JIM COULD
SHE BY PRESENTING YOU ALL WITH
A VACANCY REDUCTION PLAN WOULD
GO FAR- TO ENSURING THAT
EFFICIENCIES ARE MET AND YOUR
WITH THE GOALS ARE MET THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN THE PROPOSAL- CHIP
BUT HAS ALSO OFFERED- THE
RESOURCES AGENCY CAL JAM. AS
WELL AS YOUR COMMITTEE. AN
ALTAR PROPOSAL I WON'T GO INTO
DETAILS HERE. BUDGET TO LET YOU
KNOW WE HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE
PROPOSAL FOR YOU TO REVIEW-
THANKS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
NEXT DEADLINE. FIFTY FIVE ZERO.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS
TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT A CAP AND
TRADE ITEM IN THE BUDGET WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
PROVISION TO REQUIRE AND
RESOURCES BOARD TO CONDUCT A
BILL MAKING RECORDING CAP AND
TRADE. IN THE BUDGET IS
ANATHEMA GETTING A PROGRAM IS
VERY SUCCESSFUL IN DOING ITS
JOB AB DESIGNED BY THE LEAD THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ACHIEVE STATE.
AND FLASH MISSION AND ARE STATE.
OUR VISION IS PROUD OUR MEMBER
A PROUD BE A PART UNDER THE
CURRENT PROGRAM DEVELOPED BY A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF LEGISLATORS
TO IMPROVE THE AIR WE BREATHE.
AND WE OPPOSE ANYTHING THAT
SIGNIFICANT POLICY ITEM IN THE
BUDGET WHICH WILL HAVE FAR
REACHING IMPLICATIONS AT A TIME
WHEN OUR ECONOMY SO DESPERATELY
NEEDS TO OUR COPPER. THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE TO TWENTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS WHEN
THE CAMARO WITH THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK WE'D LIKE TO THINK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR APPROACH
TO PRESERVING THINKING THAT AND
SUPPORTIVE PROGRAM INCLUDING
THE NAVIGATORS PROGRAM THE
BLACK AND CAN HELP PROGRAM THE
MAINTENANCE OF THE ADULT DENTAL
BENEFIT THE MENTAL HEALTH
EQUITY FUND AND HELP FOR ALL
UNDOCUMENTED SENIOR WE JUST ASK
FOR THAT HELP FOR ALL YOUR THE
EXPEDITED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE NOW THE POPULATION IN
GREATEST NEED RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NEXT. TO TWENTY
ONE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CARE
MEMBERS THANK YOU DON'T ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION. THE LEGISLATURE'S
PROPOSAL THAT PRIORITIZE THE
FUNDING I THANK YOU AND WE
OPPOSE THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED 10% GENERAL FUND
REDUCTION IF YOU ASK IF YOU
STUDENTS AND GRADUATES WILL BE
KEY TO STATE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
IN ADDITION TO GET PAID THE
PORT THE USE OF RESERVE FUND BY
TO GET. OFF THE ANY GENERAL
FUND REDUCTION YES THEY ALSO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDING FOR STUDENT
INSTRUCTION HELLO DOUBLE
TRAINING AND EUIPMENT
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
RECENT ANNOUNCEMENT. REGARDING
ONLINE. ALL THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE TO TWENTY FOUR. HELLO
I'M BACK TO RE READ THE POOREST
SENIORSTECHNOLOGIES BUT A
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
WE HAVE MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY AND ELOQUENTLY TALKED
ABOUT THE SOCIAL CONSEQUENCES
OF THE ELIMINATION OF THE PEARL
OUTPATIENT CLINIC SO I KNOW I
SEE NO NEED TO REPEAT THEM
HOWEVER I WISH TO ALTER CHIU
THE MEMBERS THAT CLOTHING
CALLED OUTPATIENT CLINIC WILL
BE A DIRECT VIOLATION OF THE
FEDERAL COURT ORDER OF JULY
TWENTY NINETEEN IN COLEMAN CASE
COURT DOCUMENT NUMBER SIX TWO
ONE FOUR THEREFORE. THE
OPERATION OF PEARL OUTPATIENT
CLINIC IS SANCTIONED BY THE
FEDERAL COURT THANK CLOSING THE
PROGRAM WILL BE AN INVITATION
FOR A BARRAGE OF LAWSUIT
AGAINST THIS STATE SO MUCH MORE
THAN A BUDGETARY ISSUE THIS IS
A LEGAL AND LEGISLATIVE ISSUE
WHICH WILL BE VERY TAXING ON
THE STATE BUDGET PLEASE MAKE A
NOTE OF THIS I URGE YOU NOT TO
CLOSE P. SEE PRO OUTPATIENT
CLINIC. THANK YOU. MAC LINE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. HI MY AGE
CERVANTES AND- OF WALKING ON
ASSEMBLY PEOPLE- AND I'M WITH
THE PLOW OUTPATIENT CLINIC AND
I AGREE- WITH MY COLLEAGUES WHO
JUST WELL DOCTOR RESERVOIR IF
YOU GOT A GREAT JOB AND BOB MY
WONDERFUL CALLING OFF SO WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT I HOPE
WE CAN ABOUT THE LIFE OF
EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON IN
OUR COMMUNITY. HOW ARE WE A
LIMóN AYE WELL OUTPATIENT
CLINIC WOULD PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR OUR
COMMUNITY WITH ALREADY KNOW
BEFORE DOMINANTLY OF BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE WHAT ARE WE SAYING
AND THEN SORRY WE'RE GOING TO
CUT PUBLIC HOW TO I'M NOT ALL
THAT I HOPE DOCTOR THEN WE CAN.
THINK ABOUT BEFORE THEY TAKE
THEIR POSITIONS SOME AWAY FROM
PARKING THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE TWENTY. GOOD LUCK
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL CAN'T OF
THE CHURCH PROVISIONAL. WE
APPRECIATE THE LET RECOGNITION
OF THE AND OF THE IN KOBE NINE
RISK ABOUT HOW HE AND ARE WE
RESPECT ALSO REQUEST INCLUSION
OF FUNDING CUTBACKS OVER TWENTY
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT REDUCTION
AND THE FUNDING IS CRITICAL TO
SUPPORT EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACHES TO PROVIDING
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES- AND
CONTINUITY OF SERVICES FOR THE
POPULATIONS WE SERVE AND
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO CHEATING
ARE THE TYPE OF PUBLICLY YOU
REHABILITATED OUTCOMES THAT WE
ALL DESIRE- WE ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. OF. THAT AND
APPRECIATE THE TIME TO COMMENT
TODAY. NEXT DEADLINE TO TWENTY
SIX. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS COREY SO
THEY'LL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE THE
HARD WORK OF THE COMMITTEE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HE
HAD TO SAY AS PART OF THE
COUNTY FAMILY URGES THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
TO FULLY BACK FILL LOS
REALIGNMENT REVENUES THAT
SUPPORT VITAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PUBLIC SAFETY PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN REALIGNED TO THE
COUNTIES. THIS IS FUNNY AS YOU
KNOW FUNDS IMPORTANT PUBLIC
SAFETY PROGRAMS INCLUDING
AROUND PROGRAMMING AND
TREATMENT OF SUPERVISED
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE NEEDED
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE COUNTIES
ARE ON THE FRONTLINE OF KOBE
NINETEEN RESPONSE WE RECOGNIZE
THE ACTION TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS
NINETEEN NINETY ONE REALIGNMENT
BUT URGE FURTHER ACTION TO
PROTECT TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT. AND A VITAL PUBLIC
SAFETY PROGRAMS THAT IMPACT THE
HUMAN BEINGS IN OUR CARE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. NEXT DEADLINE TO
TWENTY NINE. PRINTER MEMBERS OF
THE KIDDING AROUND WELL ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE
CALLING TO SUPPORT REINSTATING
CRITICAL POSITION THAT CALTRAIN
THAT ARE NEEDED FOR WORKING
CURRENT LAW THANK YOU FOR THAT
IT ALSO LIKE TO ENCOURAGE YOU%
TO CONTINUE PURSUING STRUCTURAL
CHANGES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TALKED ABOUT THE JUST CONROL
THE CHANGES WILL HELP RECTIFY
STRUCTURAL FINANCIAL DOCUMENTS
AS WELL AS IMPROVED PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT SO HOPING TO CONTINUE
THAT CONVERSATION WITH YOU OUT.
AND FINALLY AND WE'RE RIGHT AND
IN SUPPORT OF THE LANGUAGE
REQUIRING AIR BE TO INITIATE A
ROLL MAKING ON THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM THERE ARE
STRUCTURAL ISSUES AND THE
PROGRAM THAT DIRECTLY RELATED
ON THE PERFORMANCE AND THE
OPTION NOW IS. THE RIGHT TIME
TO ACT THANK YOU. NECK DEADLINE.
THIRTY EIGHT. GO AHEAD NINE ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. OVER THE NEXT
NINE MONTHS TO THIRTY ONE. YES
HI GOOD AFTERNOON I REMEMBER.
THE HIGH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICT ASSOCIATION I
WE SUPPORT THE RESTORATION OF
FUNNY. IN DISTRICT AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS
MAINTAINING THE FINANCIAL
FUNDING ADDITIONALLY WE
APPRECIATE MAINTAIN A FIFTY
NINE AND MANY PARENTS NINETY
FUNDING SPECIAL DISTRICTS WERE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR THAT YET YES
AND THE LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AND
WE- APPRECIATE BUT THIS
CONCLUSION THAT HERE. ORDER THE
AUGMENTATION TO HELP AFTER AT
THE- BINDING AS A FINAL GOODBYE
NEEDED FINE TO SUPPORT LOCAL
GOT. THAT EMERGENCY. AND
FINALLY WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OPPOSED WILL HAVE BEEN
WITHDRAWN FOR THE CRIME TWENTY
BOND WE CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE TO THE BOARDING
CONSIDERING ONE. FOCUS ON
CLIMATE RESILINCY WHERE WE
ACKNOWLEDGE A SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMIC IMPACT OF COVER
NINETEEN RESPONSE. WE BELIEVE
IT'S FUNNY WOULD ALLOW SHOVEL
READY CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS TO STIMULATE LOCAL
ECONOMY PLAN DANCING CLINICAL
INCREASING RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES OF THE CALIFORNIA
CAN BE PREPARED. TO GET
CONNECTED AFTER THANK YOU. NOW
DEADLINE. ONE OH EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PANEL AGAINST
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT YOUR EFFORTS
ARE IN OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS IN DEALING WITH THE
CHALLENGING BUDGET AND WE
SUPPORT YOUR PROJECTION ON THE
EIGHT POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
A PROPOSED CUTS TO PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING IN THE
MAIN ADDITION CHECK A PROPOSAL.
SPECIFICALLY WOULD SUPPORT A
CONTINUATION OF THE AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISIO- INTO THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEAR A SCHOOL ARE STILL FACING
RE OPENING CHALLENGES AND
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE DIFFERENCE
OUR STUDENTS WE ALSO FOR WHAT
THE SOLUTIONS PROPOSED
SYNDICATE CUTS SCHOOLS
INCLUDING FLEXIBILITY- DUE TO-
OUR ENSURE THAT WOMEN ON
CONCENTRATION GRANT FUNDS. I
CONTINUED TO GO TO BE INTENDED
STUDENTS OF WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE THE VISION TO
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR OUR AFTER
SCHOOL EDUCATION FIFTY PROGRAM
AND CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS IN YOUR BUDGET OUR
PACKAGE AND LASTLY WE SUPPORT
YOUR FUNDING THE STATE
PRESCHOOL AND CHILDCARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES WE URGE YOU
TO CONTINUE TO KEEP FEDERAL
FUNDS STUDENTS AT CUTS IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE
TO. HI MY IS DOUBLE YOUNG AND
THE COLLEGES WITH DIVISION OF
JUVENILE JUSTICE AND ON BEHALF
OF MY COWORKER I WANNA STRONGLY
URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THE CLOSURE
DJJ WITHOUT NEEDED GAIN
EXISTENCE JUDGES WILL HAVE
OPTIONS FOR VIOLENT ACCEPTED
THEM TO ADULT PRISON WITH ALL
THE STATE'S WITH ADULT
OFFENDERS AND THE RETURNTHE
COMMUNITY WITH MORE CRIMINAL
SOPHISTICATION AND WHAT
PROBLEMS. UNDER THE CURRENT
PLAN MANY OF THE CURRENT DJJ
YOUTH WILL NEED TO GO TO PRISON
AS THEY CANNOT COMPLETE THE
TIME BY TWENTY ONE IF YOU DID
PROVIDE INTENSIVE HUMAN
SERVICES- VIOLENT YOU FAIL THAT
COUNTY AND ALSO HAVE A LIFETIME
THE TRAUMAS NEEDING INTENSIVE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. PLEASE
RECONSIDER CLOSURE. DJJ THANK
YOU. NEXT CENTER. TO THIRTY
SEVEN. TWO THIRTY SEVEN YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU MY NAME IS
SET UP ARE THERE SOME I'M WITH
MATERNAL AND CHILD HEALTH
ACCESS FROM LOS ANGELES I WHAT
I LIKE TO THINK-EVERYONE FOR
INCLUDING THEIR HELP NAVIGATOR
FUNDING IN THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
PLEASE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
HEALTH NAVIGATORS WHO NOT ONLY
AND ROLL THOUSANDS AND TO
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE BUT
TROUBLESHOOT THOUSANDS OF CASES
WHERE THE MEDICALLY FRAGILE AND
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHO FACED AREAS TO
HEALTH CARE. NOW MORE THAN EVER
PEOPLE NEED OUR HELP HEALTH
CANADA HEALTH KILLER NAVIGATORS
ALSO ARE CONNECTING PEOPLE TO
PROGRAMS THAT EIGHT AND IMPROVE
THEIR LIVES SUCH AS NUTRITION
HOUSING MENTAL HEALTH D. B. AND
OTHERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
DEADLINE. TO THIRTY EIGHT. YES
THANK YOU CHAIR MY NAME IS
LANCE FERRIS I WORK WITH AND ON
BEHALF OF THE PAROLE OUTPATIENT
CLINIC I'M IMPLORING YOU TO
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT TO
PAROLEES RE INTEGRATING INTO
THE COMMUNITY I'VE BEEN WITH
THE P. O. C. FOR FOURTEEN YEARS
WE WORK VERY STRONGLY WITH. THE
SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL FORENSIC
POPULATION COMMUNITY MENTAL
HEALTH ALTHOUGH THE MEANWHILE
ARE NOT OFTEN TRAINED AND IN
FACT THEY OFTEN CHERRY PICK
THEIR CLIENTS WE DON'T DO THAT
WE ARE THE FIRST LINE OF
DEFENSE NOT ONLY FOR PUBLIC.
SAFETY BUT ALSO FOR DIRECT
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT FOR THE
FORENSICALLY ILL MENTALLY ILL
HIGH RISK SEX OFFENDERS WE
IMPLORE THAT YOU CONTINUE WITH
OUR FUNDING FOR THE PAROLE
OUTPATIENT CLINIC THANK YOU SO
MUCH. EXT TO THIRTY SIX. SURE
MEMBER ONE WITH THE WHITE MAN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF MANIFEST
MEDIC ALERT THE STATE'S LARGEST
NOT FOR PROFIT HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE WE WANT TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE SPECIALLY
DR ADAM WOULD LIKE HIS DAPPER
REJECTING THE PROPOSED
REDUCTION TO THE HOUSE CALVET
PROGRAM MANY MEN IN THE CALVET
PROGRAM RECEIVED A NINETY ONE
FEDERAL MATCH OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S ACTION ON THIS
ITEM ACTUALLY SAY THE STATE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
LOCAL DESPERATELY NEED THE DATA
INSIDE PROVIDED BY THIS PROGRAM
IN ORDER TO RESPONSIBLY OPEN UP
THE ECONOMY BALLING THE CO THAT
CRISIS I THINK YOU HAVE FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS ITEM AND FOR
ALL OF THE OTHER MY DECISIONS.
IN PROGRESS THANK YOU. MAX
DEADLINE TO FORTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR SHARE MEMBERS
MARTY GUERRERO REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF YOUR OUR RECOMMENDATION TO
RESTORE THE CHILD WELFARE CHILD
SUPPORT CAL WORK AND CHILDCARE
REDUCTIONS THAT WERE PROPOSED
IN THE MAY REVISIONS IT WOULD
DEFINITELY HELP THE VULNERABLE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING A GREATDEMAND IN
THIS PANDEMIC AND ALSO IN- IF
THE CURRENT UPRISING WITH THE
RIOTS IN THE- GROUP
DEMONSTRATION. AT THEIR VERY
MUCH INDEED ALSO- VERY
APPRECIATIVE WITH THE BAND-
SUPPORT THAT WE HAVE- ACHIEVED
IN BEING ABLE TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS UP PROJECT WILL
KEY A BEEN A VERY EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND THE LIKE TO ON MY COMMENT
WITH THE PREVIOUS WITNESS YOUR
RECORD FROM THE CORPORATION IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE. TO FORTY ONE. HI
MY NAME DR EDWARDS WITH THE
DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
I'M CALLING TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE CLOSURE OF DJJ DJJ GIVE
CHILDREN AND SECOND CHANCE IN
LIFE WHICH THEY DID NOT GET IN
THE FIRST PLACE. WITHOUT THAT
WE WILL LOSE THE INCREDIBLE SEX
OFFENDER TREATMENT PROGRAM AND
THEY WILL END UP IN PRISON WE
DO NOT WANT BY THE END OF THE
RIVER BECAUSE THEY WILL NOT
RECEIVE THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED AGAIN I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
OPPOSE THE CLOSURE DJJ. NEXT
DEADLINE TO FORTY THREE. NINE
TO FORTY THREE GO AHEAD HE IS
THAT ME YES THE DESK I HAD. IN
PROGRAM THAT MEANS YES GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY OKAY MY NAME IS
NATALIE O'BRIEN AND- I'M A
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
AND I SERVED A LICENSE. SAN
LUIS OBISPO PAROLE IN NORTHERN
SANTA BARBARA PAROLE. AS THE
THERAPIST WE WORK IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE
PSYCHIATRIST WHO TELEMATIC
CATION AND PROVIDE CONTINUITY A
MENTAL HEALTH THERAPY WITH
PSYCHIATRIC MEDICATION COUPLED
WITH VARIOUS WAYS OF COUNSELING.
WE HELP RE ENTER GREAT. THE
POPULATION THAT ARE COMING FROM
PAROLE I MEAN FROM PRESENT. TO
RE ENTER ANALYST DAVE- POSITIVE
BUT THAT THE WAY. THIS ALSO. IF
HELP TO NOT IN AND DAY. COUNTY
HEALTH CLINICS IN THE
OVERCROWDING OF COUNTY JAIL.
PLEASE RECONSIDER THE
ELIMINATION OF PO'S SEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
NEXT DEADLINE TO FORTY EIGHT.
HI MY NAME MICHELLE MOM WITH
LET CALIFORNIA COALITION
APPEARANCE IN THIRTY FIVE
ORGANIZATIONS WITH STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA
CHAMPIONING EIGHTY FIVE NINETY
EIGHT FOR BOTH CHAMBERS WITH NO
VOTE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE THAT
THEY SHOULD ESCAPE THE BILL
CURRENTLY ON POTS WE THANK THE
LEGISLATOR TO KEEP THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO
STAND WITH THE MOST ACCURATE
DEFINITE HARTIGAN CHILDREN BY
INCLUDING HEARING AID PROGRAM
THE JOINT BUDGET. AS YOU ENTER
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
NEWBORN. AFFECTED BY SIX MONTHS
OTHERS WHO NEED TO HEAR THEIR
PARENTS TALK READING THING IN
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN WHO NEED TO
HEAR THEIR TEACHERS AND
CLASSMATES ONLINE TO BE. ABLE
TO ATTEND SCHOOL THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MAC FELT LINE TO FIFTY
ONE. HELLO THIS IS ANDREW MY
WEDDING IS STATE PAROLE AGENT
IN THE SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES- THERE IS NO SUBSTITUTE
OR IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE ON
SITE MENTAL HEALTH CARE FOR
PAROLEES IN CRISIS. AGENTS ARE
SIMPLY TOO BUSY TO FACILITATE
THE TRANSPORTATION OF PAROLEES
THE OFF SITE CRISIS
INTERVENTION. THE POORLY
OUTPATIENT CLINIC IS A
CRITICALLY INVALUABLE RESOURCE
THAT SIMPLY CANNOT BE
DUPLICATED. IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR THANK YOU. NEXT IN LINE
TO FIFTY THREE. HI MY NAME IS
THERESA VELLA CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORKER AT THE PAROLE OUTPATIENT
CLINIC IN SACRAMENTO AND I'M
HERE TO OPPOSE THE ELIMINATION
OF THE PEEL THE FOR ALL THE
SAME REASONS AS MY FELLOW
SOCIAL WORKERS HAVE SO
ELOQUENTLY ARTICULATED. BUT
MOSTLY FOR THE MENTALLY ILL
PROBABLY THAT ARE RELEASED IN
THE STATE HOSPITAL AND FOR THE
POORLY THAT ARE ON THE CUSP OF
BEING GRAVELY DISABLED AND A
DANGER TO THEMSELVES AND
OTHERS. WE ARE THEIR BACK FOR
ME ARE THERE OUTLET PLEASE
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE TO ASSIST
AND ADVOCATE FOR THEM THANK YOU.
AND NEXT DEADLINE TO THIRTY
FIVE. HI MY NAME IS ANTHONY
LIAM WITH THE LONG BEACH
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES I URGE THE COUNT- THE
CHAIR TO CONTINUE SUPPORT OF
THE NAVIGATOR PROGRAM AS
CALIFORNIA COMES OUT OF HIS
NINETEEN CRISIS AS WELL AS THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN OF JOB
LOSSES. LARA ROLE IS MORE VITAL
THAN EVER TO HEAR CALIFORNIA.
USE CONTINUES OF ALL THE
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM WE NOT ONLY
HELP PEOPLE WITH ACCESSING
CAMPUS CONNECT TO OTHER
RESOURCES WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU. LAST. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
OPERATE ANYBODY ELSE ON THE
LINE. OKAY HEARING NINE FOR THE
OPERATOR ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE PUBLIC
COMMENT APPRECIATE. I'M GONNA
FINANCE ONLY- FOR STICKING WITH
US THROUGH THIS HEARING AND
AGAIN VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
THE NEXT COUPLE DAYS AS WE WORK
TOWARDS PASSING A ON TIME
BALANCED BUDGET WITH THAT WE
WILL ADJOURN BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE SIX.